TODAY WE ARE HAVING A JOINT
HEARING ON HYDROGEN. THE HEARING
ROOM IS OPEN FOR ATTENDANCE OF
THIS HEARING WE ARE ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC ATTENDING THE
HEARING IS REQUESTED TO WEAR TO
IS IT COURAGE TO WEAR A MASK IF
YOU LIKE BUT HOPEFULLY AT LEAST
YOU ARE ALL VACCINATED. OR WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY BY BIZ
VISITING THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE
I KNOW THAT ANY WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THAT YOU SUBMIT TO THE
COMMITTEE WILL BE CONSIDER
PUBLIC COMMENT AND MAYBE READ
INTO THE RECORD OR REPRINTED.
EVERYONE IS ENCOURAGED TO WATCH
THE HEARING PERMITS LIVE STREAM
ON THE ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE YOU
CAN TESTIFY IN PERSON HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM OR BY USING OUR
TELEPHONE SERVICE EACH MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES
TO COMMENT STARTING WITH THOSE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO ARE
HERE IN THE ROOM. TO USE OUR
TELEPHONE SERVICE THE NUMBER TO
CALL IS 877-692-8950 SEVEN AND
THE ACCESS CODE GET YOUR PENS
READY IS. THIRTEEN FIFTEEN FORTY
TWO OH TWO THAT INFORMATION IS
ALSO ON OUR WEBSITE. FOR
WITNESSES CALLING INTO THE PHONE
LINE YOU'RE GOING TO BE PLACED
INTO A QUEUE UNTIL YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE MUTE YOUR DEVICE
WE WHEN IT'S YOUR TURN TO RE
FOUND DISTORTIONS IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT
916-319-2890 THREE. AND OUR
STAFF WILL TRY TO HELP YOU.
FINALLY THE ASSEMBLY HAS
UNFORTUNATELY WITNESSED A NUMBER
OF DISRUPTIONS TO COMEDIAN FLOOR
FOR SEEDINGS IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS. WE WILL NOT CON WE WILL
NOT. ALLOW ANY CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDE THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THIS HEARING. THAT DISRUPTIVE
CONTENT MAY INCLUDE TALKING ARE
MAKING LOUD NOISES FROM THE
AUDIENCE UTTERING LOUD
THREATENING OR ABUSIVE LANGUAGE
SPEAKING LONGER THAN THE TIME
ALLOTTED EXTENDED DISCUSSIONS OF
MATTERS NOT RELATED TO THE
SUBJECT OF THE HEARING WHICH IS
HYDROGEN. AND OTHER DESTRUCTIVE
ACTS TO ADDRESS ANY DISRUPTIVE
CONDUCT CONDUCT I WILL TAKE THE
FOLLOWING STEPS IF IT INDIVIDUAL
DISRUPTS OUR HEARING PROCESS I
WILL DIRECT THEM TO STOP. AND
WARNED THEM THAT CONTINUED
DISRUPTIONS MAY RESULT IN
REMOVAL FROM THIS BUILDING. I
WILL ALSO DOCUMENT ON THE RECORD
INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED AND THE
NATURE OF THE CONDUCT I AM A
TEMPORALLY TEMPORARILY HAVE TO
RECESS THE HEARING. IF THE
CONDUCT DOES NOT STOP I WILL
REQUEST THE ASSISTANCE OF THE
SERGEANTS AND EXCLUDING THE
INDIVIDUAL FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
YOU FOR YOUR COOPERATION. WITH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN THE
INFO AT INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
COULD MAKE A FEW COMMENTS AND
THEN TURN IT OVER TO VERYBODY
ELSE TO SEE IF ANYONE ELSE WANTS
TO COMMENT. SO THE PURPOSE OF
TODAY'S HEARING IS TO HIGHLIGHT
THE POLICY ISSUES RELATED TO THE
PRODUCTION AND USE OF HYDROGEN-
LAST YEAR. I WAS HONORED TO BE
ABLE TO ATTEND THE CLIMATE
CHANGE CONFERENCE THE COP IN
SCOTLAND IS ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
REPRESENTATIVES AND HYDROGEN WAS
A VERY LARGE TOPIC OF
DISCUSSION- I WOULD NOT JUST
FROM THE U. S. DELEGATION BUT
FROM DELEGATIONS AROUND THE
WORLD. AND THE LEGISLATURE HAS
MANY CONSENT CONF A
CONSIDERATIONS AS WE NAVIGATE
OUR WAY TO A ZERO EMISSION AND
CARBON NEUTRAL FUTURE AND
CERTAINLY HYDROGEN WILL PLAY A
ROLE IN THAT- BUT WE ALSO NEED
TO PROCEED WITH CAUTION TO
ENSURE THAT THE TRANSITION FROM
FOSSIL FUELS AND INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINES IS A
SUSTAINABLE AND EQUITABLE ONE.
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
TO STATE AGENCIES TASKED WITH
ENSURING THAT WE MEET THE
STATE'S ENERGY PRODUCTION AIR
QUALITY AND CLIMATE GOALS AND
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO HEAR FROM
STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE USING
HYDROGEN AS AN ENERGY SOURCE FOR
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES TRAINS AND
OTHER AND USES. AND FINALLY
WE'LL HEAR FROM A GROUP THAT IS
THINKING CRITICALLY ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ASPECTS OF
HYDROGEN PRODUCTION AND USE. AND
I'M VERY HONORED THAT IT'S NOT
JUST THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE THAT'S LOOKING AT
THESE ISSUES IT IS OF COURSE OUR
SISTER COMMITTEE THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE THAT'S
TASKED WITH CLEAN ENERGY AND AIR
QUALITY IN ALL THINGS
ENVIRONMENTAL. AND THEY ARE HERE
WITH US TODAY A COLD HOLDING
THIS HEARING AND SO I WOULD LIKE
NOW TO TURN THIS OVER TO MY- CO
CHAIR THREE OF US. THANK YOU
CHAIR FRIEDMAN THANK YOU TO
MEMBERS OF BOTH COMMITTEES FOR
BEING HERE WITH US TODAY- I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TAKE A DEEPER DIVE- INTO
HYDROGEN POLICY. BEFORE WE GET
FURTHER INTO THE POLICY AND
BUDGET SEASON THIS YEAR.
HYDROGEN IS PROMISING. OF
PARTICULARLY AS A REPLACEMENT
FOR DIESEL AND IN HARD TO
ELECTRIFY APPLICATIONS BUT HOW
HYDROGEN IS PRODUCED IN USE
MAKES A SIGNIFICANT. DIFFERENCE
AND ITS ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT AND
EMISSIONS BENEFITS RELATIVE TO
FOSSIL FUELS AND OTHER
ALTERNATIVE FUELS. I'M EAGER TO
LEARN MORE TODAY FOR MORE
WITNESSES ABOUT THE BENEFITS AND
COSTS OF VARIOUS FORMS OF
HYDROGEN PRODUCTION. AS WELL AS
POTENTIAL AND USES. TO THE
EXTENT THE LEGISLATURE INVEST IN
HYDROGEN. WHETHER THROUGH POLICY
OR BUDGET IT IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE MAKING
PRACTICAL INVESTMENTS FROM AN
ECONOMIC STANDPOINT. AS WELL AS
THAT THE INVESTMENTS ARE
CONSISTENT WITH OUR LONG TERM
CLIMATE ENERGY AND AIR QUALITY
GOALS. THANK YOU CHAIR FRIEDMAN
THANK YOU TO TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE ON FOR ORGANIZING THIS
I'M VERY EXCITED I'M TO JOIN YOU
TODAY. THANK YOU AND NOW I'D
LIKE TO SEE IF ANY OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE ANY
REMARKS I'D LIKE TO MAKE BEFORE
WE MOVED TO OUR PANELS. OR ANY
MEMBER WHO IS SITTING WITH THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY THANK YOU AND WE
ARE JOINED TODAY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ALEX LEE AND STEVE
BENNETT THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING
HERE. SO WHAT I WAS KALRA HI
JOSH- SO OUR FIRST PANEL IS ON
STATE GOVERNMENT IN HYDROGEN
POLICY AND I'D LIKE TO IN
WELCOME OUR FIRST SPEAKER SURE
DAVID HAAS CHILD OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION.
AND WE CAN SEE. HI THANK YOU
CHAIR FRIEDMAN AT YOUR RIVAS
GOOD TO BE WITH YOU MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR HAVING- CHILDREN
OFTEN I JOIN YOU TODAY- MY
ADVISER CAN RIDERS ON AS WELL.
YEAH DOING MY SLIDE SO LET ME
JUST START WITH THE QUESTION
WHAT IS HIGH IT IS A- ODORLESS
COLORLESS TASTELESS- NONTOXIC
HIGHLY COMBUSTIBLE GAS IT DOES
HAVE A ROLE TO PLAY IN OUR CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE I'M JUST TO SET
THE TABLE A LITTLE BIT FOR. THE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF HYDROGEN THAT
WE SEE IN THE MARKET TODAY
THERE'S GREAT HYDROGEN WHICH IS
REALLY HUNDREDS OF PRODUCED FROM
FOSSIL FUEL FEEDSTOCKS WITHOUT
CARBON CAPTURE THAT'S AT THE
POINT OF PRODUCTION. HI NOT
TODAY GLOBALLY ACCOUNTS FOR
ABOUT 95% OF HYDROGEN IN
PRODUCTION TODAY. THEN THERE'S
BLUE HYDROGEN WHICH IS HYDROGEN
THAT'S PRODUCED FROM FOSSIL FUEL
FEEDSTOCKS. WITH CARBON CAPTURE
THE BOARD PRODUCTION. BOB AND-
THAT CAN SOME- IT'S NOT ALL OF
THE OF THE- NATION'S AND THEN
FINALLY- THERE'S GREEN HYDROGEN.
WHICH ENCOMPASSES A BUNCH OF
CARBON NEUTRAL PRODUCTION
PATHWAYS INCLUDING ELECTRICAL
ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN WHICH IS
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS POWER TO GAS
WHICH IS THE CONVERSION OF
ELECTRICAL POWER. INTO GASHES
ENERGY- OUR AND- THERE'S OTHER
4 DEGREES HYDROGEN- THAT CAN BE
DONE. AS WELL SO THOSE ARE
ROUGHLY THE THREE TYPES THERE
ARE SOME DIFFERENT COLORS YOU
KNOW ABOUT BLACK HUNDRED WHICH
IS AT THE CORE PINK IDEAS AND
FOR NUCLEAR BUT THESE ARE THE
THREE BIG ONES- AND SO THE COST
POSITION YOU CAN SEE ON THE
RIGHT OF THE SLIDE. OUR GREAT
HAD HIS IS SIGNIFICANTLY CHEAPER
TODAY- RIGHT ABOUT TWO DOLLARS A
KILOGRAM- BLUE HYDROGEN- BUT TO
TWENTY SEVEN AND THEN ROUGHLY
FIVE TO NINE DOLLARS FOR GREEN
HYDROGEN ALTHOUGH- WITH SKILL
THOSE NUMBERS CAN CAN COME DOWN-
BECAUSE NEXT WHAT. SO IN TERMS
OF USE FOR HYBRID I THINK THIS
IS REALLY. THE CENTRAL QUESTION
BEFORE US I THINK IT'S CLEAR
HYDROGEN. DOES HAVE A ROLE TO
PLAY IN THE QUESTION IS REALLY
WHAT ARE THE SWIM LANES AND I
SHOULD JUST PREFACE THIS BY
SAYING THAT. WE ARE ABOUT TO DO
A CONTRACT TO FIND A HYDROGEN
ROADMAP WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS- DOES THAT WORK- FROM A
RESEARCH PERSPECTIVE IS ONGOING
BUT ROUGHLY THE THREE
CATEGORIES. THAT WE SEE HAD
GOING- LONG TERM OR TO HELP
SUPPORT THE ELECTRIC GRID- TO DO
THE HARD TO TRANSPORTATION THAT
ARE HARD TO ELECTRIFY. AND THEN
SOME HARD TO ELECTRIFY
INDUSTRIAL APPLICATIONS- JUST ON
THE ELECTRIFICATION PIZZA
TRANSPORTATION SINCE THAT'S GOT
A LOT OF ATTENTION. I DO WANT TO
COME A LEVEL SET THERE- WE- HAVE
BEEN PUTTING IN A LOT OF
INVESTMENT INTO THE SPACE. AND I
CAN TELL YOU YOU KNOW AT THIS
POINT I THINK HEAVY DUTY IS
REALLY. OF THE MUCH BETTER NEED
SH SO- BLOOMBERG NEW ENERGY
FINANCE TRACKS. NEW VEHICLE
MODEL INTRODUCTIONS- THERE ARE
PUBLIC. AND TODAY BY. TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. THEY ARE PROJECTING
FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO MODELS
OF ELECTRIC VEHICLES ARE COMING
TO MARKET OTHER ANNOUNCED AND-
THREE MODELS HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
VEHICLES OF THE PASSENGERS PICKS
LIKE TO TRACK SO. ON THE ON THE-
TRANSPORTATION SIDE WE REALLY
SEE A LOT OF MOMENTUM FOR
ELECTRIC ON PASSENGER BUT- HEAVY
DUTY WHERE THERE'S LONG HAUL
ROUTES I THINK IS IT IS
IMPORTANT EACH AND- SO A LOT OF
THE INVESTMENTS WE'RE MAKING ON
THE TRANSPORTATION SIDE ARE TO
SUPPORT THAT. WE HAVE ABOUT
FIFTY FIVE HYDROGEN. REFUELLING
STATIONS TODAY IN CALIFORNIA WE
EXPECT TO GET TWO HUNDRED BY THE
END OF NEXT YEAR. OUR STATE
GOAL. OF TWO HUNDRED BY THE END
OF. TWENTY TWENTY FIVE- NEXT
MONTH. SO SOME OF THE LIMIT OF
THAT URGES NEED TO WORK THROUGH
THE COST IS- CURRENTLY GREEN. IS
MORE. THAN GRAD TO PER- AND SO
THAT'S SOMETHING CAN COME DOWN
WITH SKILLED WITH FURTHER
INNOVATION BUT THAT'S WHERE WE
ARE TODAY- THE PIPELINE CAPACITY
LIMITS THAT EXIST. ARE ALSO ARE
A CONCERN- SO WE COULD GET UP TO
TWENTY PERCENT. THIS IS 20%
BLAND- IN THE EXISTING NATURAL
GAS PIPELINE- BUT THAT STILL
DOESN'T FULLY DECARBONISE THE
PIPELINE YOU CAN'T GO FURTHER
THAN THAT- BECAUSE OF THE
LIMITATIONS WITH THE GAS THAT'S
SUCH A SMALL MOLECULE-
DEFICIENCY IS- IS NOT IS. AS
GOOD A DIFFERENT CERTAINLY FOR
LIKE TO GET CALLS ABOUT TWICE AS
MUCH ELECTRICITY PER MILES ABOUT
ELECTRIC VEHICLE- AND THEN
THOUGH FOR EXAMPLE TECHNOLOGIES
LIKE HE PUMPED WATER HEATING.
ARE IT'S ABOUT FOUR TIMES WORTH
MISSIONS TO ELECTROCUTE PUMPED
AND HYDROGEN- THOSE
APPLICATIONS- AND THEN THERE'S
STILL YOUR POLLUTION FROM
COMBUSTION SO. HIS ARE ALL
ISSUES TO WORK THROUGH AND I
THINK REALLY THE MAIN QUESTION
HERE'S AGAIN YOU KNOW WHAT ARE
THE OPTIMAL SOME LANES. FOR
HYDROGEN AS WE GO FORWARD TO-
OUR. CLIMATE GOALS OUR NEXT
LINE. SO HOW DO CHEN VESTMENTS
THAT WE MAY- AT THE ENERGY.
TODAY ALSO IT'S OVER QUARTER
BILLION DOLLARS- AND JUST FOR
CONTEXT. THAT IS MORE. THAN IT
EVERY SINGLE NATION IN THE WORLD
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF JAPAN ON
ABSOLUTE BASIS. AND IT'S NUMBER
ONE IN THE WORLD ON A PER CAPITA
BASIS MOST OF THAT INVESTMENT
HAS GONE TOWARDS. THE
TRANSPORTATION SIDE- FOR A
REFUELING STATIONS THERE'S ALSO
BEEN SOME INVESTMENTS THROUGH
OUR EPIC PROGRAMS. AND OTHER
DEMONSTRATION- YOU KNOW
INDUSTRIAL APPLICATIONS AND SO
FORTH AND THEN IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- THAT'S PROPOSED FOR
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE YEARS A
HUNDRED MILLION. UP FOR THAT
THAT'S REALLY FOCUSED ON NON
FOSSEL HYDROGEN. HOW TO EXPAND
THE MARKET FOR THAT AND- WE HOPE
THAT INVESTMENT WILL HELP DRIVE
DOWN SO THE COST WE'RE TALKING
UP. AND IT IS IN A WE'RE DOING-
THE STUDENTS TO BILLION
ALTOGETHER FOR. OUR RECHARGING
REFUELING INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
BUDGET AND SO WE EXPECT SOME OF
THAT WILL GO TOWARD SOME OUTSIDE
REGION IN OUR- I TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM BUDGET EXCELLENT. SO
JUST TO LEVEL SET AGAIN ON THE
STATIONS- WE'RE AT FIFTY FIVE
TODAY HUNDRED BY ANY NEXT YEAR
TWO HUNDRED BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE WHICH IS THE STATE COAL-
THAT'S ANOTHER TO SUPPORT I
BELIEVE TWO HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND VEHICLES- YOU KNOW NOT
INTENDED THAT SCENARIO- ART SO
THAT IS WHERE WE ARE WE'RE WE'RE
KEEPING TO THE DIRECTIVE AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT IS A
CIRCLE- IN THE DIRECTION OF THE
LEGISLATURE HONEST BUT THAT'S
THE KIND OF. STATUS BUT DID FOR
YOU AND ROUGHLY THE COST PER
STATION IS ABOUT ONE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS- HYDROGEN. ARE
REFUELING STATION CALIFORNIA.
EXCELLENT I THINK I THINK THAT
WAS IT SO I'M HAPPY TO OPEN UP
TO QUESTIONS OR OR HEAR FROM
SURE RIGHT OFF WE CAN TAKE
pWE'RE GONNA MOVE TO THE SECOND
SPEAKER AND THEN DO QUESTIONS-
TO THE TWO OF YOU I BELIEVE. AND
I THINK THAT WE'RE OUR SECOND
SPEAKERS WILL BE CRAIG SIEGEL
FROM THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. THAT'S RIGHT
CHAIRS AND- CHAIR AND OFF WAS
UNAVOIDABLY DETAINED AT THE LAST
MINUTE AND SENDS HER REGRETS IN
REGARDS SO YOU'LL HALF AND
FRAYED TO SETTLE THE POOR
SUBSTITUTE IN ME. I'M CRAIG
SEGAL AND DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
OFFICER THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD WAY FOCUS ON
MOBILE SOURCES INCENTIVES AND
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK HERE WITH YOU TODAY.
ALTHOUGH MANY APPLICATIONS FOR
HYDROGEN INCLUDING INDUSTRIAL
ENERGY STORAGE APPLICATIONS I'LL
BE FOCUSING MY DISCUSSION TO IT
AS A TRANSPORTATION FUEL NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. FIRST I'D LIKE TO
TALK ABOUT- INCENTIVES FOR THE
USE OF GREENER HYDROGEN AS A
VEHICLE FUEL. THE LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD IS CALIFORNIA'S
MAIN PROGRAM TO ENCOURAGE THE
INVESTMENT IN USE OF LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION FUELS IN THE
STATE. IS SIMILAR TO THE
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD
WHICH ENVIRONMENTAL TARGET IS
SET WHEN WHICH WE DON'T DICTATE
THE EXACT TECHNOLOGIES TO
ACHIEVE COMPLIANCE. THIS
APPROACH ALLOWS THE MARKET TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DELIVER LOW
CARBON FUELS EFFICIENTLY AND
IT'S BEEN WORKING WELL.
INTENSITY CARRY BECOMES MORE
STRINGENT EACH YEAR WITH A
TARGET OF 20% REDUCTION IN THE
CARBON INTENSITY IN OUR
TRANSPORTATION FUELS THE TWENTY
THIRTY RELATIVE TO TWENTY TEN.
SO THE PROGRAM DOESN'T DICTATE
TECHNOLOGIES IT DOES PROVIDE A
CONTINUOUS INCREASE IN SIGNAL
FOR THOSE TECHNOLOGIES TO BECOME
CLEANER. MORE ABOUT HOW WE
DERIVE CARBON INTENSITIES FOR
FUELS IN THE PROGRAM TO THE NEXT
SLIDE. THE FIELD WITH CARBON
INTENSITIES BELOW THE STANDARD
GENERATED CREDITS. FOR FUELS
WITH CARBON INTENSITIES ABOVE
THE STANDARD GENERATE DEFICITS.
FUEL PRODUCERS WITH DEFICITS
MUST THEN PURCHASE CREDITS FROM
PRODUCERS OF LOWER CARBON
INTENSITY FUELS TO MEET THE
COMPLIANCE OBLIGATIONS. ARCAM
HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL DISPLACING
MORE THAN TWENTY BILLION WITH A
B. GALLONS OF PETROLEUM FUEL.
SINCE IT WAS ADOPTED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE BEGAN
IMPLEMENTATION IN TWENTY ELEVEN
WE'VE SEEN THE CALIFORNIA LOW
CARBON FUEL POOL INVOLVED. ONE
WITH PREDOMINATELY EHANOL IS
THE ONLY LOW CARBON FUEL OPTION
TWO AND THAT INCLUDES RENEWABLE
DIESEL ELECTRICITY AND OTHER
FUELS. LOW CARBON FUEL VOLUMES
MORE THAN DOUBLED AND THEY'VE
BEEN MANY RECENT ANNOUNCEMENTS
OF NEW FUEL PRODUCTION PATHWAYS
AND CONVERSION OF FOSSIL BASED
FACILITIES. TRAINABLE PRODUCTION
FACILITIES INCLUDING THE
CONVERSION OF EXISTING
REFINERIES TO THE PRODUCTION OF
RENEWABLE JET FUEL. MANY OF
THESE INVESTMENTS WOULD
CERTAINLY NOT BE HAPPENING
WITHOUT THE L. CFS. IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ALONE CREDIT IS
CHANGING THE MARKET WERE VALUED
AT OVER FOUR POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS. IS THE FUEL PRODUCERS
THAT MEANS THIS AND SENT IS FINE
ENTIRE BY PRIVATE INVESTMENT NOT
TAXPAYER MONEY NEXT SLIDE PLEASE
. LCF FAST RELIES ON A LIFE
CYCLE ANALYSIS IN ABOUT THE
CARBON INTENSITY SCORES THEY
MENTIONED THE FUELS THAT ACCOUNT
FOR BOTH THE DIRECT EMISSIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE FUEL. AS
WELL AS INDIRECT EFFECTS
ASSOCIATED WITH. VARIOUS CROP
BASED BIOFUELS. ALL
TRANSPORTATION FUELS VERY AND
HOW THEY ARE PRODUCED IN A COME
FROM SOURCES THAT VARY FROM
SUGAR CANE THE SOLAR PANELS TO
JERRY MINORE. WE GENERALLY
DESCRIBE CARBON INTENSITY SCORES
AS WELL TO WHEEL GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS WE USE THEM TO
CALCULATE CREDITS FOR DEFICITS
FOR TRANSPORTATION FUELS USED IN
CALIFORNIA. WELL WE'LL
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
CONSISTENT FIRST WELL THE TANK
EMISSIONS SO THINK OF FEEDSTOCK
PRODUCTION INCLUDING INDIRECT
LAND USE CHANGES IN TRANSPORT
PROCESSES WE SOMETIMES CALL
THESE UPSTREAM EMISSIONS. FUEL
PRODUCTION TRANSPORT CALIFORNIA
AND SECOND THING TO WILL
EMISSIONS THAT THESE EMISSIONS
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE USE IF YOU
WANT VEHICLES CORPORATE INTEL
COMMISSIONS AND EFFICIENCY
DIFFERENCES AND DIFFERENT
VEHICLE TECHNOLOGIES AS THE
COMBUSTIBLES. NOW FOR. FUELS
SUCH AS GASOLINE THERE'S A LOOK
AT THE EMISSIONS FROM PETROLEUM
EXTRACTION OIL WELL.
TRANSPORTATION TO A REFINERY.
REFINERY EMISSIONS
TRANSPORTATION OF FINISHED
GASOLINE TO FUEL STATION AND
COMBUSTION EMISSIONS AND
GASOLINE IN A VEHICLE. FOR
HYDROGEN THIS CAN LOOK LIKE THE
EMISSIONS ASSOCIATED WITH USING
GREAT ELECTRICITY TO CREATE
HYDROGEN VIA ELECTROLYSIS FOR
INSTANCE. AND THE TRANSPORTATION
OF THAT HYDROGEN TO A FUELING
STATION NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. TO
THE GENEROUS INCENTIVES PROVIDED
BY THE L. CFS PARTICIPATION OF
HYDROGEN IN THE PROGRAM HAS
INCREASED HUGELY SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN. TWENTY FIFTEEN ABOUT
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED GASOLINE
GALLON EQUIVALENTS OF HYDROGEN
WAS REPORTEDLY ELSIE FEST
PROGRAM. IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
REPORT VOLUME INCREASED ABOUT
ONE POINT THREE MILLION.
GASOLINE GALLON EQUIVALENTS
ANTENA THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO
TIMES INCREASE. IN RECENT YEARS
THE VALUE OF HYDROGEN SUPPLIED
IN CALIFORNIA HAS GRADUALLY
SHIFTED TOWARD LOWER CARBON
INTENSITY AND RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN. CARBON INTENSITY OF
HYDROGEN VARIES BY PRODUCTION
METHOD AND FEEDSTOCK IN
PARTICULAR HAD A GENDER RIGHTS
RENEWABLE SOURCES SUCH AS IT
GERRY BIO GAS AND ZERO CARBON
INTENSE ELECTRICITY. BETTER THAN
HYDROGEN DERIVED FROM FOSSIL
SOURCES. THE CARBON INTENSITIES
AND HAVE RANGE THUS FAR FROM
NEGATIVE TWENTY FIFTY FIVE GRAMS
FOR MAKING TOOL FOR DAIRY BIOGAS
DR TENER CHEN. TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
FOUR GRAMS TO MAKE A JEWEL FOR
HYDROGEN DERIVED FROM
ELECTROLYSIS USING ELECTRICITY.
IS THE STAND WE COMES MORE
STRINGENT HIGHER CARBON
INTENSITY HYDROGEN WILL GENERATE
FEWER CREDITS INCENTIVIZING
THEIR INTRODUCTION OF LOWER
CARBON INTENSITY SOURCES OF
HYDROGEN OVERTIME. NOW WE'VE GOT
OVER HOW INCENTIVIZE GREENER
HEADER CHEN THE TRANSPORTATION
FUEL LET'S TURN TO HOW IT
INCENTIVIZE THE USE OF THAT HAVE
REGION. IN HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLES NEXT SLIDE.
CAR HAS AN EXTENSIVE PORTFOLIO
OF INCENTIVE PROGRAMS TO IMPROVE
AIR QUALITY ENHANCE COMMUNITY
PROTECTION AND REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. WE STRIVE TO
MAINTAIN A BALANCED PORTFOLIO OF
INVESTMENTS TO MEET THE STATE'S
AIR QUALITY AND CLIMATE GOALS.
SOME OF THESE INVESTMENTS
FOCUSING NEAR TERM. REDUCTIONS
IN FULLY COMMERCIAL VEHICLES AND
EQUIPMENT. OTHERS FOCUS ON
LONGER TERM GOALS HELPING
COMMERCIALIZE AND APPLIES
INTERMISSION VEHICLES ALL OF
THESE PROGRAMS OF EQUITY FOCUS
TO THE MAXIMUM EXTENT POSSIBLE.
ENERGY VEHICLES ELIGIBLE
MULTIPLE PROGRAMS BUT IF IT
PASSED IN TECHNOLOGY ADVANCING
PROGRAMS GIVEN THAT MOST
HYDROGEN FUELS THAT. HYDROGEN
FUEL CELL TECHNOLOGY IS IN THE
EARLIER STAGES OF
COMMERCIALIZATION. THE LOW
CARBON TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
AND THE W. MITIGATION TRUST
WHICH OUTLINED IN BLUE ON THE
SLIDE. PATTERSO VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY CONTINUE TO EVOLVE
THROUGH THE COMMERCIAL ARC IT
WILL HAVE A PLACE IN OFFER
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS. NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. LET ME BRIEFLY DESCRIBE
HEDGING FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES
THAT YOU PROGRAMS I MENTIONED.
SHE ALSO VEHICLES ARE ELIGIBLE
IN ALL OF OUR CONSUMER AND FLEET
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS TODAY. THIS
INCLUDES ON THAT STEVE EUROPEAN
EACH VIP PROGRAMS FOR LIGHT AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES AS WELL AS
OUR EQUITY FOCUS CONCURRENCE FOR
ALL ROGRAM AND FINANCING
ASSISTANCE PROJECTS. TO FUEL
CELL VEHICLES OF HIGHER INITIAL
COST TODAY. I PROGRAMS OFFER
HIGHER INCENTIVE AMOUNTS FOR
FUEL CELL VEHICLES COMPARED TO
BATTERY ELECTRIC VEHICLES TO
HELP SUPPORT EARLY MARKET
INTRODUCTION. BALANCE OF THE
COST DIFFERENTIAL. AS WITH MANY
DIFFERENT. DEMAND FOR FUEL CELL
VEHICLES AND SOME OF OUR
PROGRAMS IS STILL RELATIVELY
LOW. DUE TO LIMITED VEHICLE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AVAILABILITY FOR
EXAMPLE THAT 5% OF THE CVR P.
LIKE ANY VEHICLE FUNDING. HAS
SUPPORTED FUEL CELL VEHICLES
TODAY AND THAT IS DUE ALMOST
ENTIRELY TO CONSUMER CHOICE
WHICH OF COURSE MAY CHANGE OVER
TIME. WE'VE ALSO FUNDED FUEL
CELL TRANSIT BUSES AND HYDROGEN
FUELING TO VOLKSWAGEN MITIGATION
TRUST. ME WILL BE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AVAILABLE IN THE FUTURE.
OUR PRE COMMERCIAL DEMONSTRATION
PILOT FNDING IS ANOTHER AREA
WHERE INVESTMENTS ARE REALLY
MOVING THE NEEDLE AND SPORTING
FUEL CELL VEHICLE TO POINT
DEVELOPMENT TO DEPLOYMENT. I'VE
BEEN THIS TECHNOLOGIES COME TO
MARKET SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN
COVERS FUNDED A TOTAL OF OVER
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
DEMONSTRATION PILOT PROJECTS
WITH HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
TECHNOLOGIES RECEIVING ABOUT A
THIRD OF THIS FUNDING. THIS
PROJECT TO HELP ADVANCE THE
TECHNOLOGY SO CAN PLAY BIGGER
ROLE IN A COMMERCIAL INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS IN THE NEAR FUTURE NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. ZERO EMISSION
TRUCK AND BUS MARKET HAS
EXPANDED RAPIDLY OVER THE PAST
YEARS WITH OVER ONE HUNDRED
MILES BEING AVAILABLE TODAY. OUR
MISSION TRUCKS AVAILABLE IN
EVERY WEIGHT CLASS ACROSS A WIDE
VARIETY OF LOCATIONS. TODAY IS
HERE BECAUSE I MAINLY BEING
OFFERED BY SMALLER STARTUP
MANUFACTURES NEARLY EVERY MAJOR
MANUFACTURER HAS ANNOUNCED PLANS
TO LAUNCH COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS IN
THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS. IN
TERMS OF OUR INCENTIVES THEY
CURRENTLYHUNDRED FORTY THREE
ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS AND BUS
MODELS ALL OF THE ELIGIBLE IN
THE HEAVY DUTY H. V. I. P.
PROGRAM. FOUR OF THOSE A
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL BUSES. NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. WE HAVE FUNDED
DEMONSTRATIONS AND PILOTS
INCLUDING HYDROGEN AND FUEL CELL
TECHNOLOGIES SINCE THE LOW
CARBON TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
LAUNCHED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS HAS
BEEN SPENT ON THREE FUEL CELL
BUS PILOTS TO DEPLOY TWENTY FIVE
TRANSIT BUSES THE SUPPORTING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE
TRAINING. THIS PROJECT HELPS NEW
FLYER COMMERCIALLY LAUNCHED A
FUEL CELL BUSES WHICH ARE NOW
ELIGIBLE FOR H. B. A. P. AND PW
INCENTIVES. THE PROJECTS ARE
ALSO PROVIDING OTHER TRANSIT
AGENCIES OF VALUABLE INFORMATION
IS THE TRANSITION TO ZERO
EMISSION. WE'VE INVESTED SIXTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN FIVE FUEL
CELL TRUCK DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS IN JUST LAUNCH A TWELVE
MILLION DOLLAR FUEL CELL TRUCK
PILOT IN COLLABORATION WITH CC.
ELEVEN THIRTY HYUNDAI CLASS
EIGHT DRAYAGE TRUCKS. AND WE
SUPPORTED HAD ORIGINALLY OFFERED
SECTORS WHILE ANOTHER FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR CARGO
HANDLING AND BRING OUT THE
CATIONS. AS YOU SEEN FIRST HAND
WITH A DEMONSTRATION INVESTMENTS
IN BATTERY ELECTRIC TECHNOLOGY
WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT THESE EARLY
INVESTMENTS PROVIDE A PATH TO
COMMERCIALIZATION FOR MORE HEAVY
DUTY FUEL CELL VEHICLES AND
EQUIPMENT. FINALLY BEGIN EARLY
MARKETS ACCESS FOR HEAVY DUTY
FUEL CELL TECHNOLOGIES IS
INFRASTRUCTURE. MANY AND NEED IF
CAUGHT THAT HEAVY DUTY HATTERS
AND STATIONS WILL BE INSTALLED
AND OPERATING VEHICLES EQUIPMENT
ARE DELIVERED. HER CONTINUES TO
WORK WITH ENGINE COMMISSION AND
OTHER PARTNERS TO COORDINATE
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING TO
SUPPORT ON GOING GROWTH AND
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL MARKET AND
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT
PARTNERSHIP. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
NOW FINALLY BECAUSE I WAS ASKED
TO SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS HYDROGEN
ALLOWED WITH THE THOUGHT. OF THE
CONCEPT OF HYDROGEN FUELED CARS
HAS BEEN AROUND FOR SOME TIME.
THE FIRST PRODUCTION MODEL
DIDN'T HAPPEN UNTIL TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT. WEARING ONLY NOW
BEGINNING TO SEE THEM BEING SOLD
COMMERCIALLY SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS
IS RAMPED UP STATE TIME AND THEN
ACCELERATE. FURTHER OTHER MUCH
IS BEING DISCUSSED OVER VARIOUS
COLORS OF HYDROGEN. BROWN
BLUEGREEN ETCETERA THERE'S A HER
A STICKS AND ULTIMATELY WE CAN'T
HOLD ONE TECHNOLOGY TO COMBAT
AIR POLLUTION CLIMATE CHANGE A
HIGHER STANDARD THAN OTHERS.
ANYTHING THAT IS CLEANER THAN
FOSSIL FUELS HELPS WHICH IS ONE
REASON THESE CARBON INTENSITY
METRICS HELP US SEE CLEARLY. I
BILLS THAT YOU DIFFICULT AND TOO
IMPORTANT NOT TO USE EVERY TOOL
IN THE TOOLBOX. WE MUST BE
FLEXIBLE ENOUGH TO ALLOW
TECHNOLOGIES TO IMPROVE OVER
TIME AS A PROGRAMS HELP THEM DO.
A PATIENT THAT PERTINI TO
PRESENT BEFORE THE COMMITTEE AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU- I THINK I WILL.
SEE IF ANY OF THE OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS
BEFORE I ASK MY OWN. MISTER
BENNETT SURE GO AHEAD. OKAY WILL
DO BENNETT AND THEN WILL DO
MISTER MCCARTY IN THE MISTER
KALRA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
SHARE. FRIEDMAN OF THEY JUST
MAKE A QUICK COMMENT SO THAT MY
QUESTIONS ARE NOT MISSED
MISCONSTRUED BUT I CLEARLY THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE GO
GREEN AS SOON AS POSSIBLE WE GET
TO A 100% GREEN HYDROGEN AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE- SECOND- I THINK
pIT'S REALLY HEALTHY IF WE MAKE
SURE THAT WE KEEP AS MANY AS AS-
THE CAR BUT A SPOKESPERSON THERE
JUST TO JUST MENTION THAT WE
KEEP AS MANY TECHNOLOGIES
AVAILABLE AS POSSIBLE I HARK
BACK TO THE NINETEEN FIFTIES
WHEN THE INTERNAL COMBUSTION
ENGINE COMPANIES- PURCHASED UP
THE PATENTS FOR ALL OF THE
ELECTRIC CARS. AND DESTROYED
DOES HOW MUCH DIFFERENT THE
WORLD WOULD BE TODAY- FOR THE
LAST SEVENTY YEARS WE WOULD HAVE
HAD ELECTRIC CAR TECHNOLOGY
COMPETING WITH INTERNAL
COMBUSTION TECHNOLOGY AND ALL
THE IMPROVEMENTS THAT COULD HAVE
TAKEN PLACE- SO. WHEN I ASK
THESE QUESTIONS THAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE NOT QUESTIONS THAT HAVE
ANY NEGATIVE CONNOTATIONS
TOWARDS ELECTRICITY AND BATTERY
POWERED CARS WE NEED BOTH- NOT
JUST CARS BUT IT'S IN THE HOLE
TRANSPORTATION- SECTOR- BUT MY
QUESTION- FOR- I THINK BOTH
PROBABLY SEE YOU SEE. MORE
APPROPRIATELY- THERE'S A
REFERENCE TO THE ELECTRICITY
BEING MORE THAN TWICE AS MUCH
NEEDED THREE THOUSAND KILOWATT
HOURS- FOR- TEN THOUSAND MILES
IN A BATTERY CAR- SEVEN THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED KILOWATT HOURS FOR
TEN THOUSAND MILES AND A- FUEL
CELL VEHICLE- I ASSUME THAT-
THAT THAT DATA. FROM. SIX
STANDARD IS IT THE BEST
ELECTROLYSIS TECHNOLOGY THAT'S
OUT THERE TODAY IS THAT CORRECT
. THAT PROCESS IS ESTIMATED TO
HAVE SOMEONE YEAH FOR THE
QUESTION ACTUALLY MY ADVISER CAN
RIDER DID THAT. CALCULATION CAN
ARE YOU ARE YOU ON. YES HELLO
SOME YEAH THAT THAT'S BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF STUDIES THAT HAVE
LOOKED AT THE WORLD WE- THERE
ARE A FEW DIFFERENT PATHWAYS
ACTUALLY THEY THE COMPRESSOR
METHODOLOGY IN TRANSPORTATION
AND OTHERS LARGER DIVERGENCE
ANYTHING EFFICIENTLY WHERE IF
YOU SOME OF THE QUALIFIED
PERSONS COMPRESSED WE USED TO
AND- FAVORABLY FOR THE- HYDROGEN
DISTRIBUTION THERE- BUT THERE
THAT BUILDERS EASY CALCULATION
BUT THERE ARE OTHER STUDIES
THAT- CORROBORATE- THAT.
RELATIVE EFFICIENCY. USING THE
LIQUID OR THE GAS FORM RECEIVING
GOT GREAT. BLOCKING YOUR HIGHER
OR WITH YOU LIKE WOULD WITH
MICHAEL AND MY THE NEXT QUESTION
WITH THAT IS THAT- THERE'S A
REFERENCE IN THE REPORT- AND
THIS COMPARES HYDROGEN AND
BATTERY TECH AND FUEL CELL AND
BATTERY TECHNOLOGY ON THE
ELECTRICITY NEEDED TO PRODUCE
TEN THOUSAND MILES- IS THERE A
COMPARISON OUT THERE IN TERMS OF
TOTAL LIFECYCLE- WITH THE NUMBER
OF RARE EARTHS AND- MINERALS
pEARTH MINERALS NEEDED FOR
BATTERY TECHNOLOGIES AND FUEL
CELL TECHNOLOGY AND IS THERE A
STUDY OUT THERE THAT WOULD
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF HOW MUCH.
HOW MUCH GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS WILL THERE BE IN THE
MINING OF RARE EARTH MINERALS I
KNOW WE HAVE- WE'RE VERY
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE SOURCE OF
LITHIUM BUT THERE ARE OTHER RARE
EARTH MINERALS THAT ARE ALSO
GOING TO BE REQUIRED- FOR
BATTERY TECHNOLOGY. ARE THERE
FEWER RARE EARTH MINERALS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE NEEDED FOR THE
HYDROGEN TECHNOLOGY. YEAH THAT'S
A GREAT QUESTION- SO IF YOU'LL
SELECTRIC VEHICLES USING
ELECTRIC DRIVETRAIN SO MANY OF
THEM ARE THE SAME SO FOR
EXAMPLE. DO YOU DINAMIC PRESENT
ANY- YOU KNOW IN THE BACK THAT'S
AND SO FORTH. BUT OTHERS LIKE
LITHIUM. NICKEL COBALT. YEAH AND
THE BATTERIES- DID YOU SEE
ELECTRIC VEHICLES WOULD NOT BE.
IN ALL THE I'M HAVING SAID THAT
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE BATTERY
INDUSTRY RIGHT NOW. IS A
MOVEMENT AWAY FROM- SO THERE'S
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU CAN DO IT
SPARKS JUST OPENED A FACTORY IN
AND CALIFORNIA'S DOING COBALT
FREE LITHIUM ION. AND NICKEL
FREE. ACTUALLY SO OVER TIME THE
NUMBER OF THOSE YOURS IS GOING
TO GO DOWN- I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S ANYTHING UNIQUE
OBSTRUCTING IS ANY OTHER
REPRESENTS ENOUGH FUEL CELL
VEHICLE THAT WOULDN'T BE THAT
EASY IT IDON'T I DON'T BELIEVE
THERE ARE. BUT I THINK ALL ADAMA
IS IN TERMS OF LIFE CYCLE
EMISSIONS WE SEE DRAMATICALLY
LOWER EMISSIONS FROM BOTH KIND
OF THE V. BOTH BATTERY ELECTRIC
AND FUEL CELLS THAT YOU
TRADITIONAL SUIT GAS OR DIESEL
FLOWER POWER TRUCK. AND IN BOTH
CASES THANKS TO TOOLS INCLUDING
IT CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION THE
GRAD AND THE CONTINUING LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD SIGNAL ON
CARBON INTENSITY THE SKILLS
CONTINUE TO GET LAST COVINGTON'S
OVERTIME SAYS YOUR MISSION
VEHICLE PERFORMANCE CONTINUES TO
IMPROVE. I RECOGNIZE THAT BOTH
OF THEM WITH IMPROVEMENTS WILL
HAVE FOR LIFE CYCLES I'M JUST
CURIOUS WITH THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT'S OUT THERE NOW IF YOU TOOK
FROM THE BEGINNING TO THE END
LIFE CYCLE COST YOU HAVE A- A
BIG BATTERY THAT YOU HAVE TO
DEAL WITH IN TERMS OF RECYCLING
AND- FUEL CELL YOU HAVE A MUCH
SMALLER BATTERY. TO ALMOST THAT
OF THE BATTERY THE SIZE OF IN A
PASSENGER CAR AT THIS POINT
TIME- SO RIGHT NOW IN COMPARISON
DO YOU HAVE- IS THERE AND NOW
THIS IS THIS IS RIGHT NOW TOTAL
LIFECYCLE. COST IT DO DO WE HAVE
THAT KIND OF ANALYSIS. TO COOK
OR COMPARISON BETWEEN THE TWO.
YES WE DO AFTER AND THERE'S A
USEFUL STUDY- THE INTERNATIONAL-
COMMITTEE AND CLEAN TECHNOLOGIES
THAT OFFER. GENERALLY SPEAKING
SENIOR DRAMATICALLY IMPROVED-
BICYCLE FISHING SEES THAT STUDY
WHICH IS FROM TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
I'M EVEN IN THE U. S.'S POWER
GRANTED WHICH TENDS TO BE STILL
RELATIVELY HIGH CARBON INTENSITY
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA. IT'S
IMPROVEMENTS ON THE ORDER OF ON
IT 60% OR MORE. THAT'S TRUE
WEALTHY SPEAKING FOR FUEL CELL
TECHNOLOGY AS WELL I THINK IT'S
ALSO IN THAT SERVE SIXTY
PERCENT. LEVEL I'D BE HAPPY TO
MAKE SURE THAT STUDY SHARED BACK
OVER TO YOU- THROUGH OUR
LEGISLATIVE SO IF I CAN JUST BE
CLEAR LACK LIFE CYCLE OF A OF A
FUEL CELL POWERED BY. THIS A
HEAVY DUTY TRUCK LIFECYCLE FUEL
CELLAR CELL FUEL CELL POWERED
HEAVY DUTY TRUCK LIFE CYCLE OF A
BATTERY POWERED HEAVY DUTY TRUCK
. WHICH ONE HAS THE BETTER
OVERALL LIFECYCLE IMPACT. YOU
KNOW I THINK I SEE SIMILAR
BENEFITS USING FUEL CELLS AND
BATTERIES BUT GET ARE PRETTY
HEAVILY ON THE USE ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. AND THEN- AND THEN IF
I COULD JUST ONE OTHER QUESTION-
I NOTED YOUR REPORT THAT THE
BIDEN MINISTRATION HAS-
ALLOCATED EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
TO TRY TO CREATE FOR REGIONAL-
CENTERS. OUT THERE- IT TO CREATE
GREEN HYDROGEN SO GREEN HIDES A
CLEAN HYDROGEN HUBS OF FOUR OF
THEM IN THE UNITED STATES SO-
NOT GREAT AT MATH BUT THAT'S TWO
BILLION DOLLARS EACH I THINK OF
THIS EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS- WHAT
ARE THE THINGS THAT WE CAN DO AS
A LEGISLATURE TO TRY TO HELP
MAKE SURE CALIFORNIA. IS ONE OF
THE SITES OF THOSE FOUR REGIONAL
HUBS. SO YEAH THANK YOU SO MANY.
PEOPLE WE SPOKE ABOUT THIS A FEW
WEEKS AGO I WOULD. YEAH WE'RE
VERY INTERESTED TO SUPPORT
FEDERAL DOLLARS FROM INSTRUCTORS
PACKAGE COMPANY CALIFORNIA FOR.
EVERYTHING THAT'S IN THERE
EVERYTHING FROM CARBON CAPTURE
TWO TWO BATTERIES TO HOW DO YOU
. AND WE HAVE TO GT JIM WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS I THINK
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO. HAVE A
CONVENING- OF THE LEGISLATURE
BRING TOGETHER DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS OR WORKING IN THE
SPACE TO TRY TO GET ALIGNMENT.
BONTA OVERALL CALIFORNIA
PROPOSAL- THAT'S CERTAINLY MY
HOPE I BELIEVE THAT. BY THE
MONEY WILL GO FARTHER STE- IF
IT'S IN CALIFORNIA JUST GIVEN
THE- EXPERTISE THIS YEAR IN
STATE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU CHAIR. THANK YOU AB ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS FOR SHARING THIS AND
JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON- THE
QUESTIONS YOU MISTER BENNETT.
SAID ABOUT ASK ABOUT THE
ECONOMICS OF THE STATIONS AND
THEN JUST COMPARE SING- BIG
PICTURE THE FUEL CELL HYDROGEN
AND THE ELECTRIC CARS BUT YEAH
BIG PICTURE WE ALL REALIZE THAT-IN ORDER TO TACKLE OUR CLIMATE
CHANGE GOALS ARE GHG REDUCTIONS
AND- AIR POLLUTION THROUGHOUT
OUR COMMUNITIES AT. THAT'S WILL
NEVER TALK ABOUT FRANKLY. IS-
GLOBAL SOURCES AND SO GETTING-
CLEAN CARS. ON THE ROAD IN
GETTING POLLUTING CARS OFF THE
ROAD IS YOU KNOW NOT ROCKET
SCIENCE BUT THE DETAILS ARE WHAT
MATTER AND I KNOW THIS IS NOT
EASY OR ELSE WE WOULD DONE THIS
A LONG TIME AGO AS WAS NOTED.
CERTAINLY THE COST OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS SOMETHING THAT
THAT IS HIS CAME OUT CAN WE GO
BACK TO THAT SLIDE THE YOU HAD
WERE AT AND IN CALIFORNIA TODAY.
VERSUS WHERE YOU WANT TO BE FOR
IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE THE
NUMBER OF STATIONS. I THINK IT
WAS I THINK WAS THE LAST LINE OF
MARKET YEAH. YES SIR CAN YOU
TELL US FIFTY OR SO IN
CALIFORNIA FIFTY FIVE TODAY
HUNDRED BY THE END OF NEXT YEAR
YES I KNOW THERE'S ONLY ONE HERE
AND SECRETARY I BELIEVE THAT'S
OVER IN WEST SAC RIGHT. AND YOU
SEE YOU SEE WHAT'S THAT YOU SAID
A COST OF ONE. IT'S ABOUT ONE
ONE POINT TWO MILLION IS THE
PREPARATION FOR. YEAH THAT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE IF IT'S A ONE
POINT SOMETHING MILLION PER
STATION. AND WE'RE PUTTING IN IN
THE BUDGET WHAT IS IT AGAIN OR
WAS IT ON THIS. PACKET HERE. HOW
MUCH STATE MONEY. WE'RE PUTTING
A HUNDRED MILLION. FOR THESE.
WELL THE HUNDRED MILLION IS FOR
GREEN HYDROGEN RICH AT LARGE THE
I SHOULD SAY YOU KNOW THAT MONEY
WE'VE SPENT MANY OF THESE ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF FIFTY FIVE
REPRESENT THE ONES THAT ARE
COMPLETED BILLABLE RIGHT NOW FOR
USERS BUT THERE'S A BUNCH MORE I
GUESS THAT'S MY QUESTION IS TO
GET TO FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED OR TWO
HUNDRED HOW MUCH ARE WE ASSUMING
THAT THE GOVERNMENT WHETHER IT'S
STATE OR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
NEEDS TO PUT UP FRONT FOR THE
ONE MILLION PER STATION BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THE STATION'S GOING TO
GET SOME MONEY FROM THEIR
CONSUMERS MAY BE SIGNED OFF TO
MAKE IT PENCIL OUT WHICH IS WHY
WE NEED THE SUBSIDY FOR A LOT OF
THINGS WE DO SO HOW MUCH OF IT
DO WE NEED TO PUT IN THEIR PER
STATION TO MAKE THESE.
FINANCIALLY PENCIL OUT. YEAH SO
I THINK- AND- CANTOR CREEK
PLEASE CLICK THE FIVE MINUTES
REMEMBER THIS BUT I BELIEVE THAT
. THE STATE CONTRIBUTION FOR-
HUNDRED FUEL CELL STATIONS IS
SOMETHING ON THE ORDER 40% OF
THE TOTAL COST. AND ON THE TV
STATIONS IT'S ABOUT 30% SO JUST
FOR COMPARISON LEVEL TWO
CHARGING WOULD TYPICALLY BE
ABOUT TWELVE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED AND WE WOULD GIVE US
FORTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR GRANT
FOR THAT- YEAH THAT'S YOU KNOW.
THIS IS A KIND OF TROUBLES IN
OUR JUST DESSERTS ARE YOU GOING
STATIONS ARE MARKETS LIKE A GAS
STATION- BUT I BELIEVE IT'S LIKE
FOR KIDS- CRAZE THAT'S NOT RIGHT
TO YOU. THAT I BELIEVE SO BY
DEFERRED CAN IN YOUR KINGDOM
YEAH YES- ROUGHLY OVER HALF HIS
THROUGH A SOME TYPE OF THE
SUBSIDY FROM THE GOVERNMENT. AND
THEN EVENTUALLY WHEN THESE ARE
GONNA. AVAILABLE AND UTILIZED BY
THE PUBLIC ON A LARGER SCALE
IT'S LIKE A GAS STATION TODAY
WERE PEOPLE OPEN UP IN THE GET
MINOR PEOPLE PAY THEIR BILL- AND
JUST YOU KNOW MAYBE YOU COULD
JUST ENLIGHTEN US IN A IN A IN
A- LAY PERSON. WHY DO YOU THINK
IN THE LAST FIVE TO TEN YEARS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AGAIN I THINK
WE SHOULD BE TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL
SO WHETHER THEIR BATTERY PLUGIN
BY ELECTRICITY OR- HYDROGEN.
FUEL SELLERS YOU KNOW MAYBE
POTENTIALLY THERE'S SOME YOU
KNOW ZERO EMISSION FUEL THAT'S
CREATED I DON'T KNOW THAT'S NOT
THERE TODAY BUT- WHAT. WHY DO WE
THINK THAT THAT- THE HYDROGEN
HAS LAGGED BEHIND AS FAR AS
BEING PICKED UP FROM. THE
CONSUMERS AND THE MARKETPLACE
VERSUS. BATTERY ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. YEAH THAT'S THAT'S
THAT'S THE QUESTION AND I WOULD
I WOULD JUST OPEN BY SAYING OUR
FIDELITY ULTIMATELY IS TO OUR
CLIMATE GOALS SO WE'RE NOT
COMING IN WITH ANY PREFERENCE
OTHER THAN THE MOST PRAGMATIC
WAY TO REDUCE POLLUTION- AND YOU
KNOW WE FUNDED FOR A LONG TIME
ACTUALLY IT'S A BIT COLD
MEASURE. EVM STRUCTURE FEEL SOME
OF IT WHAT WHAT HAPPENED IS THE
COST OF LITHIUM ION BATTERIES
IT'S SORT OF SIMILAR TO WHAT
HAPPENED IN SOLAR WITH
CRYSTALLINE SILICON PANEL OF
SOLAR PANELS WE JUST SAW THIS
INCREDIBLE COST REDUCTIONS SO
TEN YEARS AGO WAS ABOUT A
THOUSAND DOLLARS A KILOWATT HOUR
LITHIUM ION BATTERY TODAY IT'S
ABOUT A HUNDRED TWENTY AND
THERE'S A REALLY CREDIBLE
PATHWAY TO GET DOWN TO TWO SIXTY
TO EIGHTY DOLLARS. FOR LITHIUM
ION AND SO WHAT'S WHAT HAS
REALLY DRIVEN THIS IS THAT THE-
YAMS THAT ARE MAKING THE
VEHICLES LOOKED AT THAT MASS AND
ALSO THE FACT THAT THE ELECTRIC
SYSTEM IS UBIQUITOUS THERE'S
POWER EVERYWHERE IN EVERY HOME-
WHICH IS ABSOLUTELY UNIQUE
ADVANTAGE BECAUSE IT'S ALREADY
IN COMBAT YOU KNOW HOW TO BUILD
A NEW. HIGH COLLECTED SALT
CHARGEABLE UNITED AS THE RUN IT
A SEPARATE PIPELINE
INFRASTRUCTURE- AND SO THE WE
HAVE A SONG THAT AND THEN WHAT
HAPPENS IT'S JUST BEEN
OVERWHELMING INVESTMENT IN
ELECTRIC VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY SO
EVERY MAJOR CAR MANUFACTURER IN
THE WORLD TODAY IS BUILDING
ELECTRIC MODEL AND I THINK YOU
SAW THE SUPERBOWL THERE WERE
SEVEN ADS FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLES
THAT OCCURRED ONLY TWO BEDS FOR
KNOWLEDGE OF VEHICLES FROM MY
****
OF COURSE. EVERYBODY LOOKS AT
MARKET CAP AND THE FACT THAT.
TESLA BECAME THE MOST THE FIRST
COMPANY TO. BURST KHARQAN WORLDS
OF TO BE A TRILLION DOLLAR
COMPANY- HAS KIND OF RESETTING
SO THE MARKET IS REALLY BETTER
JAMES. THE OEMS THAT ARE
FURTHEST ALONG AN EASY OPTION
CURVAS Y. THINK YOU SEE. FORWARD
NOW RISING WITH- YOU KNOW WHAT
TO DO WITH THE ELECTRIC F. ONE
FIFTY AND SO FORTH THAT'S REALLY
THE MAIN. TREND THAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING IN THE IN THE ART
INDUSTRY LAST COUPLE YEARS. AND
I THINK ALL IT OFFER IN ADDITION
TO CHURCHILL'S GOOD POINTS. ARE
IN TERMS OF WHEN THEY HEAR
SOMEONE BRING YOUR QUESTION IS
GOING FORWARD AND HOW TO THINK
ABOUT THIS. I THINK I JUST SAY
THAT NONE OF US KNOW. EXACTLY
WHAT THE PATH IS FOLKS TAKE TO
AN END OF COMBUSTION. NO OTHER
IN HEAVY DUTY OR LIGHT DUTY. SO
IT IS ABSOLUTELY TRUE AND IS
SUCH A GOOD THING THAT CAUGHT
THE PLUNGING COST OF BATTERIES
ENABLE ALL SORTS OF GREAT.
CHANGES. IN THE TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM. RALPH LOW. OF THAT. IN
OUR MARKETS. IS GET UP TO ONE
HUNDRED. THERE'S VERY LIKELY TO
BE ROLLED A RANGE OF
TECHNOLOGIES AND DIFFERENT USES
AND USE CASES IT MAY BE
DIFFERENT STORIES AND
LIGHT DUTY SECTORS. SO ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT YOU KNOW YOU SEE
IN. THE PROGRAM SO FAR IS THIS
NEUTRALITY ESTÁ TECHNOLOGY IN
THIS DESIRE TO ENSURE SYSTEMS.
ARE BROADLY AVAILABLE AND GIVEN.
RESERVES ARE MOVING FROM A NICHE
TECHNOLOGY. TO THE ANSWER FOR
EVERYBODY ACROSS MANY USES. I'M
INTERESTED TO SEE HOW THE MARKET
DEVELOPS ACROSS MANY OF THESE
OPTIONS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
THANK YOU THINK YOUR CHAIRS FOR
HOLDING THIS MEETING- I DO
BELIEVE THAT- IT'S REALLY LONG
OVERDUE IN TERMS OF HAVING THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW HOW
HYDROGEN DOES FIT INTO ZERO
EMISSION IN THE FUTURES PRICE
BUT IT APPLIES TRANSPORTATION
AND- IN LOOKING AT. THE ABILITY
TO SCALE IT I THINK THAT THAT'S
WHERE. IN THE URGENCY- TO MOVE
FORWARD AND EXPAND THE
APPLICATIONS NEEDS TO BE
BALANCED CERTAINLY WITH THE
SOURCING OF IT PARTICULARLY WHEN
YOU LOOK AT- IN OF THE GREEN
HYDROGEN VERSUS GRAY AND BLUE
HYDROGEN THINK THAT ALTHOUGH
CERTAINLY AT THIS POINT- THE-
ELECTROLYTIC PRODUCTION. IS IT
IS MORE OF A KIND OF- A MORE
INTENSIVE PROCESS I THINK THAT
WE NEED TO BE VERY CAUTIOUS
ABOUT MOVING TOO QUICKLY JUST TO
EXPAND USAGE OF HYDROGEN. BY
CONTINUING TO GOING DOWN THE
ROUTE OF USING FOSSIL FUELS TO
CREATE THE HYDROGEN I KNOW THAT
IN ORDER TO SCALE UP OF THAT AND
THAT THAT SEEMS TO BE AT LEAST
IN THE CONVERSATION AS PART OF
THE PLAN OF HOW TO GET- A LARGER
WELL. A LARGER VOLUME OF USAGE-
BUT I DO I LIKE IT AS IT WAS
DISCUSSED AND IN THE REPORT-
FOCUSING ON WHAT USES ARE MOST
OF THEM MAKE THE MOST SENSE FOR
HYDROGEN AND IT IS SEEMS AND I
AGREE COMPLETELY ON KIND OF THE
DIESEL. ON A SHORT HAUL THE
PORTS AND THINGS OF THAT NATURE
NUMBER IT'S REALLY INTERESTING
TO SEE WHAT THE PORT OF OAKLAND
IS DOING. THAT IF WE KNOW THAT
THAT'S GOOD THAT IS. THE BEST
THE MOST BANG FOR YOUR BUCK SO
TO SPEAK IN TERMS OF USING OUR
HYDROGEN AND WE CAN DO IT IN A
WAY THAT WE'RE USING. REALLY
GREEN HYDROGEN- THAT THAT.
SHOULD BE UP AT LEAST IN THE
SHORT TERM. OR MUCH OF OUR
RESOURCES SHOULD GO TOWARDS I
THINK THAT- GO PUTTING RESOURCES
INTO THE GRADING OF THE
TECHNOLOGY I THINK WE'LL
FURTHER. MOVE US AWAY FROM LONG-TERM GOALS- IN TERMS OF- ZERO
MISSION GOALS FOR OUR STATE AND
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS I KNOW THE- TECHNOLOGY
CHANGES. USUALLY WHEN
TECHNOLOGIES ARE NEWER THEY'RE
NOT AS EFFICIENT AS THEY ARE TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE TEN YEARS DOWN
THE LINE SO. I'M HOPEFUL THAT
WITH HYDROGEN IT'LL BE JUST THE
SAME AS WE SAW WITH SOLAR AND-
IN OVERSEEING THE CLUTCH OF
VEHICLES ON HAVE YOU. AND THE
ABILITY TO CREATE ENERGY TO
FUEL- IN A POLITE VEHICLE THAT
YOUR VEHICLE IS MUCH DIFFERENT.
THE ABILITY TO FUEL I'M-
HYDROGEN VEHICLES BUT I'M HOPING
THAT WITH THE INVESTMENT WITH
THE STATE INVESTMENT WE CAN MOVE
IN A MORE POSITIVE ACTION SO. I
AM. I JUST WANT TO PUT OUT THAT
I DO HAVE- SOME. CONCERNS ABOUT
. USING A- AT. THE END L. NAMAN
. TO CREATE THIS. OTHERWISE
RENEWABLE POTENTIALLY RENEWABLE
SOURCE. AND SO- BUT I'M VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THIS CONVERSATION
BECAUSE I THINK AGAIN IS LONG
OVERDUE. AND IT'S SOMETHING I
THINK WE NEED TO REVISIT. A
PRETTY REGULARLY AS TECHNOLOGY
CONTINUES TO ADVANCE AND
HOPEFULLY IN A DIRECTION WE CAN
GET MORE MORE EFFICIENT IN
CREATING. A GREEN TECHNOLOGY
KNOWN SAN JOSE WE HAD DIED AND
WILL DIE JESTERS WHAT HAVE YOU
WHICH A- MIXED RESULTS. IN TERMS
OF THE- THE BUILDING TO CREATE-
HYDROGEN BUT AGAIN EVEN THAT
TECHNOLOGY IS DRASTICALLY
IMPROVING WE SEE GREAT ADVANCES.
IN GERMANY AND OTHER PLACES WITH
THAT AND SO I LOOK FORWARD. TO
I'M KIND OF CONTINUAL. CHECK INS
REPORT BACKS ON HOW WE CAN IT
REALLY ADVANCE. THE
DISSEMINATION OF THE OF GREEN
HYDROGEN. AS OUR NUMBER ONE
FOCUS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SUMMER FONG. I THANK YOU CHAIR
STAFF WERE- FOR HAVING THIS I
JUST WANTED TO MAYBE THIS
QUESTION IS- FIRST YOU- AT THE
CDC- IN TERMS OF. WHAT PROJECTS
ARE IN THE WORKS WHEN IT COMES
TO YOU- SCALING UP HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION WHAT'S WHAT'S WHAT'S
BEING PLANNED AND WHAT WHAT ARE
THE METRICS MOVING FORWARD.
MAYBE THAT'S FOR THE CARP TO AND
I GUESS THAT THAT THAT THAT THAT
THAT THE THAT QUESTION TO BOTH.
THANK YOU SENTIMENTS SO. THE
NUMBER OF- MEASURES. WE'RE DOING
THROUGH THE- EPIC. PROGRAM
YOU KNOW IT IN TERMS OF ITS
APPLICATIONS AND SO FORTH. I'M
NOT I CAN'T GIVE YOU THE- THE
TOP OF. ITEM ON THE LIST OF.
HYDROGEN PRODUCTION- PROJECTS I
DON'T I HAVEN'T LOOKED AT THE-
STE. YEAH ALL RIGHT OFFER IN
ADDITION TO MEMBERS WE'VE HAD A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT PROJECTS IN
THIS SPACE. WHICH WE'RE HAPPY
BEING YET SHARE FURTHER BUT IN
ESSENCE WE'VE LOOKED AT
DIFFERENT SORTS OF WAYS AND TO
TEST OUT THE USE OF FUEL CELL
VEHICLES- THROUGHOUT THIS
INCLUDES FUNDING- IN BUSES
TRUCKS REYES SHUCKS IMPORTS AND
LYFT. AND WE'VE SEEN YOUR
DEVELOPMENT OF HYDROGEN FUELING
STATIONS THE CONTESTANTS AND
HEAVY DUTY USES ESPECIALLY I'M
REDUCING POLLUTION AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES SO A
LOT OF THE GOALS OF THESE
PROGRAMS ON THAT YOU'VE HEARD ON
THE FUEL SIDE IN THE LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD. THE GOAL IS TO
SEND THIS VERY CLEAR YOU'RE NOT
PRESCRIPTIVE MESSAGED HELP
ENSURING THE CARBON INTENSITY
KEEPS FALLING. BY THE TECHNOLOGY
DEMONSTRATION SIDE AND THERE IS
AN EFFORT TO FIGURE OUT HOW THIS
WORKS IN VARIOUS DEMOS IN
VARIOUS CONTEXTS WHICH ARE
SHOWING US THAT IS REALLY STRONG
AND YOU'LL HEAR AND I THINK WHEN
POTENTIAL AND HIGHLIGHT. IT'S
REALLY STRONG POTENTIAL IN HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLE IMPORT USES HIS
GIVEN THAT SO MANY OF THE
STRANGELY AT SIX BUT WAS
COMMUNITIES TO SO MUCH CUSHION
SO IT'S EXCITING TO SEE LET'S
BEGIN WITH A COCKER. CERTAINLY I
CERTAINLY- WHEN IT COMES TO
RENEWABLES I'M I'M SURELY TECH
AGNOSTIC I GUESS THE QUESTION
MAYBE S WITH IN A DIFFERENT
WAY- SO THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS- IN
THE IN THE IN HIS BUT BUDGET
PROPOSAL- WHAT WOULD THAT MONEY
BE SPENT ON. AND WHAT PROJECTS
WOULD BE FUNDED. SO THE ARE
GENERALLY CAN. FOR PROJECTS S I
CAN'T SAY SIX SIX WHAT. IN A-
BUT I WOULD SET THE UP CHEN
SPEAKING. IS THERE IS A
EXTENSIVE PUBLIC PROCESS TO
DEVELOP THE CRITERIA. FOR
PROJECTS SO AND HE'S VERY BY
PROGRAM I KNOW I LOOTED FOR
INSTANCE TO THE H. V. I. P.
PROGRAM WHICH ARE VOUCHERS- IN
THAT CASE YOU'RE JST COMING TO
LEICESTER FUNDS TO YOU KNOW.
PURCHASE A VEHICLE- IN OTHER
CASES ESPECIALLY IN CASES OF
PILOT PROJECTS WHAT WE TRY TO
DO. IS DEVELOP CRITERIA FOR WHAT
WE WANT TO SEE DEMONSTRATED
WHETHER FOR INSTANCE SAY IT'S A
BETTER APPROACH DEAD REYES TRUCK
REFUELING. OR HELPING TRANSIT
AGENCIES MOVE FORWARD AND WE ASK
FOR COMPETITIVE BIDS SO REALLY
TRY TO CREATE. AN IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE PUBLIC
AND THROUGH THESE PUBLIC PROCESS
THESE. PATHS THROUGH WHICH WE
CAN LEARN ARE COMMERCIALIZED
ACKNOWLEDGES AND THAT AS
TECHNOLOGIES BECOME MORE
COMMERCIAL. THE TENDER GRADUATE
FROM THIS BEACH HEADS INTO
PARTICULAR PROGRAMS WHERE WE CAN
ACT YOU KNOW FOLKS EQUITIES
SCALE. AND I LASTLY I NOTICED
ONE OF THE REAL FOCUSES
THROUGHOUT THOSE MORE SCALE
PROGRAM. THAT MAKING SURE WE'RE
TAKING CARE NOT JUST ABOUT BIG
FLEETS BUT A SMALL FLEET SO
MAKING SURE THAT THEY CAN
ACCESS. THIS TECHNOLOGY TO JUST
GIVEN THE DIVERSITY OF THAT
KANEMI. OKAY SO YOU. JUST ADDED
THAT SO WE TYPICALLY TRY TO LIKE
LEVEL SET OR WHERE PROCESS ISN'T
ON THE GRANTS ARE FOCUSED ON.
WHAT IS THE MOST PRAGMATIC WAY
TO LOWER THE COST OF FOR.
EXAMPLE FOR ELECTROLYTIC
HYDROGEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT
EXACTLY WHAT PROCESSES YOUR
BOOK. THE MOST PROMISE AND THEN
EVERYTHING YOU WORKSHOPS%
EVERYTHING SO WE DON'T TAKE
ACTION ON DESIGN PROGRAM UNTIL.
WE'VE GOTTEN STAKEHOLDER INPUT-
IT'S A GREAT. BUT NOW WE CRAFTED
FROM THAT. OKAY SO TERMS OF
METRIC- AND YOU MENTIONED THAT A
NUMBER OF THE GRANTS THAT YOU'RE
DEVELOPING M. IS TO ENCOURAGE
THE PURCHASE OF A OF A RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN VEHICLES SO- ANYWAY AND
I THINK YOU MENTIONED A METRIC
WHERE YOU WE WENT FROM THIRTY
FIVE HUNDRED- GASOLINE
EQUIVALENT- PRIVILEGED TO NOW
ONE POINT THREE MILLION- SO HOW
MANY L. HYDROGEN VEHICLES OR HOW
TO IF YOU SELL VEHICLES ARE ON
THE ROAD RIGHT NOW AND HOW IS
THAT GROWING OVER TIME. SAYS
GRAHAM CONSIDERABLY IT'S REALLY
TAKEN OFF MY DUTY I THINK THAT
THERE ABOUT NINETY SIX HUNDRED
VEHICLES WE FUNDED THROUGH
RECEIVE YOUR P. IN TERMS OF
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES THERE A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER BEHIND THE
CURVE. SO I'M AWARE FOR INSTANCE
ABOUT THIRTY DRAYAGE TRUCKS WE
FUNDED WITHIN TRANSIENT OTHER
THIRTY SIX TRUCKS IN TECHNOLOGY
DEMONSTRATION LAXER TALKING TENS
OF VEHICLES. BUT THEY'RE REALLY
IMPORTANT STARTING POINTS THAT
SERVE TRACKS ABOUT THE
CONVERSATION YOU'RE HAVING
EARLIER EACH OF THESE PROGRAMS
THE COMES TO CONSUMER PURCHASES.
YOU'RE TALKING IT OUT. AT
TECHNOLOGY A GNOSTIC PROGRAM
WHERE CONSUMERS ARE DRIVING THE
CHOICE. AND HENCE YOU KNOW THESE
OVER TEN THOUSAND. I THINK SOME
OF MY STAFFERS AND AROUND TWELVE
THOUSAND. VEHICLES IN CONSUMER
PROGRAMS VERSUS AND BEGINNING TO
SEE A FUEL CELL VEHICLE ROLLOUTS
AND HEAVY DUTY SPACE. IS YOUR AT
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THAT FOR
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE THE
EMPHASIS IS WHICH- I GUESS THAT
WAS AS MORE THAN HIS BEEN ON
LIGHT DUTY AND THAT'S WHY
THERE'S BEEN MORE VERSES HEAVY
DUTY OR- HOW DO YOU- I GUESS HOW
DO YOU ASSESS AS SHOULD WE BE
FOCUSING ON HEAVY DUTY OR SHOULD
WE- PRIORITIZE. OUR DO YOU- HOW
DO YOU LOOK AT THEM. WELL I
THINK THIS IS A TECH DEVELOPMENT
CURVE STORY YOU KNOW LIKE THE
VEHICLES AND GENERALLY BAN
SOMEONE AHEAD OF THE CURVE IN
TERMS OF ITS ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES GENERALLY AND THAT'S
TRUE FOR BOTH BATTERY AND FUEL
CELL- AND THAT'S RAPIDLY
BEGINNING TO CHANGE IN PART
THROUGH. STATE INVESTMENT
DOLLARS SO YOU KNOW IT WILL STAY
TRUE AND AT LEAST IN A CURRENT
STATUS THE LIKE TO THE PROGRAMS
THOSE THEIR FUEL NEUTRAL. AT AT
HOLDEN AND WE CAN FOLLOW THAT
CHOICE WHICH I THINKMAKES SENSE
AS WE SEE REGULATORY WRAP UP TO
A 100% IMPORT TO STAY FLEXIBLE.
AND HEAVY DUTY. THAT TECHNOLOGY
IS RAPIDLY DEVELOPING YEAH WE
REALLY SIZE BATTERY ELECTRIC
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES START TO
TAKE OFF WILL BEGIN TO SEE THE
SAME THING THE FUEL CELL. AND WE
THINK ABOUT GETTING ALL THE WAY
TO ONE HUNDRED BILLION PORTED TO
STAY SOMEWHAT FLEXIBLE GIVEN
THESE DIFFERENT USE CASES ONE
THING I WOULD SAY OVERALL THOUGH
IN THIS IS I THINK PART OF THE
OVERALL BUDGET PROPOSAL THIS
YEAR. A STRONG FOCUS IN HEAVY
DUTY IS QUITE IMPORTANT THERE
FEWER OVERALL VEHICLES WHICH IS
ONE REASON THE NUMBERS WIND UP A
BIT LOWER. THEY'RE REALLY
PLEADING VEHICLES IN THE TEND TO
EXPOSE ON EACH A COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY ACUTELY IT'S ALSO A
PLACE WHERE FOR DRIVE TECHNOLOGY
DEVELOPMENT WE SEE IT SPREAD.
INTO LIGHT DUTY IN BACK AND
FORTH SO I GUESS WHAT I'M SAYING
HERE IS THE SORT OF PORTFOLIO
APPROACH REALLY SPEAKS TO
SEVERAL THINGS IT SPEAKS TO
RELATIVE VOLUMES OF VEHICLES IN
THE MARKET. IT SPEAKS TO WEAR
TECHNOLOGIES ARE ON THE CURRENT.
IN SPEAKS TO THE NEED AT LEAST
IN MY VIEW- TO HAVE PROGRAMS
THAT CAN FIND. OUT AT DIFFERENT
POINTS ON THAT CURVE SOME
PROGRAMS THAT ARE HELPING
COMMERCIALISE TECHNOLOGIES SOME
THAT ARE FOCUSED. SPECIFICALLY
ON EQUITY NEEDS OUR SMALL FLEET
NEEDS. AND SOME THAT ARE
DRIVING. DEVELOPMENT ONE THING
THAT IS REALLY STRIKE ME ABOUT.
PROGRAMMING GENERAL. YOU DO SEE
THAT SUCCESSFUL MARRIAGE BETWEEN
THE INCENTIVE PROGRAMS. AND
REGULATORY PROGRAMS SUCH THAT
EACH OF THESE CADRES. YOU SEE
TECHNOLOGY IS MOVING FROM
INITIAL BEACH HAD ALL THE WAY TO
MARKET. AND PART OF WHAT WE HOPE
TO DO AND WHICH WE REALLY VALUE-
AND- YET. GUIDANCE FROM IN THESE
COMMITTEES FROM THE PUBLIC- IS
YOU KNOW TRYING TO MAINTAIN THAT
BALANCE. SO WE'RE TRYING TO- BE
PRESENT FOR ALL PARTS OF THAT
TRANSFORMATION. SO IN TERMS OF-
SCALING UP- DO YOU HAVE INTERNAL
METRICS WERE WITH ORACLE
POLITICAL GOAL POSTS WHERE YOU
YOU WANT A CERTAIN NUMBER OF AYE
CHEN VEHICLES. YOU KNOW EACH
YEAR BEING SOLD OR OVER DUBBED
BY A WINDOW I MEAN DO YOU GET
DOWN TO THAT THAT LEVEL OR- ARE
YOU JUST TRYING TO JUST GET MORE
PEOPLE TO BUY ARJUN VEHICLES.
WHAT WILL WE DO TRACK PRETTY
CLOSELY ACTUALLY- IN CONTRACTING
WITH VARIOUS PARTS OF FROM THE
CALIFORNIA FIRST YOU SYSTEM TO
TRACK. YOUR PROGRAM PERFORMANCE
ACROSS ALL THESE INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS AND THE METRICS TO
TRACK VERY LITTLE BIT BY PROGRAM
I MEAN FOR INSTANCE IF YOU'RE
FOCUSED ON A PILOT PROJECT. YOU
MIGHT BE LESS INTERESTED IN
TOTAL VOLUME I'M MORE INTERESTED
IN WHAT WE'VE LEARNED IN THE
KNOWLEDGE IS PRODUCED AND
EXPERIENCE OF THE USERS. WHICH
FOR SOME THE OTHER PROGRAMS WERE
REALLY INTERESTING UNDERSTANDING
NOT JUST VEHICLE VOLUME AND
WE'RE INTERESTED AGAIN IN ALL
KINDS OF THEIR MISSION VEHICLES
IN ITS GETTING OUT OF COMPASSION
THAT MATTERS. OF COURSE WE ALSO
TRY TO TRACK WHICH SORTS OF
TECHNOLOGIES ARE TAKING OFF FROM
A USER EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN SO
THESE YOU KNOW INVOLVES TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND EVERYTHING FROM
HOW PEOPLE ARE EXPERIENCING.
REAL ABILITY THE CHARGING
NETWORK- TO- YOU KNOW THE
EXPERIENCE OF THE VEHICLE AND
HOW THAT SCALES BETWEEN FOLKS IN
DIFFERENT INCOME LEVELS CLASSES
ECCENTRICITY LET DIFFERENT
METRICS THE GOING TO THAT'S AND
WE TRY TO KEEP LEARNING I KNOW
THAT'S A- BIG PICTURE ANSWER
SURE THAT'S IN PART BECAUSE
THERE'S SO MANY DIFFERENT
PIECES. NO I'VE I APPRECIATE
THAT- ENTER ENTER IN TERMS OF
SCALING UP HYDROGEN PRODUCTION
HOW DOES THAT HOW DOES THAT
LOOK- MOVING FORWARD. FOR THE
FUTURE- I. TELL GO I CAN. TO
SOME OF THE- MY STAFF JUST AS-
PER SO WE- SET. MILLION IN OUR
TRANSPORTATION PROBE INTO
HUNDRED PRODUCTION FAR THIS TO.
PLANTS EXPECTED TO COME ONLINE.
BY NEXT YEAR AND THEN THE NOPE
IT JUST WENT UP FOR THREE MORE
WHICH WILL BE RENEWABLE HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION PLANTS. OKAY THEN
THAT'S SO THAT'S IN THE IN NEXT
TWO THREE YEARS YOU YOU EXPECT
EXPECT FOR AT FIVE FIVE FIVE
PLANNED TO GIVE TO RIGHT NOW AND
THREE IN THE WORKS. CORRECT AND
THEN JUST TO YOUR EARLIER
QUESTION DOES NOT KNOWLEDGE THIS
GOAL ON. FUEL CELL VEHICLES THE
GOVERNOR'S CALL YOU DON'T GET A
FIVE MILLION- THESE ARE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE SAY COMPASS.
ELECTRIC AND FUEL CELL BUT AGAIN
AS CREEK. POINTED OUT WE HAVE
ABOUT TEN THOUSAND. ALSO
VEHICLES THE IN THE ELECTRIC IS
WE'RE AT TODAY. OKAY NO I MEAN
I'M JUST TRYING TO GET A- YOU
MADE A LOT OF TIMES I THINK. YOU
KNOW WE HEAR THE NOMINAL NUMBERS
I GUESS FOR MYSELF I WILL SAY
THAT THE GOAL I WAS JUST KIND OF
CURIOUS FROM AN AGENCY
STANDPOINT WHETHER YOU HAVE. YOU
KNOW PERCENTAGES OF WILL UP A
PERCENTAGE OF CARS ON THE ROAD
THAT YOU WANT TO BE AYE CHEN
THAT YOU WANT TO HELP ELECTRIC
THAT YOU WANT TO BE- WHATEVER
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S THERE. SO I
BRIDGE PUT NOTE. YEAH NO I MEAN
THAT'S REALLY THIS IS WHERE THAT
AT SOME POINT THE MARKET HAS TO
JUST DECIDE OUR FACILITIES TO
THE- GOALS THAT WE WERE IT'S-
INTERMISSION THOUGH HARD TARGET
THAT WE DO HAVE. TO GET CARDS AS
THE VEHICLES WE DO THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND A HARD TARGET
THAT WE DO HAVE- THE DIRECTION
WE'RE CALLING. FOR EXECUTIVE
ORDERS TO GET TO TWO HUNDRED.
YOU'LL SELL STATIONS. DID
KNOWLEDGE. WAS ARE GOING TO GO
AS TO HOW. HYDROGEN FUEL TANK
PLANTS ARE HOUSING. YOU'LL STILL
DIGITAL BY TWENTY FIVE CORRECT
AND WE'RE FIFTY FIVE TODAY. YEAH
A PART OF I THINK THE SUCCESS
WE'VE HAD HONESTY'S BEEN SOME
LIKE GNOSTIC AS TO THE
TECHNOLOGY TYPE THAT'S NOT
ALWAYS TRUE I GET A MENTION THIS
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS WE'RE
TRYING TO LEARN AND
COMMERCIALIZE. WHEN IT COMES TO
HELPING FLEET OWNERS MAKE
CHOICES- REALLY WANT N CHOOSING
BASED UPON THE NEEDS OF THEIR
FLEET AND THAT ALSO ENCOURAGES I
THINK MANUFACTURERS DEVELOP AND
RANGE OF TECHNOLOGIES VEHICLE
TYPES. SO THE HOPE HERE REALLY
IS FOR THE STATE'S INVESTMENT
DOLLARS TO DO THE THINGS THE
PRIVATE SECTOR DOLLARS CAN'T IN
TERMS OF BOTH CREATING STRONG
REGULATORY SIGNAL AND THEN ON
THE INCENTIVE SIDE. I'M
PROVIDING FOR THE PRETTY HIGH
DEGREE OF UNCONSTRAINED CHOICE
OR WE CAN THAT RECOGNIZES THAT
PARTICULARLY CREATING PATHS FOR
SMALLER OPERATORS SMALLER
BUSINESSES AND REDUCE EXPOSURE
TO COMMUNITIES THAT ARE ON THE
FRONTLINE- HAS PARTICULAR VALUE
TO US- AN- BY LAST QUESTION AND
A CURIOSITY YOU MENTIONED-
MARKET DYNAMICS WHAT IS. WHAT IS
THE MARKET TELLING YOU WHAT IS
WHAT ARE CONSUMERS SAYING WHAT
ARE THE BARRIERS TO ADOPTION
RIGHT NOW IS IT IS IT
INFRASTRUCTURE. IS IT THE REBATE
IS IT I MEAN IS IT A COMBINATION
OF BOTH IS IT IS WHAT WHAT WHAT. DO YOU SEE RIGHT NOW AND IN
TERMS OF THE NUMBERS. SO THE
FIRST SAYS PRETTY GOOD NEWS
UNLIKE YOU DECIDE TO PROP HEARD
THE MILLIONS OF FLORIDIANS
AVERAGE JUST SOLD AND WE'RE UP
TO LIKE EIGHTY SEVEN. THAT
MODELS AVAILABLE. TO PART OF
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS HELPING
PEOPLE RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS A
REALLY DIFFERENT MARKET THAN
THEY MAY PERCEIVE IT TO BE FROM
THE TIME THE LAST BY THE
VEHICLE. AND HELPING THEM
RECOGNIZE THAT THESE ARE
GENERALLY. CHEAPER VEHICLES TO
ROT SO HUGE DEMAND RIGHT FOR-
VEHICLE REBATES YOU KNOW IT'S
LIKE FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
ALMOST SENIOR P. REBATES AND
GONE OUT CLEAN CARS FOR ALL IS
GOING UP. WE DO SEE A LOT THERE
AND SIMILARLY HUGE DEMAND. IN
BOTH H. FIFTEEN CORE PROGRAMS
FOR THESE VEHICLES AND PEOPLE
LOVE THEM YOU KNOW WHEN THE
DRIVER. SO THAT'S BAD AT LEAST
IS NEVER THE ISSUE THEY DON'T
BREAK DOWN THE LAST LONGER
ESPECIALLY WITH THESE- CRAZY
TIMES THEY'RE A LOT CHEAPER TO
FUEL. SO THOSE ARE ALL WINS-
PEOPLE OF COURSE I WAS A
QUESTIONS ABOUT RANGE WHICH IS
ALWAYS GOING OUT THERE QUESTIONS
ABOUT FEELING WHICH IS SEIZING
THE WANT TO SPEAK TO BUT THAT'S
ALSO EVER EXPANDING. REALLY FEEL
LIKE WERE RIGHT ON THE CUT CARE.
WHERE WE'VE SEEN THIS SORT OF.
MAJOR EXPANSION. MOVING
THOROUGH. AND THAT'S INCREDIBLY
FORWARD YOU KNOW A LOT OF HOW
WE'VE CALIBRATED THESE PROGRAMS.
IS TO CONTINUE SENDING
CERTIFICATES STRONG COST SIGNALS
TO IMPROVE THE FUELS. ARMIES HAD
BEEN TRYING TO. CONTINUE TO
BUILD OUT. YOU KNOW APPROPRIATE
INFRASTRUCTURE CC WILL SPEAK TO.
AND THEN ON THE LIGHT DUTY AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES SIDES.
MAKING SURE THAT THIS CHANGE
WORKS FOR SMALL FLEETS YOU KNOW
WORKS FOR EQUITY COMMUNITIES.
AND ALSO THAT THE GOOD NEWS GETS
OUT IS ON THESE HUGE PRIVATE
INVESTMENTS. AND BEGIN TO REALLY
TAKE OFF BY THEM THE FURNITURE
HELP SHIELD ON ANYTHING HE IS
HERE. I THANK YOU FOR THE
INFORMATION IF I COULD JUST ASK
OUT IF YOU COULD GIVE US THE
INFORMATION OF WHERE THOSE
PLANTS ARE GONNA COME THOSE-
THREE ADDITIONAL ONES I'D-
APPRECIATE IT. THANKS VERY MUCH
. YEAH WE'LL DO THAT THANK YOU
SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER LEE.
THANK YOU CHAIR I HAD HOPED THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG WOULD
EVENTUALLY ASK MY QUESTIONS BUT-
I HAVE ONE SIMPLE QUESTION
BEFORE- FOR CC I THINK WOULD BE
MOST EFFICIENT. WELL FIRST OF
ALL I'M VERY EXCITED THAT
POTENTIAL PERHAPS TO HAVE
ANOTHER A TECHNOLOGY OUT THERE
WE NEED I THINK ALL OPTIONS ON
THE TABLE HERE. BUT IN A
DISCUSSION ABOUT GRAY BLUE AND
GREEN HYDRANT DO WE KNOW RIGHT
NOW IS A STATE WHAT IS THE BREAK
UP PERCENTAGE OF HYDROGEN BEING
PRODUCED IS A MAJORITY ONE
VERSION OR THE OTHER. YES WE DO
SO- UNFORTUNATELY GRANT HUNDREDS
IS ONLY ABOUT 1% OR SO OF THE
HYDROGEN BEING. PRODUCED IN
CALIFORNIA- AND- YOU KNOW
BECAUSE POINT THE VAST MAJORITY
BUDGET BOTH DOMESTICALLY IN
CALIFORNIA AND GLOBALLY IS- FROM
FOSSIL FUELS. AND THAT'S JUST A
FUNCTION OF COST I MEAN IT'S
BEEN ON THE MARKET IS VERY IN
TUNE TO THAT AND AS I MENTIONED.
THE COST IS ROUGHLY TWO DOLLARS
A KILOGRAM WERE THE GRAY
HYDROGEN AND IN THE FIVE TO TEN
NINE DOLLARS FOR A GREEN TODAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I AM LITERALLY
COLOR BLIND SO I COULDN'T TELL
IF I COULD SEE IT. I WOULD SAY
THAT- THAT LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD PROGRAM I'VE TALKED
ABOUT BEFORE HELPS THE SEAT THAT
FURTHER SO ONE THING THAT IS ONE
REEMPHASIZE THAT HAVEN'T
CONTINUED SIGNAL. OUR PRODUCTION
PROTHESIS REDUCE CARBON
INTENSITY. SHOULD HELP TRACKING
PRIVATE INVESTMENTS WHERE WE
ONCE IN. BUT I STILL BE ABLE TO
TELL WHAT COLOR THEY ARE. I'LL
NEVER BE A FIGHTER PILOT. OKAY
YOU KNOW I HAD A QUESTION
SIMILAR TO MR LEE'S QUESTION ON
THE HYDROGEN CLASSIFICATIONS BY
COLOR I BELIEVE OF THE SPEAKER
FROM CARB MENTION THAT RIGHT NOW
WE'RE NOT FOCUSED ON ANY GOALS
BY CLASSIFICATION- PRODUCTION
METHOD. YOU KNOW BUT EACH
HYDROGEN PRODUCTION METHOD HAS A
DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
SO I WAS CURIOUS YOU KNOW WHEN
DO YOU THINK WE WOULD BE READY.
OR WHY YOU SAID THAT LIKE RIGHT
NOW THAT WE SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON
THE PRODUCTION METHOD OF
HYDROGEN. WHAT THIS IS AND HOW
WE THINK ABOUT THE CARBON
INTENSITY OF IT I DON'T WANT FOR
A SECOND TO SUGGEST THAT WE
THINK ABOUT PRODUCTION MANY FEEL
THAT WE DON'T NEED TO THINK
ABOUT OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL.
PIECES OF THE PUZZLE NOT ALL OF
WHICH ARE ENCOURAGED TO REVIEW
SOME ARE YOU KNOW WE'RE
DISTRICTS AND RATHER REGULATORY
BODIES. IT JUST COMES TO THE
CARBON INTENSITY PUZZLE THAT'S
ONE WHERE OUR PARTICULAR TOOL
NOT LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD AND
SOME OF HER RELATED POLICIES.
HAPPENS TO REALLY BE FOCUSED ON
THE PARTICULAR PATHWAYS FOR
PARTICULAR FUEL AND ITS CARBON
INTENSITY. IT JUST MEANS THAT
RATHER THAN USING THESE
HEURISTICS OF COLOR WE CAN TO
REALLY BE FOCUSED ON WHAT'S TRUE
ABOUT THIS PATHWAY WHICH DOES
HAVE THE BENEFIT OF PROVIDING
THAT I SHARED SIGNAL. IN ACROSS
THAT MARKET TO CONTINUE REDUCING
INTENSITY REGARDLESS OF HOW IT'S
PRODUCED BUT AGAIN THAT IS TO
SAY THERE ARE ALL SORTS OF THE
THINGS WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT
INDUSTRIAL AIR POLICY DON'T
SUGGEST OTHERWISE. JUST HAPPENS
TO BE WITHIN THE SORT OF GHG.
FRAME ON THE TROLLEYS. SO I HAVE
A I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS AND
THANK YOU ALL FOR TAKING SO MUCH
TIME- FIRST AND I THINK THIS IS
FOR CC BUT EITHER YOU CAN.
ANSWER IT- GIVEN THAT. THE
INDUSTRY ESTIMATES THAT THE
POPULATION OF FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLES WILL BE SIXTY ONE
THOUSAND BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN. SHOULD WE BE
SPENDING. THIS MONEY ON HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE. ARE WE GETTING
AHEAD OF THE MARKET HERE. WITH
THE FUELING STATIONS ALL ASSET
TO CC. SO THAT IS THE CHOICES
ABOUT BECAUSE WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING. AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
THAT THAT SETS THE TWO HUNDRED
STATION GOAL AND THAT'S THE
MESSAGE AND SO WE ARE AND IN
FACT EIGHTY EIGHT HAD DIRECTED
AT THAT CARVED OUT. OF YOU KNOW
PORTION OF OUR FUNDS FOR FUEL
CELLS SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
REALLY IS A STEP BY THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE. ITHINK AT
THE END OF THE DAY YOU KNOW
THERE ARE. GOING TO BE-
EVOLUTIONS IN THE MARKET WHERE-
YOU KNOW. WALDRON EACH FOR FOUR
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGY CALPERS
BECOMES REALLY CLEAR- I WOULD
SAY TEN YEARS AGO WAS NOT CLEAR
AT ALL WITH THE FUTURE PASSENGER
VEHICLES. WAS GONNA LOOK WORK-
AND I THINK THAT'S THAT'S BEEN-
OVERWHELMINGLY TRENDING TOWARDS
HIS I THINK. YOU KNOW SIMILARLY
WITH WITH HYDROGEN YOU KNOW
LOOKING AT OTHER THESE OTHER
NATIONS AND THEIR STUFF IT'S
REALLY HARD TO ELECTRIFY- THAT
I'M TAKING YOU KNOW SB NATION-
CERTAINLY LONG HAUL AVIATION.
ELEMENTS YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
RAIL LOCATIONS OF INDUSTRIAL
POWER SECTOR- WHERE WE CAN
REALLY SEE. AN ISSUE BUT YOU
KNOW THIS POINT WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING DIRECTIVE THAT WAS
GIVEN TO US SOME YEARS AGO
BURKE. GOING TO- STAY ON COURSE. UNTIL WE GET TO TWO HUNDRED.
LET ME ASK YOU MENTION THE
CARBON. ROAD MAP THAT YEAH DOES
THAT DOCUMENT. HOW YOU SITE
THESE STATIONS AND WHAT IS THE
STRATEGY AS TO WHERE YOU'RE
PUTTING THEM ARE YOU LOOKING AT
FOR INSTANCE THE DIFFERENT TYPES
OF VEHICLE CLASSES AND- HOW DO
YOU MAKE THE DETERMINATION OF
WHERE THESE INVESTMENTS ARE
GOING TO GO. YES THAT'S ALSO
THROUGH A PUBLIC PROCESS YOU ARE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM WE
TAKE A LOT OF FEEDBACK AND
TRYING TO LOOK COMPREHENSIVELY.
I DO THINK YOU KNOW THERE'S A
PARTICULAR FOCUS ON THE HEAVY
DUTY SECTOR NOW- HENRYSON MORE
WHO SHOULD BE GIVING THIS
PRESENTATION BUT ISN'T BECAUSE
HE'S VISITING US. IS A BIG TOUR
OF LITHIUM VALLEY- TODAY IS MUCH
MORE ABOUT- UP TO SPEED AS HE
RUNS ARE. I CAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION- BUT THAT'S THAT'S
ALSO THROUGH A PUBLIC PROCESS
THE HYDROGEN. ROADMAP THAT
ATTENTION IS MORE ROAD MAP FOR
OUR RESEARCH INVESTMENTS THROUGH
THE EPIC PROGRAM. WE'RE GOING TO
THE CONTRACT- IN THE COMING
MONTHS HOW TO REALLY GET VERY
GRANULAR WAY DOWN TO THE DETAIL
EXACTLY WHERE. THE BEST
INVESTMENT OF OUR HYDROGEN
RESEARCH MONEY. NEEDS TO GO TO
FIGURE OUT THE BEST ONE MILLION
SPECIFICALLY. FIVE HUNDRED
RESEARCH. THANK YOU- ARE YOU
TALKING TO THE AG INDUSTRY ABOUT
HYDROGEN APPLICATIONS IN
AGRICULTURE IN TERMS OF-
AGRICULTURAL VEHICLES FOR
INSTANCE JUST OUT OF CURIOSITY
AND I ASK THAT BECAUSE WHEN I
WAS YOU KNOW HOW BECAUSE I DID
SEE A WHOLE BUNCH OF
AGRICULTURAL HYDROGEN VEHICLES
WHICH WAS PRETTY EXCITING YOU
KNOW AND GIVEN THE DIFFICULTY OF
ELECTRIFYING VEHICLES THAT ARE
YOU KNOW HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
OF ACRES IN DIFFERENT PLACES ALL
THE TIME I JUST WONDER HOW MUCH
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL FOR HYDROGEN FUEL. AS
AS AS AS ZERO EMISSION FUELING
FOR THESE VEHICLES WHETHER
YOU'RE THINKING AT ALL ABOUT
WHAT KIND OF INFRASTRUCTURE IF
ANYTHING THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED. SO I HAVE NOT MYSELF TALK TO
ANYONE. OUR CULTURE INTO A
HYDROGEN. VEHICLES TO
APPLICATIONS I HAVE VISITED MARC
IS ELECT TRACTOR COMPANY THAT'S
NOW AND LEARN MORE- LARGEST
ELECTRIC CHARGING COMPANY
RESIDENT THEY'RE SELLING OF MID
SIZED TRACTORS- I I'M SURE THERE
ARE SOME AGRICULTURAL EQUIPMENT-
BURKE YOU ALSO BUT I'M NOT. I
DON'T KNOW CRAIG ARE YOU- YOU
ENGAGED IN THAT SPACE YOU KNOW
SOMEONE AND I GUESS WHAT I'D SAY
THAT ALTHOUGH WE HAVEN'T SEEN IN
A PARTICULAR- FUEL CELL USES AND
TRACTORS THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
THAT COULDN'T BE A THING AND AS
EVER IN EVERY CULTURE THERE SO
MANY DIFFERENT SPACES THERE
THINK FOR INSTANCE OF WAREHOUSES
WHERE FORKLIFTS ARE HUGE DEAL
AND FUEL CELLS ARE GOOD USE
FORM- SIMILARLY THERE MAY BE
OTHER FORMS IN THE APARTMENT
WHERE THIS MAKES SENSE. ONE
THING THAT'S TRUE IN
AGRICULTURAL USES YOU KNOW WE
NEED TO BE REALLY THOUGHTFUL
ABOUT WHICH TECHNOLOGIES GET
INTRODUCED AGENCIES ACKNOWLEDGES
MOVE AND SPREAD INTO THOSE
SPACES SO THIS MADMAN HOPEFUL
ANSWERS WATCH THIS SPACE AND
ANYTHING CREATING IN. THIS POOL
OF PROJECTSAND FUNDS SHOULD
HELP DRIVE CHANGE THERE TOO
THANKS I THINK THIS IS FOR CAR
BUT- HOW IS THE STATE TRACKING
PROGRESS OR TRENDS IN HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION AND ITS IMPACT ON AIR
QUALITY AND POLLUTION I KNOW WE
TALKED ABOUT EMISSIONS BUT ARE
YOU ALSO LOOKING AT THE IMPACT
ON YOUR QUALITY AND KNOCKS AND
OTHER TYPES OF POLLUTION'S WOULD
OCCUR JUST. WITH REGARD TO
HYDROGEN SPECIFICALLY. SO I'M
CERTAINLY ARE A GET ON THE WAY
INTO TOWN TO. THAT'S BECAUSE
THE- GUIDE WHAT SAY. IS CARD HAS
JUST AND LET YEAR RENEWAL
ADVANCE. IN ITS MY AND REPORTING
PROGRAMS FOR ALL INDUSTRIAL
SOURCES WHICH WOULD INCLUDE AND
ANY AND SEE HOW GIN PRODUCTION
FACILITIES TO MY KNOWLEDGE AT
LEAST INCLUDING THE SUN.
KRITERIEN TOXICS REPORTING
REGULATION WHICH IS PHASE IN
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS AND
REALLY HELPS US TRACK. ON THAT
FACILITY BEHAVIOR SO WELL I
CAN'T TODAY GIVE YOU PARTICULAR
NUMBERS AND HYDROGEN PRODUCTION
CRITERIA POLLUTANTS BUT I CAN
SAY. THAT WE'VE SEEN MUCH MUCH
DEEPER INVESTMENTS BOTH A
MODERATE OF EXPOSURES- TO
COMMUNITIES AROUND REFINERIES
OTHER SOURCES. AND SIGNIFICANT
ADVANCES IN RECORDING-
REGULATIONS ON ALL INDUSTRIAL
FACILITIES THANKS TO THIRTY
PROVIDED BY THE LEGISLATURE SO
THERE'S A LOT. OF INFRASTRUCTURE
REGULATORY INFRASTRUCTURE
ALREADY THERE AND ENSURE MORE TO
DEAL WHICH I'M SURE WE CAN
FOLLOW UP ON WHEN. MY STAFF AND
THAT'S THE ONLY THING I'M
MISSING. THANKS I'LL ASK BOTH OF
YOU- WHAT ADDITIONAL POLICIES
ARE CONSIDERATIONS YOU THINK WE
SHOULD BE TAKING. WHEN IT COMES
TO HIGH PER. AND DISTRIBUTION TO
HELP US MEET OUR- CLIMATE GOALS
IN CALIFORNIA'S OR ANYTHING THAT
YOU WISH WE WERE DOING. OR THAT
WERE MISSING THAT WILL. HELP
ASSIST YOUR EFFORTS. AND WHEN IT
COMES TO OUR GOALS. NO MADAM
CHAIR MY MIND I THINK THE SINGLE
MOST IMPORTANT THING RIGHT NOW
IN THIS SPACE IS THE OPPORTUNITY
GET FEDERAL MONEY INTO
CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL RIGHT. I DO
THINK IT BE HELPFUL FOR. PERHAPS
YOUR TO COMMITTEES TOOK TO
CONVENE- THE STAKEHOLDERS AGAIN-
ON HYDROGEN TO BETTER COORDINATE
ON A JOINT CALIFORNIA PROPOSAL I
THINK. WE WILL HAVE A BETTER
CHANCE THAN PROBABLY ANY OTHER
REGION. IN THE COUNTRY TO DIRECT
THIS MONEY INTELLIGENTLY AND
HELP IT. SUPPORT SERVICE SMART
DEVOLUTION OF ONCE THIS SECTOR-
AND SO YOU KNOW BUT IT WOULD BE
A BIG WIN FOR CALIFORNIA TO GET.
A MEANINGFUL HUB IN THIS AREA.
THANK I'LL JUST HAVE TWO THINGS
I'M IN SPEAKING JUST MYSELF AND
THAT BALLING YEAH THE FIRST IS
CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR YOU READY
PERMITTING THAT IS HEALTH
PROTECTIVE IN COMMUNITY
PROTECTION. AND PRODUCTION
FACILITIES I THINK IS REALLY
CRITICAL NOT JUST FOR HYDROGEN
BUT FOR OUR EFFORTS TO BUILD
BACK BETTER FAST ON A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PARTS OF CLIMATE
POLICY TRYING TO BUILD. NOW OUR
WAY FORWARD THAT'S REALLY
CRITICAL AND ANOTHER PIECE HOLDS
KNOWN AS FOR ESPECIALLY THE
HEAVY DUTY SPACE ON THREE
MANAGERS TO LOOK PRETTY FAR
AHEAD SO THE SORTS OF MULTI YOUR
PACKAGES LEGISLATURES DECIDED ON
THE PAST FEW YEARS AND FUNDING.
I'M HAVING A REALLY IMPORTANT
AND I THINK REALLY CLEAR STUDY
FINDING ON A STATE PROGRAMS AND
WHAT FOLKS NOT TO THAT AND NOW
HOW TO PLAN THEIR FLEETS INTO
ZERO EMISSION WILL HELP
PROVIDING A GREAT DEAL. OF ROOM
ON ON BOTH ON. BETTER ELECTRIC
AND FUEL CELL VEHICLES AND
THANKS FOR ASKING THE QUESTION.
THANK YOU MISTER BENNETT YOU HAD
NOT ANOTHER QUESTION OF THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM SURE FOR
LETTING ME COME BACK AND UP JUST
DOUBLE DUTIES AS QUICK AS I CAN
ONE I JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT- PROBABLY THE ONLY SILVER
LINING OF THE TRAGEDY THAT'S
GOING ON TODAY IN THE WORLD IT'S
RESULTING IN THE HIGHER FUEL
PRICES IS IT'S PROBABLY GOING TO
ACCELERATE. THE ADOPTION OF
HOUSE OF TECHNOLOGY OUT THERE
WHICH I REALLY APPRECIATE- BOTH-
THE CC AND CARB- IDENTIFYING
THAT THE GOAL IS NOT ANY
TECHNOLOGY THE GOAL IS TO THE TO
THE MISSION AND THAT IS TO
DECREASE THE EMISSIONS OVERALL-
BUT FOR THOSE OF US THAT ARE
MORE NOVICES. COULD YOU PLEASE
AND I THINK THIS IS PROBABLY
COMES FROM THE FOR THE ENERGY
COMMISSION- AND- CHAIR HARSH GOT
CHILD- COULD YOU JUST SUMMARIZE
GIVE US THE ELEVATOR PITCH THE
SIXTY SECOND PITCH AS TO WHY-
HYDROGEN SEEMS TO BE BETTER FOR
HEAVY DUTY- RIGHT NOW. THAT'S
IT'S IDENTIFIED A NUMBER OF
TIMES IN THE REPORT HERE- BUT-
COULD COULD YOU COULD YOU
IDENTIFY THAT OR WHOEVER IS THE
APPROPRIATE PERSON ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. YEAH I THINK ONE OF
THE ONE OF THE KEY ISSUES USES
THE RANGE OF THE VEHICLES ARE
WHICH YOU KNOW FOR HEAVY DUTY
TRUCKING AND SO FORTH. ARE RIGHT
NOW YOU KNOW- THE- ABILITY TO DO
LONG RANGE. ISN'T THERE FOR EASY
TRUCKING OBVIOUSLY TESLA HAS
ELECTRIC SEMI IN DEVELOPMENT BUT
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF OTHERS.
THAT ARE LOOKING FOR LONG RANGE-
YOU KNOW THERE ARE SOME LIKE MID
RANGE YOUR MOTIVES DURING
ELECTRIC. TRUCK YOU KNOW FOR
DELIVERY VEHICLES AND SO I'M-
BUT FOR THE MOST PART I THINK
THE HEAVY DUTY SPACE IS. THE
AREA WHERE HE IS OUR WEAKEST.
TODAY AT THIS POINT SO I THINK
THAT WOULD BE THE- DO THAT WOULD
BE KIND OF. Y. SE FUEL CELLS
ARE. ARE STRONGER IN THAT
POSITION THAN ON PAST YOUR CALLS
COULD COULD ANY OF THIS
COMMUNITY ASIDE SCIENTIST. TALK
ABOUT JUST FROM A SCIENTIFIC
STANDPOINT THE AMOUNT OF ENERGY
AND HYDROGEN VERSUS THE AMOUNT
OF ENERGY AND THEN THE FUEL CELL
BATTERY IS THERE. IS THERE ARE
AND ENERGY INTENSITY THERE THAT
HELPS WITH THE. HEAVY DUTY. I
THINK IT'S MORE OF AN DENSE. SO
YOU'RE ABLE TO GET FUEL. SMALLER
SPACE- YOU KNOW TERMS OF THE
BILL TO GO- ALONG RANGE. THAT'S
YOUR ADVANCE. FROM ANY IT'S PER
THAT MENTIONED. IT'S A- HALF OF
THE- TRICITY- TO DO ELECTRIC
VEHICLE PER MILE THAN A FUEL
CELL VEHICLE BUT THE DENSITY OF
THE HYDROGEN IS IT IS A VALUE.
FOR AND RENT AND SO FORTH IF WE
GET INTO JUST RECHARGING TIMES
EXETER RIGHT THERE THERE'S A
REFERENCE IN THE REPORT THAT
SAYS A SUBSET OF VEHICLE MARKET
WILL STILL REQUIRE FREQUENT
RELATIVELY FAST REFUELLING
PARTICULARLY FOR LARGER VEHICLE
CLASSES. AND SO- MIGHT AT AND
JUST LIKE TO CHECK AND SEE. I'M
I AM I UNDERSTAND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS YOU COULD
REFUEL FASTER WITH HYDROGEN THEN
YOU CAN RECHARGING THE BATTERY-
AND SO THIS IS JUST THIS IS
THAT'S THE STATISTIC THAT I HAVE
IN MY HEAD AND I JUST LIKE TO
CONFIRM WHETHER THAT'S ACCURATE
OR NOT. THERE IF YOU PULL IN-
WITH THAT LET'S TALK ABOUT LIGHT
DUTY VEHICLES RIGHT NOW JUST TO
KEEP. COMPARING APPLES TO
APPLES- A LIGHT DUTY EVEY PULLS
IN TO US TO A STATION- IT'S
GOING TO TAKE. A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT TIME FORTY MINUTES OR SO
TO CHARGE UP- WHEREAS A LIGHT
DUTY HYDROGEN CAR PULLING INTO
THE STATION COULD CHARGE IN
ABOUT FIVE. MINUTES MY
UNDERSTANDING IS. THAT THE
REFUELING STATIONS SUBSIDIES
THAT WE'RE GIVING IS ABOUT ONE
POINT TWO MILLION AS YOU SAID
FOR HYDROGEN AND ONLY ABOUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR THE E. IS
FOR THE- HE IS THE- HE TO.
REGULARLY AND SO BASICALLY A
LITTLE BIT MORE THAN TEN TIMES
AS MUCH. BUT ON A PER VEHICLE
BASIS IF YOU COULD CHARGE TEN
TIMES AS MANY VEHICLES. AT THAT
HYDROGEN STATION AS YOU CAN AT
THE E. V. STATION DOWN ON JUST A
JUST STRAIGHT UP PER VEHICLES
BASIS. THEY'RE ABOUT THE SAME IN
TERMS OF THE SUBSIDY BECAUSE YOU
CAN CHARGE TEN TIMES AS MANY
VEHICLES BECAUSE YOU CAN
CHARGING FASTER AND MIKE AM I.
IN THE BOOK I THINK THIS IS A
THAT'S A GOOD WAY TO THINK ABOUT
I MEAN REALLY THE HYDROGEN FUEL
INFRASTRUCTURE PUTTING ITS MORE
KNOWLEDGE AS TO A GAS STATION.
NOW HAVING SAID THAT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE V. CHARGING IS
WE'RE MOVING TO FASTER FASTER
CHART SO THERE IS A THREE AND A
FIFTY K. W. YOU CHARGER. THAT'S
THROUGH THE U. L. TESTING RIGHT
NOW AND BEING DEPLOYED WHICH IS
A HUNDRED MILES OF CHARGE IN
FIVE MINUTES OR TWO HUNDRED
MILES CHARGING IN TEN MINUTES WE
JUST FUNDED A PROJECT A TWO
WEEKS AGO AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION. FOR US K. W. BUS
CHARGER SO THE CHARGING STE IS
ALSO OUR RECORD. INCREASING SO.
WHAT EVEN THOUGH YOU DON'T SEE
THOSE ARE VERY ARE IN THE MARKET
TODAY BUT THAT'S THE DIRECTION
IT'S GOING TO BE A SUBSET OF.
VERY VERY FAST CHARGING- NO IT'S
A CHARGER FOR MY WILL BE INS AND
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE
WILL BE AT. A HIGHER STE IT DOES
WILL BE MORE EXPENSIVE TO PUT IN
THE IN THE- IN THE EAST TO YES.
SO ACTION. FASTER BUT THEY WILL
COME CLOSER TO THE CHURCH'S SORT
OF LIKE A HYDROGEN IT COSTS- SO
TO GET TO THAT A FAST SPEED YOU
COULD DO THAT- AND THEN- IT. THE
TWO OTHER THINGS I JUST LIKE TO
CHECK MY UNDERSTANDING AS TOYOTA
IS GOING TO HAVE TO DRIVE TRAINS
FOR FUEL CELL TECHNOLOGY READY
BY THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. IS THAT THE DATA THAT YOU
AND CARP HAVE BECAUSE ONCE THE
ONCE THAT IS SET BY THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THAT'S THEIR
GOAL THEN WE WOULD START HAVING.
THE ABILITY TO MORE MASS
PRODUCED AS A QUESTION WAS OUT
THERE YOU KNOW WE GET WHICH IS
VERY DIFFICULT TO PRODUCE. RIGHT
NOW THEY'RE BUT THEY'RE MAKING
HYDROGEN TO HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS BY
HAND VIRTUALLY- BUT THEY WOULD
BE ABLE TO DO THAT IS THAT IS
THAT THE DATA THAT YOU DID TO
ANYBODY AND EITHER THE TWO
DEPARTMENTS HAS FROM TOWARD
OTHERS. READING ON THE CONSUMER
TIME AT THE PASSENGER VEHICLE
SIDE OF IT SO THERE ARE THREE
COMPANIES THAT- BY THE BY THE
END OF FIVE TWENTY FOUR. ARE
HAVE ANNOUNCED PASSENGER FUEL
CELL VEHICLES THAT'S TOYOTA AND
HONDA YEAH YOU HAVE W. AND I'M
SORRY MY QUESTIONS ABOUT HEAVY.
DUTY THESE ARE DRIVE TRAIN
FRONT- YEAH I'M NOT I'M NOT I'M
NOT FAMILIAR WITH THOSE. ADS ON
PAGES THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I WAS
TOLD BY TOYOTA REPRESENTATIVE
SYMPTOM SO MAYBE SOMEBODY HAS AT
AND- MY FINAL. COMMENT IS. BOB I
THINK IT WAS CRAIG THERE FROM
CARB MADE THE COMMENT THAT ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT- YOU'VE SEEN
AND I JUST WANNA CONFIRM THAT I
HEARD THAT RIGHT IS THAT. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT CAN THAT THAT
YOU THINK IS A IS A VERY LIKELY
POSSIBILITIES AT THEIR- ONCE YOU
START IN THE HEAVY DUTY IF YOU
FOCUS HYDROGEN ON THE HEAVY DUTY
ONCE YOU START AND HEAVY DUTY.
THE TECHNOLOGIES THAT MAKE IT
EASIER TO EXPAND INTO THE LIGHT
DUTY YOU DID DID I HEAR THAT
CORRECT CRAIG IS THAT WHAT YOU
WERE IMPLYING A THREE YEAH AND
TO BE CLEAR THAT GOES BOTH WAYS
BUT THIS IS ONE OF THOSE ONES
WHERE. SOLVING THE UNIQUE
PROBLEM IN THAT SPACE CONSCIOUS
THAT OF ENGINEERING VALUE IT
HELPS US LEARN THAT HELPS US
FIGURE OUT NO ARRAY TECHNOLOGY
OPTIONS SO RIGHT NOW YOU KNOW WE
SEE A LOT OF TECHNOLOGY TRANSFER
RECORD EXPERIMENTED IN LIGHT
DUTY AND HEAVY DUTY. AND HEAVY
DUTY FOLKS CAN BE FIGURING OUT
BIGGER MORE POWERFUL VEHICLES IN
A LARGE SCALE ENERGY DELIVERY
LOTTA USEFUL MUTUAL INTERACTIONS
HEARING BOTH SIDES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
SUMMARY THANK YOU SURE WOMEN IN
THANK YOU FOR HOSTING THIS
HEARING- GONNA. PRETEXT THIS
SOME OF MY BACKGROUND ON ALL OF
THIS- WITH THE ADVENT OF LOSING
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE THAT MAKES
ME THE LAST DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY- LEGISLATIVE ENERGY
HORIZON INSTITUTE GRADUATE LEFT
IN THIS BUILDING- AND BEFORE MY
TIME IN THE ASSEMBLY- I KNOW A
LOT OF YOU KNOW THAT I'M A
VETERAN BULLET- THEY A SERVE TEN
YEARS IS A TRANSPORTATION AND
LOGISTICS SERGEANT DEALING WITH
HEAVY DUTY- IN MOVING VEHICLES
ALL OVER IRAQ AND KUWAIT. THE
PORTS AND EVERYTHING ELSE- SO TO
ANSWER SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT THAT I'VE ACTUALLY ALREADY
HEARD- FRANKLY EUROPE'S ALREADY
MOVED FORWARD ON A LOT OF THIS
ON MY ACCOUNT I HAVE SOME
CONCERNS NOW HEARING THAT WE'RE
WE'RE STILL LOOKING AT AT
TESTING AND PROJECTS VERSES
MOVING FORWARD IN IMPLEMENTING
THE PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE IS THE
FACT THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE FUEL
STATIONS. BECAUSE WHEN YOU GO TO
LOOK AT LARGE THIS FLEETS.
ESPECIALLY IN THE TRANSPORTATION
FREIGHT AND GOODS MOVEMENT THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM THE ENTIRE
NETWORK. IT IS BASED UPON GOING
IN AND FEELING. IT AND THEN
MOVING FORWARD. AS FAR AS HEAVY
DUTY FLEETS TO MISTER BENNETT'S
QUESTION AND HOPEFULLY THIS WILL
HELP I KNOW TOYOTA HYUNDAI
MERCEDES BENZ ARE ALREADY IN
MASS PRODUCTION OF LARGE. HEAVY
DUTY- THE TRUCKS TO REPLACE THE
EIGHTEEN WHEELERS FOR MOVING
FREIGHT IN AND THEY'RE ALREADY
DOING THIS IN EUROPE AUSTRALIA
IN THE ASIAN MARKETS THAT
THEY'RE ALREADY MOVING FORWARD.
YOU THESE GUYS ARE LEAVING US IN
THE DUST. ON WE NEED TO GET
CAUGHT UP OF THIS IS THE
DIRECTION WE'RE TRULY GOING TO
GO- MY QUESTION FOR CARVE IN.
TWO TO THE FOLKS ON THE PANEL.
WHAT PARTNERSHIPS ARE BEING
BUILT WITH EXISTING FUEL STATION
COMPANIES LATELY GLOVES AND-
FLYERS IN THESE OTHERS THAT THE
DEAL WITH THE HEAVY DUTY.
COMMERCIAL TRUCKING FLEETS
BECAUSE WHAT A I THINK WE NEED
TO BE DOING IS LOOKING AT THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS YORDY HAVE FEEL
STATIONS THAT ARE BUILT. THE WAY
HYDROGEN WORKS IS IT'S NOT A
CHARGE IT SEES GUYS PULL WHEN
THEY STICK IT IN THERE AND THEY
FEEL IT UP AND THEN THEY GO. SO
IF THEY GOT A RUN IN AND GO TO
THE BATHROOM AND GRAB SOME%
SNACKS MAYBE FIFTEEN TWENTY
MINUTES. BUT BUT THEY'RE NOT
STUCK THERE FOR A PROLONGED
PERIOD OF TIME. THAT'S HOW
TRANSPORTATION WORKS. THE ON THE
DAY TO DAY. SO WE SHOULD REALLY
BE LOOKING T PARTNERSHIPS WITH
THESE GUYS ALREADY DO THIS
ALREADY IN BUSINESS THIRTY
MOVING FORWARD BUT I HAVEN'T
HEARD ABOUT WE'RE BUILDING
PARTNERSHIPS WITH EXISTING FUEL
STATIONS. BECAUSE IN THIS IS
BEEN TALKED ABOUT ON A
DIFFERENT. SUMMITS AND DIFFERENT
THINGS IS WE'VE DISCUSSED
BRINGING HYDROGEN INTO THE MIX.
IS HOW DO YOU SET UP A PROGRAM
WHERE YOU CAN TELL THE TRUCK
STOP COMPANY HEY YOU YOU'VE GOT
DIESEL YOU'VE GOT GAS WHAT DOES
IT TAKE US TO PUT A HYDROGEN
TANK IN THERE FOR YOU GUYS RUN
SOME HYDROGEN LINES OUT. WHAT
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE SO
EVENTUALLY WE CAN PUT IN A
HYDROGEN TANKS IN AS WE CURB IN
GET THE INDUSTRY GOING TO MOVE
FORWARD THEN YOU CAN TAKE OUT
THE DIESEL D. COMMISSIONER
WHATEVER WHATEVER POINT WE
EVENTUALLY GET TO THAT. WE NEED
TO HEAR THOSE CONVERSATIONS IN
THOSE PARTNERSHIPS BECAUSE I
HAVEN'T HEARD THAT TODAY. IN IF
THIS IS REALLY WERE GONNA GO THE
STATE. TO INTEGRATE INTO NEW
TECHNOLOGY THE EV'S IN IN THE
ELECTRIC IT IT'S GREAT. ON THE
SMALL SCALE FOR DRIVING A CAR
AROUND A LARGE CITY THAT HAS
ACCESS TO THIS FOR MY PEOPLE IN
RURAL CALIFORNIA. WE DON'T HAVE
THE CHARGING STATIONS WE'RE
WE'RE GETTING MORE MORE BUT- HE
IS NOT THERE BUT I THINK OF
WE'RE GONNA MOVE FORWARD ON THE
HEAVY DUTY SIDE WHICH IS WHERE.
MOST OF THE- HARDER EMISSIONS
ARE COMING FROM IT THAT YOU NEED
TO LOOK AT THE HEAVY DUTY YOU
NEED TO LOOK AT PARTNERSHIPS AND
I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE ANOTHER
HEARING WHERE WE BRING IN SOME
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS TO THE
CHAIRWOMAN'S QUESTION WITH
AGRICULTURE THEOTHER SOME
SMALLER LIGHTER DUTY THINGS
COMING ON SCALE BUT THE BIG
MASSIVE TRACTORS. THE TECHNOLOGY
IS THERE. I HOST MY JUST REALIZE
THE WORLD EXPO EVERY YEAR. COME
DOWN CHECK IT OUT THERE'S A LOT
OF REALLY NEAT STUFF IN THIS
REALM. BUT INTEL THE FUEL. IS
THERE I MEAN AS A FARMER COULD
IF THEY REALLY WANTED TO AND
THIS IS WHERE WE GET TO YOU
KNOW. WHO KNOWS HOW LONG DOWN
THE ROAD INSTEAD HAVING A DIESEL
TANK OUT ON THEIR PROPERTY THEY
CAN HAVE A HYDROGEN TANK. BUT
WHAT ARE WE DOING AS A STATE TO
HELP THEM GET THERE. BECAUSE I'M
NOT GONNA GO HOME AND TELL MY
GUYS HERE WE'RE GONNA SWITCH
YOUR HYDROGEN WITHOUT HELPING
THEM GET THERE AND THAT'S BEEN
THE BIGGEST GAP THAT WE'VE SEEN
SINCE WE'VE PUSHED ALL OF THIS-
THAT'S WHY WE WORK SO HARD ON
CAP AND TRADE. WITH THEN
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN MAKING SURE
THAT AS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SWITCHING ENGINE TYPES FIXING
THOSE HOLES BECAUSE IT USED TO
BE DIESEL TO A CLEANER BURNING
DIESEL TO THAN IN NEWER CLEANER
BURNING DIESEL INSTEAD OF GOING
DIESEL. TO ANOTHER ENGINE TYPE.
SO WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
NOT MISSING THOSE THINGS- LIKE
WHAT'S DONE IN THE PAST. SO
AGAIN THE PARTNERSHIPS AND THEN
JUST BRING IN A STAKEHOLDERS I'D
LOVE TO SEE A HEARING WHERE WE
BROUGHT IN YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
FOLKS FROM THE TRANSPORTATION
INDUSTRY IN SOME OF THE FOLKS
THAT DEAL WITH LARGE SCALE
TRACTORS FROM THE AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY I'M I'M SURE THEY'D
LOVE TO WEIGH IN ON SOME OF
THESE THINGS THANK YOU MANAGER.
MATHIS THANK YOU FOR YOUR SHARE
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE
ACTUALLY I JUST WANT TO SAY ONE
OF THE THINGS WE WERE SO WE WORK
REALLY CLOSELY WITH. ALTERING
CALIFORNIA BUDGET FOR PROJECTS
AND THE MARINE CORPS- TOLD ME
THE 25% OF THEIR CASUALTIES THAT
THEY TOOK AND RACKING UP KANSEN
WERE ON. MISSIONS DELIVERING
FUEL. I REALLY STUCK WITH ME-
YEAH NO PART OF THE YET ANOTHER
REASON WHY WE NEED TO TRANSITION
KNOW WHAT I WAS GOING TO SUGGEST
REALLY THE BEST PERSON TO SPEAK
TO THE QUESTION YOU ASKED. IS
TERRORISTS WHO WAS ACTUALLY
RUNNING THE QUICK TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS BUT DEALING WITH ALL
THE HYDROGEN STATIONS AND AS A
FOLLOW UP TO THIS YOU KNOW WHAT
MIGHT BE HELPFUL. IT'S INVITE
HIM TO CME PRESENT AND ACTUALLY
SHOW YOU THE MAP OF WHERE I JUST
STATIONS ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
NOW. THE PLAN IN CASE. WHAT THE
WHOLE NETWORK WILL LOOK LIKE-
AND THEN YOU CAN TALK. AS WELL
ABOUT THE ENGAGEMENT WITH. THE
VERY STATION OWNERS AS JUST. AS
A FOLLOW UP WITH THAT STARTED.
AND JUST TO CHIME IN BRIEFLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. GOSH ARE YOU
WERE RIGHT ABOUT NEEDING TO GET
SOME OF THOSE BIG PRIVATE
FEELING COMPANIES EVEN FURTHER
INTO THE GAME. AND SOME OF CARDS
PROJECTS MATCHING GOING DOWN
TOMORROW TO SEE AN EXISTING
HYDROGEN- RATHER IT IS A FEELING
ADDED TO EXISTING SHELL STATION
THAT'S RUN AND HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS
OFF THE PORTS. WHICH IS GREAT SO
WE ARE FOCUSED ON YOU HAVE SHOWN
THAT STATION OWNERS THIS PROJECT
CAN WORK. WELL JUST TELL YEAH
WITHOUT THROWING ANY PARTICULAR-
EXTRACT COMPANY UNDER THE BUS.
SOMETIMES THE FOLKS THERE WHO
ARE UNDULY CONSERVATIVE WHEN IT
COMES TO THESE TECHNOLOGIES IN
OTHER WORDS THERE WAITING AND
SEEING I GET THAT. NOW I'M
THINKING ABOUT BUSINESS
DECISIONS. BUT I DO THINK THAT
IT IS VALUABLE IN ADDITION TO
SENDING REALLY CLEAR REGULATORY
AND INCENTIVE SIGNALS HEY LOOK
AT THE MARKETS COMING GET DOWN
AT. THIS IS WE'VE SEEN UNLIKE
YOU DECIDE YOU KNOW PRIVATE
UNIQUE PRIVATE COMPANIES REALLY. JUMP IN THE IN THE FEELING.
YEAH THIS IS ABOUT NEED TO BE
ABOUT. I'VE I'M SURE KNOW THE C.
C. TEAM IS HEARD WAY MORE THAN I
HAVE ABOUT IT INFRASTRUCTURES
THERE WERE OWN VEHICLES ARE
MINE. BUT I THINK THAT THIS IS A
REAL BUSINESS OPPORTUNITY. AND
ARE THERE IS VALUE IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS
REGISTRATION INTEREST THEIR
POINT TO SOME EARLY PARTNERSHIPS
THAT WE'VE GOT. AND SAY THAT-
SOMETIMES- IF YOU'VE BEEN IN ONE
KIND OF BUSINESS FOR A WHILE YOU
MAY MISS WHAT BIG BUSINESS LOOK
AT OPPORTUNITIES THERE ARE-
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AREAS FOR
FOLKS. ABSOLUTELY ALL THE
BENEFIT FROM THIS TECHNOLOGY BUT
NEED BOTH THE PRIVATE AND PUBLIC
SECTORS TO STEP UP AND HELP IN
THE NATION. I AGREE WITH YOU BUT
IS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
REGULATORY MATTERS. FOR THOSE
THAT ARE- IS YOU SAY STRONGLY
CONSERVATIVE AND. AND KIND OF-
TO- FRAZIER WHICH OF STUCK IN
THEIR WAYS- THE- CARE IT
DEFINITELY WORKS BETTER THAN A
STICK WITH A LOT OF THEM SO I
WOULD ENCOURAGE A MORE CARROTS
UNLESS STICKS. THANK OF CARROTS
AND- HAPPY TO KEEP WORKING ON
THAT AS WELL. GREAT THANK YOU
EVERYBODY THANKS FOR THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION GREAT INFORMATION AND
NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO OUR
SECOND AND LAST PANEL. FOR THIS
PANEL EVERYONE WILL HAVE FIVE
MINUTES ALL OF THE PANELISTS.
AND WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
OUR FIRST SPEAKER WHO'S HERE IN
PERSON WELCOME. JAMIE LEVIN THE
DIRECTOR OF WEST COAST
OPERATIONS FOR THE CENTER FOR
TRANSPORTATION AND ENVIRONMENT.
THANK YOU FOR WAITING SO
PATIENTLY. SEP CAN YOU HEAR ME
OK. SURE FRIEDMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION AND
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE WITH YOU TODAY INFORMATION
ABOUT NOR CAL ZERO AN EXCITING
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
TRUCK PROJECT LARGELY FUNDED BY
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES AND
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF WEST COAST
OPERATIONS FOR THE CENTER FOR
TRANSPORTATION THE ENVIRONMENT A
NON PROFIT ORGANIZATION WITH
OFFICES IN BERKELEY LOS ANGELES
ATLANTA AND MINNEAPOLIS ST PAUL
THE MISSION OF OUR ORGANIZATION
IS TO HELP FACILITATE THE
TRANSFORMATION OF THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR TWO ZERO
EMISSIONS IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
THE HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITIES
AND OUR PLANET BY SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCING BOTH CRITERIA AND
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. AS A MEMBER BASED
ORGANIZATION WE REPRESENT OVER
EIGHTY SIX MEMBERS FROM INDUSTRY
PUBLIC AGENCIES UNIVERSITIES AND
OTHER NONPROFITS NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE NOR CAL'S ZERO WILL BE
THE LARGEST DEPLOYMENT OF CLASS
EIGHT FUEL CELL ELECTRIC TRUCKS
IN NORTH AMERICA WITH ONE OF THE
LARGEST FUELING STATIONS IN THE
WORLD CAPABLE OF FUELING SIXTY
TRUCKS PER DAY WAS SIXTY
KILOGRAMS OF FUEL PER TRACK.
ALTHOUGH OUR PROJECT WILL BE
DEPLOYING ONLY THIRTY TRUCKS IN
THIS PILOT DEMONSTRATION THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS ENDEAVOR IS
REALLY ABOUT PAVING THE WAY TO
DEPLOY TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
TRUCKS THAT OPERATE TO AND FROM
OUR MARITIME PORTS IN REGIONAL
LOCATIONS AND DESTINATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE WANT TO
DEMONSTRATE TO FLEET OPERATORS
THE COMMERCIAL VIABILITY A FUEL
CELL ELECTRIC TRUCKS BY PROVING
THAT THESE VEHICLES CAN REPLACE
DIESEL AND SEE AND- THE TRACKS.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. BEGINNING IN
TWENTY NINETEEN C. D. E.
ORGANIZED A GROUP OF FOURTEEN
ORGANIZATIONS FROM THE PRIVATE
AND PUBLIC SECTORS TO COMPETE
FOR CARBON C. E. C. FUNDING.
ALAMEDA COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION IN THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
COMMITTED SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN MATCHING FUNDS IN PRIVATE
INDUSTRY INCLUDING HYUNDAI MOTOR
COMPANY AND FIRST ELEMENT FUEL
COMMITTED ANOTHER SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN COST SHARE.
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE OUR PROJECT
PROPOSAL WAS AWARDED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN GRANTS FROM
CARBON C. E. C. NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. BEGINNING IN JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND OPERATING FOR
SIX YEARS THEREAFTER THESE
TRUCKS WILL SERVICE DESTINATIONS
IN THE BAY AREA SACRAMENTO AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. WITH A RANGE OF NEARLY
FIVE HUNDRED MILES THEY'RE
PROJECTED TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS BY FOUR THOUSAND
METRIC TONS PER YEAR CRITERION
MISSIONS BY OVER TWO TONS PER
YEAR. AND PETROLEUM FUEL
CONSUMPTION BY OVER THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND GALLONS PER
YEAR NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. WHAT
DISTINGUISHES FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
TRUCKS FROM OTHER ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES IS AN EXTENDED
RANGE OF FIVE HUNDRED MILES WITH
. SACRIFICING PAYLOAD WHICH WILL
BE NEARLY EQUIVALENT TO A DIESEL
TRUCK CARRYING FORTY THOUSAND
POUNDS OF PAYLOAD. THE ABILITY
TO QUICKLY RE FUEL THESE TRUCKS
IN TEN TO TWENTY MINUTES WILL
ENABLE FLEET OPERATORS TO
OPERATE MULTIPLE TRIPS WITH
NEGLIGIBLE DOWNTIME THE SAME
REASON FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
FORKLIFTS ARE NOW A COMMERCIAL
PRODUCT. FOR WAREHOUSE OPERATION
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. INITIALLY THE
FUEL SUPPLY WILL BE SOURCED FROM
54% RENEWABLE FEEDSTOCK WITH THE
CARBON INTENSITY OF ZERO. BUT I
MUST EMPHASIZE THAT FUEL CELLS
ARE AGNOSTIC. TO THE SOURCES OF
HYDROGEN SO THE ULTIMATE GOAL
FOR OUR INDUSTRY IS TO PROVIDE A
100% RENEWABLE FEEDSTOCKS BUT AT
AN AFFORDABLE PRICE WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT THE POSSIBILITY OF
USING SOME OF OUR TRUCKS TO
TRANSPORT THE HYDROGEN FROM
PRODUCTION FACILITIES AND
DISTRIBUTION HUBS. TO FUELING
STATIONS NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. THE
TRUCKS WE ARE DEPLOYING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA OR IN UPGRADE TWO
TRUCKS PRESENTLY DEPLOYED IN
SWITZERLAND WHERE THEY HAVE
ALREADY PROVEN THEIR COMMERCIAL
VIABILITY. THE GOAL WEIGHT IN
EXCESS OF NINETY THOUSAND POUNDS
HAVE NAVIGATED ONE AND A HALF
MILLION MILES WITH VERY LITTLE
DOWN TIME FOR MAINTENANCE BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. MORE THAN
SIXTEEN HUNDRED OF THESE TRUCKS
WILL BE OPERATIONAL THROUGHOUT
SWITZERLAND NEXT SLIDE PLEASE
FINALLY I'D LIKE TO CONCLUDE BY
ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE FORTY TWO THE SALE THE
STATE SALES TAX EXEMPTION BILL
FOR ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS. IF WE
ARE TO ACHIEVE THE TARGETED
GOALS OF 1100% OF ALL TRUCK
SALES AND 1100% OF ALL DRAYAGE
TRUCKS IN SERVICE TO BE ZERO
EMISSION BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
THEN HELPING TO REDUCE THE COST
OF THIS ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY FOR
EARLY ADOPTERS WILL BE CRITICAL
TO PAVING THE WAY FOR OTHERS TO
FOLLOW WITH MORE AFFORDABLE
PRICES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INTEREST IN TIME AND AGAIN
GIVING ME FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH YOU
TODAY THIS IMPORTANT PROJECT AND
LASTLY I'LL JUST SAY- I HAVE
VERY GOOD OPINIONS ABOUT HOW THE
STATE CAN LEVERAGE ITS FUNDING
FOR THE HYDROGEN HUB PROGRAM THE
EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR. PROGRAM SO
IF THAT'S A QUESTION THAT YOU
WISH TO ASK I HAVE AN OPINION TO
OFFER THANK YOU THANK YOU WE'RE
GONNA WAIT AND TAKE QUESTIONS AT
THE END AFTER THE PANEL BUT I'M
GOING TO TEACH YOU UP TO ANSWER
THE QUESTION HOW ABOUT. THAT
BACK IF I FORGET YOU CAN JUST GO
AHEAD AND ANSWER OKAY OKAY THANK
YOU SO DON'T GO FAR YOU MAY BE
THE ONLY PERSON HERE IN OUR
PERSON. SO YOU MIGHT AS WELL TO
STAY THERE OKAY OKAY THAT OUR
NEXT- HANDLE IS TO BUY ZOOM IS
KEPT- KEVIN SHERIDAN THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE TRI
VALLEY SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
REGIONAL RAIL AUTHORITY OR-
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS VALLEY LINK
FOR GOOD REASONS THANKS YOU'RE-
YOU'RE UP NEXT KEVIN. HE RAN MY
CHAIR REMAIN RE. AND CERTAINLY
CAN APPRECIATE ALL THE
CONVERSATION DAY AND I FEEL
LIKE. PROJECT I'M ABOUT READY TO
SHIP ITS- VERY MUCH TOWARDS VERY
MUCH IN LINE WITH A LOT OF THE
DISCUSSION. THAT IS OCCURING
SUMMER SHARE MY SCREEN NOW.
WHERE EVERYBODY CAN SEE THAT
OKAY. NOT GO TO THE BALLOT LINK
PROJECT THANK YOU. BOTTLING'S
SEEKING TO BE A 100% SELF
SUFFICIENT AND TO BE A MODEL OF
SUSTAINABILITY AND PASSENGER
RAIL. ON THE COURT OR THE
NEWPORT OR- IS APPROXIMATELY
FORTY TWO MILES LONG WITH SEVEN
STATIONS IN A MAINTENANCE
FACILITY. DALY COMMUTERS ARE
THIRTY THREE THOUSAND. THE
AVERAGE DAILY- VEHICLES TRAVELED
IN THE CORRIDOR OF OVER A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
VEHICLES TODAY. WE GO TO THE
SOMEWHAT QUICKLY TO GET TO THE
HYDROGEN PLANT. SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES IN MEGA REGION IN
THIS PROJECT IS CONSIDERED-
BALLACK IS CONSIDERED A MEGA
REGION PROJECT AS IT LINKS.
ASSEMBLY KEEN COUNTY TO ALAMEDA
COUNTY TRI VALLEY BUT ALSO OTHER
COMMUTERS ARE COMMON AS FAR
SOUTH AS- STANISLAUS COUNTY. AND
DINNER THE REASON FOR THOSE
MAKING COMMUTES ARE HARDLY JOBS
IN HOUSING BALANCE. IN BALANCE
AND IT FOR EVERY SIX NEW JOBS
ARE CREATED IN THE BAY AREA.
ONLY ONE HOUSE IT IS AVAILABLE
AND- THOSE UNDERSTAND WILL
HOUSING COSTS- IF YOU CAN SEE ON
THE BOTTOM THERE ONE HOUSE ONE
HOUSE IN A VERY CLOSE PROXIMITY
THREE HOUSES IN NORTH SAN
JOAQUIN. VALLEY TRAFFIC IS
EXPECTED TO INCREASE BY 60% SHE
COULD SEE THAT THE PICTURE THERE
ON FIVE EIGHTY A THAT IS A
COLLECTION THAT THAT. OCCURS
DAILY. FROM FIVE THIRTY IN THE
MORNING TO NOT- TO NINE THIRTY
THE PEAK HOUR IN THE MORNING AND
IN THE EVENING- TWO THIRTY TO
SEVEN JUST FLIP IT OVER THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE ROAD- AND I'M
GOING WEST AT EASTBOUND ANNOUNCE
WHAT TRAFFIC LOOKS LIKE SO IT'S
A HIGHLY CONGESTED CORRIDOR. IN
THE MEGA REGION. BOB BALLINGER
ALSO CONNECTS IS A STANDALONE
PROJECT IN WHAT IT WOULD BE FOR
THE CORPORATE ALSO CONNECTS-
OTHER IMPORTANT PROJECTS IN THE
REGION SUCH AS BY RAIL WHICH IS
EXTENDING- THE EXISTING COMMUTER
RAIL SERVICE FROM SACRAMENTO TO.
MERCED WHERE- VENTURI- DIæN WITH
HIGH SPEED RAIL AND THEN. AS IT
COMES OVER THE YELLOW LINE TO
THE GREEN LINE WHICH IS VIOLATED
THAT PROVIDES CONNECTION TO.
THAT PART. IN THE SPIRIT. SO ARE
THE BALLOT BOARD ESTABLISHED A
SUSTAINABILITY POLICY WITH THE
GOAL TO BE A MODEL OF
SUSTAINABILITY IN THE DESIGN
CONSTRUCTION OPERATION THE
BOTTLING SYSTEM WITH A LOT OF
THE TOPICS DISCUSSED TODAY BEING
THE FOCUS IN THAT SUSTAINABILITY
POLICY SO IT WAS EXCITING TO
HEAR ALL THE ROBUST DISCUSSION
ON OUR HYDROGEN AND ZERO
EMISSIONS AND REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GASES TODAY AT THE
HEARING. SOME OF THOSE
SUSTAINABILITY IN ACTION OUR
SELECTION OF ITS ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE. RING ENERGY PRODUCTION
STATION AREA PLANNING AROUND THE
STATIONS AND INNOVATIVE STATION
ACCESS SUCH AS- A POLICY YOUR
GOALS SHOT AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES.
SO WITH THAT IN ORDER TO PREPARE
FOR A HYDROGEN RAIL- WE DID NOT
WANT TO BE IN A SITUATION I'LL
AND DID NOT WANT TO BE IN A
SITUATION WHERE TRYING TO BUILD
OUR REGION RIGHT AFTER THE FACT.
SO NOW IT HAS TWO HUNDRED ACRES
LOCATED IN THE CITY OF TRACY
VETERANS SET ASIDE FOR
MAINTENANCE FACILITY. AND A
SENIOR AND THE PICTURE OF THE
WHITE AREA IS ENERGY FARMER I DO
GET QUITE STORAGE RAWLING WANTS
TO BE THE FIRST- PASSENGER RAIL
START UP. WITH ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY NOT CONVERT BUT TO
ACTUALLY START UP. THAT WAY AND
- SO WE'RE LOOKING TO
INSTRUCTORS I DO CHEN PLANT
AHEAD OF TIME. AND TO DO THAT WE
HAVE PARTNERED WITH OTHER
TRANSIT AGENCIES IN THE TRI
VALLEY. AND SURROUNDING THIS
LOCATION IS ALSO A LOT OF OUR
GREAT. AND GOODS MOVEMENT WHAT
TRUCKS YEAH MAINLY THE
WAREHOUSING THAT'S BEEN ONE OF
THE LARGEST- AREAS OF
CONSTRUCTION IS WHERE HOUSING IN
THIS AREA SO DON'T BE
OPPORTUNITIES TO PARTNER WITH.
SOME OF THOSE WAREHOUSES THAT
ARE SEEKING TO YOU. THE HYDROGEN
POWER FOR TRUCK FOR LONG HAUL
AND HEAVY DUTY SO THIS IS A
HEAVY DUTY ARM FIVE FACILITY
THAT SCALABLE AND INITIAL SCALE
WILL BE TO BUILD A HYDROGEN
FACILITY TO START. FEELING
LOSSES WHAT CONTRA COSTA
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY-
LIVERMORE ORDER VALUE
TRANSPORTATION. AND ALSO A
COUNTY COURT OR IN THE TRI
VALLEY AND- FRANKLY ANY OTHER
TRANSIT AGENCIES IN THE AREA
THAT. SEEKS TO USE HYDROGEN WE
HAVE HAPPENED A VALUABLE SOURCE
OF HYDROGEN HELPED FUEL THOSE
BUSES AND THEN ONCE THE RAIL IS
CONSTRUCTED. AND THAT THE TRAINS
ARE BEING BUILT- NOW SAMBAR DINO
IS GETTING SOME OF THE FIRST
HYDROGEN TRAINS AND- R. I.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR SO THOSE WILL
BE OPERATIONAL BY TIME WE'RE
FINISHED CONSTRUCTING. THE RAIL
AND THEN WILL HAVE AVAILABILITY
TO EXPAND THE HYDROGEN FACILITY
BUT MORE TO CONTINUE WITH THE-
GREEN AS POSSIBLE TYPE HYDROGEN
READ. I MERRILY SOLAR. AND WIND
DRIVEN. BUT ALSO TO BE UP ALSO
IN STORE ON ON SITE AND YOUR
YOUR TIME IS A BUT IF YOU CAN
JUST FINISH UP PERHAPS FROM
QUICKLY. I AM FINISHED SURE YOU
IT'S OKAY FOR YOU TO DO THAT
LAST SLIDE IF YOU LIKE WITH YOUR
YOUR FUNDING. WHEN I'M TO GO
AHEAD AND QUICKLY GO THROUGH
THAT. SO THIS IS A FUNDING THANK
YOU SURE SO THIS IS THE FUNDING
FOR THE OVERALL PROJECT. I
CURRENTLY HAVE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION- SECURED AND THE
GOAL WAS TO ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION Q. ARE COMPLETE INITIAL
OPERATING SEGMENT BETWEEN DUBLIN
PLEASANTON BART. AND MILHOUSE
AND TRACY STATION MANAGER SHARP
AND- THAT IS NOT THE COST OF THE
START UP HYDROGEN PLANT THAT WE
SUBMITTED AN APPLICATION FOR
RECENTLY A WORKING PARTNERSHIP
WITH CONTRA COSTA. THAT'S MUCH
LESS- YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING ABOUT TEN MILLION
DOLLARS JUST TO KIND OF BUILD
LARA I DO TO BE SOLELY BECAUSE
WE ALREADY HAVE SECURED LANDING
COMPLETED DEPARTMENT ALSO
ACTUALLY READY TO. GO TO OUR
INSTRUCTIONS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I KNOW I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME JULIE MCNAMARA. THE
DEPUTY POLICY DIRECTOR- I'M
SORRY NEXT TIME WELCOMING NEIL
NOW BEEN THE VICE PRESIDENT FOR
CLEAN ENERGY INNOVATIONS FOR THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY. THERE'S SOMEONE TO SHARE MY
SCREEN. THANK YOU. YOU KNOW WHAT
I'M GONNA DO THIS WITHOUT SLICE
OF THAT'S OKAY. AND WE ALSO
SHARE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS UNTIL THEY'VE
BEEN THE VICE PRESIDENT CLEAN
ENERGY INNOVATIONS RECYCLE GAS
AND I OVERSEE OUR PORTFOLIO
CLEAN ENERGY INNOVATION SOME
PROJECTS TO SUPPORT OUR ROLE. AS
A LONG TERM LEADER AND ENTER IN
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE
. I'M HERE TO VOTE TO SPEAK
BRIEFLY ABOUT OUR EFFORTS TO
DEVELOP NEXT GENERATION HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION A PROFICIENT
TECHNOLOGIES. TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE AND AIR QUALITY. I DON'T
CHEN IS AN ESSENTIAL
DECARBONISATION TOOL AND WHEN
COUPLED WITH RENEWABLE ENERGY
HUNDRED RESULTS IN A GLOBALLY
SCALABLE. LOW AND ZERO EMISSIONS
ENERGY SYSTEM THAT EFFECTIVELY
ADDRESSES CLIMATE CHANGE. SO GAS
CURRENTLY HAS TEN THE HYDROGEN
PILOT PROJECTS EMOTIONS
INCLUDING. ATTESTING NATURAL GAS
. EXISTING NATURAL GAS
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE ALSO HAVE A
FEW KEY PROJECTS INCLUDING OUR
AWARD WINNING H. TWO HUNDRED AND
HOME WHICH WHEN COMPLETED THIS
SUMMER WILL DEMONSTRATE HOW.
CARBON FREE GAS MADE FROM
RENEWABLE ELECTRICITY CAN BE
USED TO FUEL CLEAN ENERGY
SYSTEMS OF THE FUTURE AND
HOUSING. WE'RE ALSO PARTNERING
WITH SUNLINE TRANSIT AGENCY AND
A THREE YEAR DEMONSTRATION
PROJECT TO PRODUCE. CLEAN
HYDROGEN FROM RENEWABLE HYDROGEN
MANEUVERABLE NATURAL GAS TO FUEL
THEIR FLEET OF HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL TRUCKS OR BUSES. AND JUST
LAST MONTH WE ANNOUNCED A
PROPOSAL TO DEVELOP THE ANGELES
WINK. WHAT COULD BE ONE OF THE
NATION'S LARGEST GREEN HYDROGEN
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE SYSTEMS.
WILL DELIVER CLEAN RELIABLE INTO
THE LOS ANGELES BASED. OUR
VISION IS THAT THE ANGELES LINK
CAN BE THE CORNERSTONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S HYDROGEN
ENTERTAINERS ECONOMY. AND WHAT
POSITION ARE STATE TO BE THE
CLEAN FUELS BOMBER. THE LOS
ANGELES BASED FILM AS YOU KNOW
IS THE COUNTRY'S LARGEST
MANUFACTURING CENTER. MAKING IT
ALL TOO MANY POTENTIAL GREEN
HYDROGEN END USERS. WE KNOW
TRANSPORTATION SOURCES
PARTICULARLY HEAVY DUTY
TRANSPORTATION OR THE PRIMER.
THERE'S JUST SMOG FORMATION IN
THE REGION AND AS SUCH WE
ENVISION THE ANGELES LINKS GREEN
HYDROGEN PLAYING A ROLE IN
REDUCING THE EMISSIONS FROM.
TRANSPORTATION IN ADDITION TO
DISPATCH WILL ELECTRIC
GENERATION AND HEAVY AND HEAVY
DUTY MANUFACTURING. THOSE AREAS
OF THE ECONOMY WHERE THERE IS
BROAD AGREEMENT THAT
ELECTRIFICATION WILL BE
CHALLENGING. THIS MEANS
DECREASING DEMAND FOR NATURAL
GAS DIESEL AND OTHER FOSSIL
FUELS WHICH WOULD IN TURN REDUCE
GHG EMISSIONS AND HELP
ACCELERATE CALIFORNIA'S. HI MY
GOALS. OUR PROPOSAL IN OUR
PROPOSED RETENTION SYSTEM HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO HELP TRANSITION
LONG HAUL TRUCK FLEETS. AND THEN
BEGIN THEIR JOURNEY AT THE PORTS
OF LOS ANGELES AND LONG BEACH.
AND COULD YOU HAVE WELL
DEVELOPED FULLY DISPLAYS UP TO
THREE MILLION GALLONS OF DIESEL
A DAY. THIS COULD POTENTIALLY
ELIMINATE AFTER TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND TONS OF SMOG FORMING
KNOCKS POLLUTION- YEAR. AND
REDUCING GHG EMISSIONS BY
FOURTEEN MILLION METRIC TONS OF
CO TWO OAKLAND WHAT. MANDEL'S
LAKE THE NATURAL EXTENSION OF
SPOKE AGAINST THIS ROLE AS AN
INDUSTRY LEADER IN HYDROGEN. AND
WE COULDN'T BE MORE EXCITED TO
POTENTIALLY DEVELOP THE ANGELES
LINK. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU OUR CUSTOMS ONE
HUNDRED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
AND OUR LAST SPEAKER IS JULIE
MCNAMARA NOW WHO IS THE DEPUTY
POLICY DIRECTOR WITH THE CLIMATE
AND ENERGY PROGRAM AT THE UNION
OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME I'M HAPPY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS YEAR AND-
I'M AT STATE. AS WE'VE HEARD
TODAY THERE IS CLEARLY A ROLL
FOR HYDROGEN IN THE CLEAN ENERGY
TRANSITION. AND THE SPECIFIC SET
BACK ROLE ARE STILL FAR FROM
CLEAR. THAT'S BECAUSE THE
HYDROGEN CANCER A RANGE OF END
USES A RANGE OF POTENTIAL
SOLUTIONS. IT DOES SO AT A COST
AND THAT MEANS THAT WE NEED TO
CAREFULLY INTERROGATE PROPOSALS
FOR BRINGING LARGE SCALE
HYDROGEN PROJECTS FORWARD BEFORE
COMMITTING TO SUCH A PATH.
DISCUSSION OF COURSE REQUIRES A
CAREFUL BALANCE WE SHOULD BE
FULLY EXPLORING THE SOLUTION
SPACE WE SHOULD NOT BE
PRECLUDING POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS.
THAT SAID. WE'RE ON A TIGHT TIME
LINE WITH LIMITED BY ITS
INVESTMENT APPLE WHICH MEANS
IT'S INCUMBENT ON US TO FULLY
CONSIDER HOW ANY GIVEN SOLUTION
MIGHT FIT INTO A LONG TERM
TRANSITION PLAN. WHEN WE
CONSIDER THAT FULLER PICTURE
SOME SOLUTIONS WILL STAY IN THE
RUNNING BUT SOME THINGS JUST
FALL DOWN. AND WHEN IT COMES TO
HYDROGEN IT'S INCREASINGLY CLEAR
THAT THERE ARE SOME PRODUCTION
PATHWAYS AND SOME END USE
APPLICATIONS THAT JUST WON'T GET
THE JOB DONE. SO TO BE ABLE TO
CONSIDER WHETHER AND HOW
HYDROGEN FITS WITHIN THE ECONOMY
WIDE TO CARBONIZATION PICTURE.
IT'S WORTH CONSIDERING THREE KEY
FACTORS PRODUCTION TRANSMISSION
AND STORAGE AND END USE
PRIORITIZATION. FIRST WHEN IT
COMES TO PRODUCTION WE'VE HEARD
IN SOME OF THESE EARLY PROJECT
PRESENTATIONS CONSIDERATION OF
CARBON INTENSITY. FROM THIS
REFERS TO THE AMOUNT OF CARBON
EMISSIONS- HIGH- HYDROGEN
PRODUCED BOB THIS HAS TO INCLUDE
UPSTREAM EMISSIONS IT'S CRITICAL
THAT WE NOT JUST CONSIDERED THE
POINT OF PRODUCTION. BECAUSE
LETTING IGNORES CRITICAL
INFORMATION THAT CAN GIVE A VERY
MISLEADING PICTURE OF THE CARBON
INTENSITY OF THE FINAL PRODUCT.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT THAT WE NOT
JUST CONSIDER CARBON BUT ALSO
COMPLETES. THE TRANSITION TO OUR
CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE HAS TO BE
TRULY CLEAN NOT JUST DE
CARBONIZED. FINALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO PRODUCTION METHODS IT'S
ALSO VERY IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER
TIGHTENING AND RAMP RATES
SPECIFICALLY HOW FAST AND TO
WHAT DEGREE CAN BE GIVEN
PRODUCTION PATHWAYS SKILLED TO
MEET PROJECTED NEEDS. AND WILL
THE VARIOUS PERFORMANCE LEVELS
THAT ARE BEING PROJECTED SUCH AS
THE LEVEL OF CARBON CAPTURE A
BLUE HYDROGEN PROJECT MIGHT
ACHIEVE ACTUALLY MEET THOSE
TARGETS. WE COMBINE THESE
QUESTIONS YOU START TO HAVE REAL
REAL CONCERNS ABOUT SOME OF THE
PATHWAYS THAT ARE OUT THERE AND
WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO REALLY
FULLY. CONSIDER THEM BEFORE
TAKING A FULLY ACKNOWLEDGE STICK
APPROACH. SECOND WHEN IT COMES
TO TRANSMISSION DISTRIBUTION AND
STORAGE IT'S IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT HYDROGEN LEAKS
. THERE ARE SAFETY CONCERNS THAT
COME WITH IT. AND THERE'S
INCREASING INFORMATION COMING
OUT THE POTENTIAL OF HYDROGEN TO
SERVICES INDIRECT. GREENHOUSE
GAS POLLUTION. THAT MEANS WE
NEED FAR BETTER INFORMATION AND
TRACKING ABOUT HYDROGEN LEAKAGE
TO BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND THE
DEGREE TO WHICH THIS MIGHT
ACTUALLY FURTHER IMPACT THE
CARBON AT THE GLOBAL WARMING
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT HYDROGEN MAY
OR MAY NOT HELP DRIVE DOWN. BOB
IT'S ALSO GREAT HYDROGEN HAS
SOME INEFFICIENCIES AND STORAGE
AND SPACE CONSTRAINTS- THE PILOT
PROJECTS THAT ARE COMING ONLINE
THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED
WILL BE IMPORTANT TO COLLECT
GRANULAR DATA ON AND TO FULLY
CONSIDER WHAT'S COMING DOWN THE
LINE. AND FINALLY IT COMES TO
THE STRATEGIC PRIORITIZATION AND
USES. WE KNOW THE HYDROGEN HAS
VALUE WE KNOW THAT IT HAS AN
IMPORTANT ROLE TO PLAY. BUT HE
INEFFICIENCY OF ITS PRODUCTION
METHOD MEANS THAT VALUE COMES AT
THE COST. ESPECIALLY IN THE NEAR
TERM WE SHOULD BE PLACING A
LARGE PREMIUM ON THE STRATEGIC
PRIORITIZATION OF ITS USE.
BECAUSE SUPPLIES WILL BE LIMITED
WE SHOULD BE DIRECTING HYDROGEN
TO WHERE THERE IS GREATEST
VALUE. AND THAT INCLUDES
CONSIDERING WHERE THERE WILL BE
STEALING OPPORTUNITIES AND WHERE
THERE WILL BE DENNIS. SO EVEN
THOUGH HYDROGEN CAN PLAY A ROLE
IN EVERY SECTOR. AT AT POSSIBLY.
YOU KNOW ACT COST ANY GIVEN
SKILL IT SHOULD NOT AND THERE
WILL BE REAL COSTS WERE WE TO
COMMIT TO SUCH A WIDE SCALE USE
. IN FACT WHEN WE CAN DIRECTLY
ELECTRIFIED WE ALWAYS SHOULD
BECAUSE THE EFFICIENCY GAINS
WILL HELP US DISPLACE FOSSIL
FUELS FASTER. SO WE SHOULD
ALWAYS CONSIDER HYDROGEN I
TESTING SECTORAL CONSIDERATIONS
WITH IN OUR BROADER ECONOMY WIDE
ASSESSMENT TO REALLY UNDERSTAND
HOW NEARER EVALUATIONS OF WHERE
HYDROGEN MANY OR MAY NOT PLAY A
ROLE IN A GIVEN SECTOR HOW THAT
ALIGNS WITH THE BIGGER PICTURE
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT OTHER AND
USES FOR HYDROGEN MIGHT BE USED.
INSTEAD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF THAT WAS OUR LAST
PANELISTS I'D LIKE TO GO TO SEE
IF ANY MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS MISTER MURATSUCHI.
THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR I WAS FOLLOWING THE FIRST
PANEL. BY BROADCAST AND SO I
APPRECIATE THIS VERY IMPORTANT
TO A HEARING. I FIRST HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS FOR THE MR NAVIN WITH
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GAS
COMPANY. IF HE IS AVAILABLE GO
AHEAD AND ASK IF THEY'LL POP
THEM OUT HERE TAUGHT OKAY ALL
RIGHT- SO MISTER NAV AND YOU.
DESCRIBE THE- WHAT SOUNDS LIKE A
VERY EXCITING NEW PROJECT
ANGELES LINK POTENTIALLY THE
LARGEST PRODUCER OF GREEN
HYDRATION AND YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE- HELLO B. WELL COULD YOU
TALK MORE ABOUT HOW- BASICALLY
THAT THE THAT THAT GREEN
HYDRATION- WOULD DO A WEE BIT
WOULD BE PRODUCED. CERTAINLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF THAT GREEN
HYDROGEN WOULD BE PRODUCED FROM
A CURTAILED. AND NEW BUILD-
RENEWABLE ENERGY SO THAT'S
SIMILAR TRADITIONAL RENEWABLES.
WHAT SOURCED FROM AREAS OF HIGH
OTHER HIGH SOLAR IRRADIANCE OR A
HIGH WIND WITHIN THE STATE SO
THOSE AREAS. OF THE STATE. THAT
TOWARD ARE CURRENTLY- PROVIDE A
SIGNAL AMOUNT OF RENEWABLE
ELECTRICITY SO WOULD LOOK TO OUR
- HE IS CURRENTLY CURTAIL OUR-
BOB AND NEW BEEN BUILT SOLAR AND
WIND TO PRODUCE GREEN HYDROGEN
AND MOVE THE MOVE THAT HYDROGEN.
INTO THE LOS ANGELES BASIN WHERE
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT OFFTAKE
POTENTIAL INCLUDING- THE LOS
ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND
POWER. DISPATCHABLE ELECTRIC
GENERATION BUT ALSO HEAVY DUTY-
TRANSPORTATION THAT COMES IN AND
OUT OF THE PORT THAT'S CURRENTLY
FUELED BY LARGELY DIESEL TRUCKS
- THAT COULD BE TRANSITION TO
FUEL CELL VEHICLES FOR THOSE
LONGER HAUL ROCKS. UP AND THAT
ALSO TO- A HEAVY DUTYINDUSTRY
MANUFACTURING THAT CURRENTLY
EXIST WITHIN THE BASIN WELL THAT
WELL AT SOME POINT NEED TO
DECARBONISE. ABOUT MAY NEED- SO
EVEN THOUGH YOU REPRESENT THE
GAS COMPANY. YOU'RE ENVISIONING
THEY THE PROPOSAL FOR THE
ANGELES LANG DOES NOT INVOLVE
ANY USE OF NATURAL GAS IN THE
PRODUCTION OF GREEN HYDROGEN.
WELL THAT'S CURRENT IN THE
INTENT OF THE PROJECT IS
ACTUALLY TO SOURCE OUR GREEN
HYDROGEN SO HYDROGEN FROM OUR-
EXISTING RENEWABLES NEWBUILD
RENEWABLES AND TO BRING THAT
HYDROGEN INTO THE PREVIOUS AND-
SOME ALTERNATELY THE END EFFECT
WOULD BE TO DISPLACE- EXISTING
NATURAL GAS. USE WITHIN THE
BASE. WHAT IS YOUR- PROPOSED
TIME LINE IN TERMS OF BRING IN
THIS ANGELES FLANK. ONLINE AND-
WHAT WHAT WHAT ARE YOU- THE
MAJOR OBSTACLES THEY USE AND FOR
C. N. N. GETTING THIS UP AND
RUNNING. CERTAINLY WE- NUMBER OF
WEEKS AGO SUBMITTED AN
APPLICATION TO THE CQC OR
MINIMAL CAL ESSENTIALLY AN
ACCOUNT THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO.
START THE PLANNING PROCESS. AND
THIS WOULD BE A STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT PROCESS THAT WOULD
LOOK TO INCLUDE- LEGISLATORS
REGULATORS- THE ENVIRONMENTAL
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES. UP TO. LOOK AT THE
SCOPE AND SCALE OF THE
APPLICATION OF GREEN HYDROGEN
WITHIN THE LOS ANGELES BASED. SO
WE WOULD PROPOSE A MULTI PHASE
PROCESS TO MOSCOW AND- AND ROUTE
THE PIPELINE AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT GOES WITH IT
LOOKING AT THE OFF TAKERS-
ENVIRONMENTAL STAKEHOLDERS AND
THE PRODUCERS AS WELL. SO WE
LOOK AT A PHASED APPROACH TO
SCOPING AND THEN ULTIMATELY ONCE
THE SCOPING WAS COMPLETE WE'VE
LEFT AT SOME POINT IN THE FUTURE
APPLY TO- TO BUILD UP THE
FACILITIES. SO WHEN YOU WHEN YOU
SAY YOU'RE GOING TO BE THE P.
YOU SEE HERE ARE YOU ARE YOU
BASICALLY. PROPOSING THAT
RATEPAYERS PAY FOR THIS ANGELES
FLANK. HELLO NOT WORD. AT THE
MOMENT WE'RE LOOKING AT SCOPING
THE PROJECT- AND THEN WE WOULD
LOOK TO. AT SOME POINT IN THE
FUTURE LOOK AT THE- OF THE
ENTITIES THAT DERIVE THE BENEFIT
FROM THE- OUR PLANET FOR
STRUCTURE AND ULTIMATELY THE
COST WOULD ACCRUE TO THOSE-
ENTITIES ULTIMATELY THOUGH THAT.
WOULD LIKELY REQUIRE EIGHT EIGHT
NUMBER TO DETERMINE RATES
SOMETHING FROM US BECAUSE
INITIAL. COULD YOU IDENTIFY THE
MAIN CATEGORIES OF THOSE
ENTITIES THAT WOULD BE PAYING
FOR THIS WHAT ANGELES LINK. ONE
ONE COULD ENVISION- DISPATCHABLE
POWER GENERATION IF YOU DO THE
INDUSTRY AND. THEN THE ONLY-
ATTENTIONS. ARE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
PANELISTS SO I'LL ASK A WHILE
YOU'RE ON THE SCREEN I THINK I
WILL ASK YOU- YOU MENTIONED
SOURCING THE GREEN HYDROGEN I
WAS A LITTLE UNCLEAR WHETHER
YOU'RE PRODUCING IT OR WHETHER
YOU'RE PURCHASING IT AND BRING
IT IN. WE CERTAINLY A SECOND
GAS- WOULD- YOURSELVES LARGELY
AS- A CONNECTION BETWEEN.
PRODUCTION AND- AND USERS SO WE
WOULD NOT UNTO OURSELVES I'M
SUGGEST THAT WE WOULD REDUCE THE
GRADUATION SO WE CAN BE
SOURCING. THE HYDROGEN FROM THE
DEVELOPERS THAT WOULD LOVE TO.
EITHER INCLUDE DIVERSION AS PART
OF THEIR EXISTING. RENEWABLES
GENERATION. IN INDOOR. THE NEW
BUILT CONSTRUCTION SO WE UNTIL
OURSELVES WOULD NOT BE A
PRODUCING HYDROGEN THE MIST
THANK YOU KNOW YOU MENTIONED A
VARIETY OF END USES- YOU
MENTIONED HEAVY INDUSTRY YOU
MENTIONED TRANSPORTATION I THINK
TRANSPORTATION FUEL. BUT THERE'S
ALSO THIS CONCEPT OF YOU YOU
ALSO MENTION THOUGH BRINGING
INTO HOMES SO DOES THAT IS THAT
STILL THE IDEA THAT YOU BLEND IT
WITH NATURAL GAS THEN AND REDUCE
THE NATURAL GAS USE BY 7% OR
SOMETHING OR IS THIS A TWO
DIFFERENT IDEA FOR. SO ANGELES
LINK ITSELF WOULD NOT THOSE
THOSE MOLECULES WOULD NOT BE
USED FOR HOMES WHAT WILL LIKELY
HAVE A PARALLEL EFFORT TO LOOK
AT THE VIABILITY OF. A BLENDING
IS I THINK ONE OF THEM ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MENTIONED BUT THE
ANGELES LINK ITSELF IS INTENDED
TO BE A- GREEN HYDROGEN I
FLYING. IT WOULD SERVE THE HARD
TO ELECTRIFY SOME SECTORS OF THE
LOS ANGELES REGION SO IT'S A
PHYSICAL PIPELINE THAT THEN YOU
SOURCE HYDROGEN. AND YOU BRING
UP THE PIPELINE INTO LOS ANGELES
AND THEN YOU BECOME A
DISTRIBUTION CENTER. FOR ALL
THOSE DIFFERENT AND USES THAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT SET THE
IDEA LOW YES CURRENT MANAGER YES
GOT IT THANK YOU NOW THAT'S AYE.
AYE IT'S IT IT IS VERY
INTERESTING. I'M LET ME GO BACK
COULD I FOLLOW- JUST. LET ME
FINISH THE QUESTIONS WE CAN ASK
WHOEVER YOU YOU WANT TO ASK
QUESTIONS TO. YEAH THAT'S OKAY
MISTER LEVIN WHY DON'T YOU ASK
THE QUESTION OF ME WHY DON'T YOU
ANSWER THE QUESTION THAT YOU
WANTED US TO ASK YOU- REGARDING
THE HYDROGEN HUBS YES. CHAIR
FRIEDMAN- SO FIRST OF ALL WE'RE
VERY GRATIFIED THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS FINALLY REALLY
STEPPING THROUGH FORWARD WITH. A
VERY AGGRESSIVE PROGRAM. TO
INCREASE THE SCALE IN PRODUCTION
OF HYDROGEN- THERE ARE THREE
COMPONENTS TO THAT PROGRAM ONE
IS PRODUCTION. THE OTHERS
DISTRIBUTION IN THE THIRD IS OFF
OFFTAKE WHERE IS THAT HYDROGEN
GOING TO GO. UP THE SPEAKER FROM
THE UCS. UCS MADE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT THERE ARE STILL MANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT. HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION AND THE WHOLE
MANAGEMENT OF HYDROGEN IN ORDER
TO ENSURE A CLEAN SOURCE. AND SO
THAT HAS TO BE A FACTOR THAT HAS
BEEN EMPHASIZED VERY STRONGLY
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE OUR STATE HAS BEEN A
LEADER IN MOVING THIS TECHNOLOGY
FORWARD AND I SPOKE OF ONE OF
THE PROJECTS WERE INVOLVED IN.
THERE ARE SEVERAL OTHERS AS
WELL. WE ARE IN THE BEST
POSITION. TO LEVERAGE TO PROVIDE
COST SHARE. AND LEVERAGE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FUNDING MY
GUESS IS FROM WHAT WE BURDEN-
YOUR WORKSHOPS. IS THERE. THEIR
FOCUS IS GOING TO BE ON
PRODUCTION AND DISTRIBUTION. A
TO INCREASE THE SCALE OF
RODUCTION. UP BUT IN ORDER TO
MATCH THAT WE NEED. TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE APPROPRIATE OR
SIGNIFICANT OFFTAKE. AND I THINK
CALIFORNIA IS IN A VERY GOOD
POSITION. TO COST SHARE THAT
OFFTAKE PORTION OF IT WE'RE VERY
FAR ADVANCED MORE THAN ANY OTHER
STATE. IN SOME CASES
INTERNATIONALLY WITH RESPECT TO
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
UTILIZING HYDROGEN FOR THOSE
PURPOSES. SO I WOULD HOPE THE
CALIFORNIA IN ITS STRATEGY TO BE
ONE OF THE HUBS AND I IT WELL
THE INITIAL LEGISLATION TALKED
ABOUT FOUR HUBS AT ROUGHLY TWO
BILLION DOLLARS PER HUB. THE
LATEST DISCUSSIONS IN THE
WORKSHOPS WITH DEAL WE IS
SOMEWHERE AROUND TEN TEN HOBBS
THAT COULD BE FUNDED UPWARDS OF
A HALF A BILLION TO A BILLION
DOLLARS AT 50% COST SHARE. SO
THESE ARE PROJECTS THAT ARE ONE
TO TWO BILLION DOLLARS
CALIFORNIA IS IN A VERY GOOD
POSITION TO THE PROPERTY COST
SHARE THAT. BUT IN DOING THAT
IT'S GOING TO BE IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S OFF TAKE FOR
THAT FUEL AND WE ARE IN A VERY
GOOD POSITION. TO EXPAND SUCH AS
THE PROJECT I SPOKE OF EARLIER.
OF THIRTY TRUCKS TO BUILD TWO
HUNDRED OR FOUR HUNDRED TRUCKS
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO TAKE THAT
OFF TAKE AND MAKE A REAL
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF THE
IMPACT ON CRITERIA MISSIONS ON
PORCH IN THE LIGHT. SO I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE CALIFORNIA LOOKING
AT WAYS TO LEVERAGE ITS
RESOURCES. TO GO AFTER THE
FEDERAL FUNDING I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANY DOUBT THE CALIFORNIA
SHOULD AND CAN BE ONE OF THOSE
HUBS THE LAST POINT I WOULD MAKE
IS THAT THERE IS NOT A LARGE
NETWORK OF PIPELINES THAT IS.
CLEARLY ONE OF THE POTENTIAL
POTENTIALLY CHEAPEST WAYS OF
MOVING HYDROGEN. SO WITHOUT THAT
PIPELINE WHICH DOES EXIST IN
MUCH GREATER. NUMBERS IN TEXAS
OKLAHOMA IN THE STATES ARE
PRIMARILY ARE REFINED REORIENTED
WE NEED TO MOVE IT WITH
TRANSPORTATION AND
TRANSPORTATION. DOES COST
CRITERIA MISSIONS WHEN YOU
TRANSPORT BY TRUCK. BUT HERE WE
NOW HAVE FUEL CELL TRUCKS THAT
WE BELIEVE CAN MOVE THAT FUEL.
WITH ZERO EMISSIONS IN THE
TRANSPORTATION OF IT SO THAT'S
ANOTHER COMPONENT OF IT THAT I
THINK WE CAN LEAD THE WAY IN
DOING THAT. THANK YOU I'D LIKE
TO ASK A QUESTION OF MS
MCNAMARA- YOU MENTIONED. THE
NECESSITY FOR US TO EVALUATE
EMISSIONS NOT JUST OUT
PRODUCTION BUT THROUGH THE WHOLE
A CHAIN OF USE OF HYDROGEN AND I
WAS JUST CURIOUS GIVEN THAT IT'S
A ZERO EMISSION FUEL WHAT YOU
MEAN BY THAT EXACTLY. WHAT WHAT
WOULD BE THE MISSED EMISSIONS
DOWN THE ROAD THAT YOU'RE
THINKING OF. SURE SO. WHEN WE
THINK OF HYDROGEN'S USE ADS IN A
FUEL CELL VEHICLE FOR EXAMPLE
YOU WON'T HAVE THE MISSIONS ARE
RIGHT FROM THE TAIL PIPE ONLY
WATER. FOUND BUT WE THINK ABOUT
HOW TO HOW THAT HYDROGEN IS
PRODUCED YOU COULD HAVE
ELECTROLYTIC DRIVEN FULLY BY
RENEWABLE SIR USING CLEAN
ELECTRICITY TO SPLIT WATER AND
THERE ARE NO EMISSIONS. FROM BUT
THERE ARE ALSO DISCUSSIONS AS
THE FIRST PRESENTATION MENTIONED
OF USING NATURAL GAS FOR EXAMPLE
STEAM METHANE REFORMING THE
PRIMARY METHOD OF PRODUCING.
HYDROGEN TODAY RIGHT. YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE PRODUCTION AND
YOU'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT LEADER
DOWN DOWNSTREAM I THINK I MAY
HAVE MISSED. IT YES I DID
MENTION IT YOU'RE YOU'RE RIGHT I
WAS TALKING ABOUT PRODUCTION
THERE IS ALSO THE POTENTIAL.
LEAKAGE OF HYDROGEN WHICH IS NOW
THE SUBJECT OF A DISCUSSION
PAPER. AND GROWING STUDY- THE
DEGREE TO WHICH HYDROGEN IS AN
INDIRECT GLOBAL WARMING
POLLUTANT AND SO IT'S ALL
LEAKAGE CAN ALSO CONTRIBUTE. TO
GLOBAL WARMING MUCH LIKE NOTHING
HAVE WE- HOW- RAPE OR THOSE
STUDIES I MEAN DO WE HAVE ANY
INDICATION OF HOW IT WOULD
COMPARE FOR INSTANCE TO METHANE
OR NATURAL GAS. WHEN IT THE IN
ITS LEAKAGE PROFILE AND I'M I'M
NOT SAYING WHETHER AT LEAST MORE
I'M SAYING WHEN IT DOES WHAT'S
THE COME WHAT'S THE SORT OF
COMPARISON OF DAMAGE DONE AND IS
IT A GREENHOUSE GAS.
CONTRIBUTORS IT'S NOT BUT THE
WAY IT FUNCTIONS AS AS AN
INDIRECT POLLUTANT SO FOR
EXAMPLE ONE OF THOSE PATHWAYS
DESPITE. I'M INTERFERING WITH
THE MOLECULES THAT BREAKS DOWN
METHANE SO MAKING EXISTS IN THE
ATMOSPHERE OR LONGER. THERE IS
RESEARCH. AND SOME UNDERSTANDING
ALREADY TODAY. OF HYDROGENS
GENERAL HOWEVER THERE'S ONLY A
MERGING RESEARCH NOW THAT STILL
GOING THROUGH. PUBLICATION AND I
THINK THERE'S BEEN A FEW OUT BUT
THEY'RE STILL. CERTAINLY UNDER
DISCUSSION- ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
FOR IT ESPECIALLY IF YOU LOOK AT
SHORTER TIMELINES. THE HOBBIT
OUTSIZED EFFECT MUCH LIKE WE
THINK OF MATTHEW RIGHT WE LOOK
AT A SHORTER TIMELINE COMPARED
TO CARBON DIOXIDE. IT HAS A HIGH
GLOBAL WARMING POTENTIAL IF YOU%
LOOK OVER THE LONGER PERIOD THIS
IS LESS. I WOULD JUST REITERATE
I THINK IT'S AN AREA OF
IMPORTANT RESEARCH I THINK IT'S
AN IMPORTANT AREA TO TRACK- THEM
BUT. BUT BUT IT IS NOT SETTLED.
OKAY YOU KNOW IT IT'S- I FULLY
UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE TO BE
VERY AWARE AS WE MOVE INTO THESE
TECHNOLOGIES OF. UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND OF ANY OF THEIR
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS- IT IS
INTERESTING TO ME AND I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU WANT TO ANSWER THIS
OR NOT THAT IT'S INTERESTING
THAT HYDROGEN IS KIND OF GETTING
SO MUCH SCRUTINY. WHEN AND AS
SOMEONE WHO DEFINITELY SUPPORTS-
EVEY TECHNOLOGY IN
ELECTRIFICATION- YEAH I THINK
THERE'S ALSO A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A LECTURE
ELECTRIFICATION WHERE YOU HAVE A
RENEWABLE SOURCE AND YOU'RE-
PUTTING INTO YOUR GRID AND POWER
IN YOUR HOME WITH IT. AND THE
IMPACT THAT WE SEE FOR MINING
FOR LITHIUM AND THINGS THAT
POWER OF THIS THE KIND OF STATIC
BATTERIES THAT GO INTO ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. SO I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS ARE WE- YES WE NEED TO BE
SKEPTICAL OR WE NEED TO BE
CONCERNED BUT ARE WE PUTTING
HYDROGEN THROUGH HOOPS THAT
WE'RE NOT PUTTING. ELECTRIC
BATTERIES THROUGH- I YOU KNOW I
JUST I'VE NEVER HEARD. YOU KNOW
ENVIRONMENTALISTS COME IN
RAISING SO MANY CONCERNS ABOUT
ELECTRIC CARS AS I SEEM TO BE
HEARING ABOUT HYDROGEN AND I'M
JUST WONDERING. IF YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENT ABOUT THAT. SURE I
APPRECIATE THAT QUESTION AND YET
I CAN'T SPEAK FOR ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. BOTH WHAT I CAN
SAY IS WHERE ICS NOW STANDING ON
THE THRESHOLD OF SIGNIFICANT
ENERGY TRANSITION WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO LOOK BACK AND
SEE THAT MISSTEPS WE'VE MADE TO
DATE THAT THINGS WE SHOULD HAVE
SEEN AND DID NOT BEFORE WE
COMMITTED TO PATHWAYS SUCH AS
ARE FAR GREATER UNDERSTANDING
NOW OF METHANE LEAKAGE FROM
NATURAL GAS SYSTEM. AB ORDERED
PROTECT THE CRITERIA AIR
POLLUTANTS FROM COMBUSTION SOME
FORMS OF FOSSIL FUELS COMPARED
TO OTHERS WHEN WE TAKE THIS
BROADER PERSPECTIVE AND WE LOOK
AT THE LOCAL AIR POLLUTION WE
LOOK AT THE- BROADER
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS WE CAN SEE
WE MIGHT HAVE TAKEN A DIFFERENT
PATH THAN. BUT TODAY WE'RE
STANDING HERE LOOKING AT THIS
BROAD SUITE OF SOLUTIONS
AVAILABLE TO US OR WE HAVE TIME
ON THE LINE RIGHT WE KNOW WE
WANT TO TAKE THE BEST POSSIBLE
PATH. HOW DO WE MAKE SURE WE'RE
TRULY THINKING ABOUT ALL THE
POTENTIAL IMPLICATIONS BEFORE WE
COMMIT TO POWER AGAIN I DO WANT
TO REITERATE THAT THE START OF
MY COMMENTS IT DIDN'T. TRY TO
EMPHASIZE THE FACT THAT WE
SHOULD NOT BE PARALYZED BY THESE
CONCERNS WE HAVE TO KEEP THE
SUITE OF SOLUTIONS OPEN BUT WE
SHOULDN'T DO IT WITH A NARROW
MINDSET WHERE WE WHERE WE GET
MORE WHAT COULD REALLY HELPED
SHAPE A BETTER PASSWORD. YEAH
AND YOU ALSO MADE THE POINT I
THINK THAT'S VERY GOOD POINT
THAT WE KNOW WHAT WHAT SECTORS
ARE MORE DIFFICULT TO
DECARBONISE AND FOCUSING ON
THOSE WITH THIS RELATIVELY NEW
TECHNOLOGY I MEAN MAYBE IT'S NOT
RELATIVELY NEW BUT AT LEAST ARE
SORT OF. COMPREHENSIVE AND
HOLISTIC UNDERSTANDING OF THE
IMPACTS ARE STILL DEVELOPING
THAT FOCUSING ON THE THINGS THAT
WE KNOW WE'RE GOING TO BE
TOUGHER RATHER THAN THE ONES
THAT. YOU KNOW OUR EASIER DEALT
WITH WITH OTHER ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES. MAYBE IS- CAN IT
NEEDS TO CONTINUE TO BE THE FOLK
AYE A- THAT PERSPECTIVE WELL- I
WILL GO TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT WHO I THINK HAS SOME
QUESTIONS AS WELL. THANK THANK
YOU FOR THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
GAS REPRESENTATIVE AND THEN I'D
LIKE TO COME BACK TO THE UNION
OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS TO
REPRESENTATIVE. RATHER THAN A
SWITCHING I'M HAPPY TO SWITCH MY
ORDER QUESTIONS BUT WE LOVE
THAT- IT WILL. I REALIZE THAT
SHE'S ON THE SCREEN ALL RIGHT
LET ME JUST WHICH MY ORDER
QUESTIONS HERE AND IF- IF THAT'S
OKAY- I APPRECIATE THE- QUESTION
THAT- MADAM CHAIR- ASKED ABOUT-
THE SCRUTINY IT YOU KNOW IN
TERMS OF HYDROGEN AND WAS GOING
FORWARD- THE- N. I. I AGREE WITH
YOU WE SHOULD ALWAYS BE TRYING
TO- IDENTIFY WATER THE UNKNOWNS
AS AS AS WE MOVE FORWARD. OF
STRIVE COUPLE QUICK QUESTIONS
ARE ONE ARE THE EUROPEANS WHO
SEEM TO BE MUCH FURTHER DOWN THE
ROAD ON HYDROGEN AND WE ARE ARE
THEY IDENTIFYING HYDROGEN AS A-
AS A YOU KNOW AS AN-
ENVIRONMENTAL PROBLEM OR IS JUST
IS JUST MOSTLY JUST BE BEING
IDENTIFIED AS SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD BE RESEARCH. BUT NOBODY'S
ACTUALLY YOU KNOW NOBODY THAT'S
FURTHER DOWN THE ROAD IS
IDENTIFYING IT AS AN ACTUAL
PROBLEM. I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION- THIS IS A VERY ACTIVE
POINT OF DISCUSSION IN EUROPE-
AND IN FACT I WOULD- SUGGESTS
THAT THEY ARE PURSUING FAR MORE
AMBITIOUS STANDARDS WHEN IT
COMES TO THE CURRENT INTENSITY
AND OVERALL- PRODUCTION PICTURE.
AND ENTITIES PICTURE OF
HYDROGEN- COMPARED TO WHERE WE
ARE AT. THE NATIONAL LEVEL TODAY
I WILL SAY THERE ARE SOME GOOD
INITIATIVES NOW UNDERWAY. I'M
HERE BUT I WOULD SAY WE'RE INTO
CATCH UP MODE AND- WHAT WE
CONSIDERED MANY OF THE PROPOSALS
THAT HAVE COME UP AND I SPEAK
ACROSS THE COUNTRY I DON'T SPEAK
JUST TO CALIFORNIA. WE'VE SEEN
OUR OWN LARGE BIASED TOWARDS
NATURAL GAS BASED HYDROGEN
SOLUTIONS. AND CALCULATIONS THAT
WOULD ALLOW HYDROGEN FROM THOSE
FORMS HERE THAT WOULD NEVER PASS
THE TEST IN EUROPE I'M SO
DISAPPOINTED JUST WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT TRADE THAT THEY WOULDN'T
QUALIFY GREAT AS I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THAT FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF PRODUCTION AS
MADAME BETTER. IDENTIFIED IF
IT'S THE QUESTION OF ARE YOU
GOING TO PRODUCE IT WITH
SOMETHING ELSE WITH A FOSSIL
FUEL VERSUS IF YOU'RE A PRODUCER
WITH RENEWABLES BUT WHAT IS NEW
TO ME THAT I'M HEARING FOR THE
FIRST TIME IS JUST THE ACTUAL
PRODUCING OF HYDROGEN NO MATTER
HOW YOU PRODUCE IF YOU PRODUCE
IT WITH RENEWABLES THE IDEA THAT
IT MIGHT LEAK AND MIGHT CAUSE A
PROBLEM. AT LEAST AT THIS POINT
TIME I WANT TO PUT IN THE
CATEGORY OF THAT'S A RESEARCH
POSSIBILITY BUT THERE'S NO.
EVIDENCE OF THAT YET IS THAT
CORRECT. HELLO WE'VE ALSO SEEN
IT M. THE STATE AS A POTENTIAL
SENSITIVITY TO INCLUDE IN SOME
COUNTRIES ANALYSES OF THE- OF
THE PICTURE THE OTHER. THE OTHER
WAY I'D SAY THAT EUROPE HAS BEEN
FULLY CONSIDERING HYDROGEN IS BY
PURSUING THE STRATEGIC ROADMAPS
THAT LOOK KIND OF THE WIDE AND
THEN SECTOR BY SECTOR WITHIN
SURE I STARTED TO BE HARD TO
HEAR THIS EARLIER PRESENTATION
THAT INCLUDED A CONSIDERATION OF
THE BIGGER PICTURE OF HYDROGEN
BECAUSE THAT HELPS GUIDE BEFORE
COURSE GREAT THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE AND I DON'T MEAN TO
CATCH UP ON YOU KNOW WE'RE
TRYING TO. GET TO GET THROUGH
ALL THE STUFF THAT HE IS THERE
AN EQUAL CONCERN ON THE EASY
SIDE ABOUT. IF IMAGINE IF WE
HAVE BATTERY TECHNOLOGY AS WE
ELECTRIFY VIRTUALLY EVERYTHING
AS- NIKOL CONCERN ABOUT THE
RECYCLING OF ALL THESE BATTERIES
ABOUT THE POTENTIAL FOR THE
MINING OF ALL THE RARE EARTH
MINERALS- FOR THE BATTERY
TECHNOLOGY IS THAT ALSO. EQUALLY
BEING A POINT OF CONCERNS AND
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO HAVE
FURTHER RESEARCH I HEAR BROUGHT
UP FOR HYDROGEN IN THIS HEARING
I DON'T HEAR THAT BROUGHT UP-
FOR THEBATTERY SIDE OF THIS
ALSO. WE'RE SIT THIS IS A IN
IMPORTANT POINT OF CONVERSATION
AND YES THE SOURCING AS WELL AS
THE END USE RECYCLING. OF
MATERIALS THROUGHOUT THE CLEAN
ENERGY SUPPLY CHAIN FROM
ELECTRIC VEHICLES TO SOLAR
PANELS THINKING ABOUT ALL THE
FEES. HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE MAKING THAT THAT SUPPLY
CHAIN CLEANER MORE DEFINITELY
PERCEIVED THANK YOU AND DAN I
APPRECIATE THAT WE ALL ARE
WRESTLING WITH THIS QUESTION.
AND I THINK I CAPTURED IT IN
WHAT YOU SAID I JUST WANT TO
CONFIRM THAT AND THAT IS. WE
HAVE THIS RACE AND THAT WE COULD
WAIT TOO LONG. AND STUDY AND
HAVE THE CLIMB IT GETS SO BAD
THAT IT IT'S MAKES IT LESS
MEANINGFUL WHAT CHANGES WE MAKE
WE ALL KNOW THAT WE THERE'S WE
HAVE A LIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME.
AND SO WE HAVE A TRADE OFF TO
HOW INTENSELY. DO WE DO THE
RESEARCH FOR SIS- YOU KNOW DOING
SOMETHING AND THEN IF WE SEE A
PROBLEM TRYING TO ADJUST FROM
THERE SO THAT WE AT LEAST
ADJUST. IT AM I CORRECT THAT
YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE RECOGNIZING
THAT ALSO AND THAT'S WH YOU'RE
SAYING FOCUSING ENERGY ON THE
MOST VALUABLE USES OF SOMETHING
LIKE HYDROGEN- SO THAT WE CAN
GET MOVING. AND THEN TURN AROUND
AND- CONTINUE TO DO THE RESEARCH
AND IF THERE'S A PROBLEM COME
FROM THERE MY CORRECTOR. THAT'S
EXACTLY RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I REALLY APPRECIATE THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS YES MISTER MAYOR
CITY. THANK YOU I STAYING WITH
THEM AS MCNAB ARE A- AND
FOLLOWING MISTER BENNETT'S LINE
OF QUESTIONS- I WAS AT A RECENT
CONFERENCE WHERE- THE POTENTIAL
FOR GREEN HYDROGEN NOT ONLY. AS
A- TRANSPORTATION FUEL BUT ALSO
AS A FORM OF ENERGY STORAGE WAS
DISCUSSED GREG GOOD COULD YOU
TALK ABOUT THE- YOU KNOW THE-
EFFECTIVENESS OF- GREEN HYDROGEN
STORING. WIND AND SOLAR ENERGY.
VERSES BATTERY STORAGE. THANK
YOU I'M. HYDROGEN IS ARE LESS
EFFICIENT A STORAGE MECHANISM
THAT BATTERY STORAGE HOWEVER IT
DOES HAVE THE ABILITY TO BE
STORED AND LARGE VOLUMES AND FOR
LONG PERIODS WHICH MEANS THAT IT
IS UNLIKELY THAT HYDROGEN AND
BATTERIES WILL GO HEAD TO HEAD
FOR THE SAME PURPOSE BUT IN THE
POWER SECTOR BUT WE CAN IMAGINE
PERHAPS FOR SEASONAL STORAGE
WHERE WE HAVE LARGE PRODUCTIONS
RIGHT IT IS SAFE FOR SOLAR- BUT
WE HAVE. OVERPRODUCTION AT
CERTAIN PERIODS OF THE YEAR ARE
WE CAN TURN THAT INTO HYDROGEN
AND STORING AND THEN USED IT
DURING PERIODS WHEN WE MAY HAVE
LESS RENEWABLE ABUNDANCE PROBLEM
AND THAT STAGE JUST WITHIN THE
POWER SECTOR. OR IT CAN BE
BROUGHT AS IT'S BEEN DISCUSSED
TODAY ACROSS OTHER SECTORS AS A
WAY TO TAKE THAT CLEAN
ELECTRICITY AND USABLE SQUARE.
THANK YOU AND- IN IN TERMS OF-
STATE INVESTMENTS ZERO EMISSION
. VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE- IN THE COMMITTEE
REPORT THAT WE HAVE THAT THAT
WAS SHARED FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THERE IS A SUMMARY OF A RECENT
REPORT BY EARTH JUSTICE. THAT
THAT FOCUSES ON YOU KNOW THE.
THE DIFFICULT TO DECARBONISE
SECTORS- LIKE LONG HAUL TRUCKS-
BUT DISCOURAGING- INVESTMENTS-
AND OR OR THE USE OF HYDROGEN OF
FOUR FOUR CARS AND BUSES- IT
WOULDN'T WHICH YOU CAN CURRENT
THAT AND IF SO. YOU KNOW IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FOR THE STATE
TO CONTINUE TO INVEST LIMITED
RESOURCES INTO- HYDROGENFUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR CARS AND
BUSES. YEAH THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
AN IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION ALLEN
WE DON'T WE DO THINK THAT THERE
IS SOME ROLE ACROSS ALL THESE
END USES ACROSS CARS AND BUSES
REGIONAL TRUCKS AND SAID HERE.
AB BUT WE DON'T THINK THAT WE
SHOULD WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE
READILY AVAILABLE I HAVE DIRECT
ELECTRIFICATION ALTERNATIVES
TODAY THAT ARE RAMPING WITH
INCREDIBLE SPEED AND COST
EFFECTIVENESS SO WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT. HOW TO PURSUE THE FORWARD
COURSE WE ARE NOT SUGGESTING
PRECLUDING THESE AS AS VIABLE
TECHNOLOGIES BUT WE CERTAINLY
DON'T THINK THAT INVESTMENTS
SHOULD BE STALLED ON BEHALF.
RIGHT JUST WAITING FOR THEM TO
CATCH UP. I'M WE THINK LIKELY
MOST OF THESE WILL BE DISH
APPLICATIONS THAT IT WILL BE A
VERY SMALL SHARE VEHICLES THAT
WILL BE LIKE TO BE A COSTS THAT
WILL BE NITROGEN BUT THERE IS
THE POTENTIAL FOR SEVERAL- AND
SO JUST THINKING ABOUT
INVESTMENTS IN LINE WITH THAT
BALANCING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DOES ANYBODY ELSE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OKAY WE'RE GONNA MOVE
NOW TO PUBLIC COMMENT BEFORE WE
DO I'D LIKE TO THANK OUR
PANELISTS FROM BOTH PANELS WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR SHARING
YOUR TIME AND YOUR EXPERTISE AND
I CAN TELL BY THE LEVEL OF
ENGAGEMENT FROM THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS THAT YOU SHARED A LOT OF
VERY RELEVANT AND VERY IMPORTANT
INFORMATION WITH US SO THANK YOU
ALL. AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO THE PUBLIC WILL START FIRST
WITH THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND YOU
WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES APIECE
WHICH IS A 100% MORE THAN THE
AMOUNT OF TIME WE NORMALLY GIVE
TO PARTICIPANTS SO TWO MINUTES
EACH AND I ACTUALLY I THINK YOU.
STAYS BACK THERE RIGHT WE'RE
THAT'S OKAY YOU'RE THERE GO FOR
IT I THINK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE TWO MINUTES IN A- TIMELY
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY THERESA
COOK I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN COALITION
OUR MEMBERS REPRESENT-
MANUFACTURERS SPANNING FROM
LIGHT DUTY TO HEAVY DUTY WE ALSO
REPRESENT. I 80% OF THE LIGHT
DUTY HYDROGEN INFRASTRUCTURE
MARKET AND 1100% OF THE HEAVY
DUTY- HYDROGEN INFRASTRUCTURE
MARKET AS WELL AS MAJOR HYDROGEN
PRODUCERS- A COUPLE OF THINGS
ABOUT AMOUNTS AROUND A LOT SO
I'M NUMBER ONE I WANTED TO
FOLLOW UP TO THE DISCUSSION
AROUND HYDROGEN LEAKAGE BY
SHARING A QUOTE THAT COMES FROM
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL- QUOTING A HYDROGEN LEAK
OR SPILL WILL NOT CONTAMINATE
THE ENVIRONMENT OR THREATEN THE
HEALTH OF HUMANS OR WILDLIFE BUT
FOSSIL FUELS COMPOSED
SIGNIFICANT HEALTH AND
ECOLOGICAL THREATS WHEN LEAKED.
SPILLED COMBUSTED THE EUROPEAN
CAN COMMISSION EUROPEAN UNION
HAS DONE AN ANALYSIS ON LEAKAGE
RATES AND SHOWS THAT IT IS
NEGLIGIBLE AND I WILL ALSO POINT
OUT THAT HYDROGEN IS NOT A
GREENHOUSE GAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AT SU CHI YOU ASKED WONDERFUL
QUESTIONS I WOULD REALLY
RECOMMEND YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY FIVE BY FIVE
ANALISIS WHICH WAS DONE. AROUND
THEIR. FLEET OF NATURAL GAS US-
DIESEL BATTERY AND FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLE BUSES WHAT
WE'RE MISSING IN THE DISCUSSION
IS PERFORMANCE THAT SOMETHING
THAT CANNOT BE SACRIFICED
WHETHER YOU'RE TRANSIT DISTRICT
OR WHETHER YOU'RE AN INDIVIDUAL
WHICH WILL TALK ABOUT IN A
MOMENT- SO. ARE A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS MY PAL- I LEFT BUT- WE
WERE CHATTING A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
INCENTIVIZING PRODUCTION AND
MAXIMIZING HOBBS WITH THE IG ME
LEVIN. AND I WANTED TO
UNDERSCORE EVERYTHING THAT HE
SAID BUT REALLY BRING IT BACK TO
SUPPORT FOR AND YOU SAYS WE HAVE
THIS OPPORTUNITY. TO GROW AND
ENERGY TECHNOLOGY TRANSPORTATION
TECHNOLOGY BUT WE NEED TO BE
SUPPORTING AND YOU SAYS SO THREE
HUNDRED MILLION TO FINISH LIGHT
MEDIUM DUTY FUELING NETWORK. BUT
I WILL ALSO POINT OUT THAT 62%
OF THE TEN BILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S BEEN PUT OUT IN THE LAST
TWO YEARS FOR IS I'VE
INFRASTRUCTURE. IS DEDICATED TO
HEAVY DUTY SO I'D LIKE TO SEE
LESS THAN THREE PERCENT. OF
DOLLARS DIRECTED TOWARDS
HYDROGEN WHICH IS HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW INTERCEPT SPENDING AND
I FEEL LIKE THAT BUT AS IT WAS
MEANT FOR ME IT WAS A- OKAY- SO
WHAT'S- ONE CLOSING. COMMENT IF
I MAY. A LOT OF DISCUSSION TODAY
AROUND EFFICIENCY AND IT BEGS
THE QUESTION EFFICIENT FOR HILL
EFFICIENT FOR THE TRANSIT
DISTRICT THAT NEEDS TO HAVE
PERFORMANCE EXPECTATIONS.
EFFICIENT FOR THE HOUSEHOLD THAT
NEEDS TO HAVE IS YOUR MACHINE
VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY THAT CAN TAKE
THEM WHERE THEY NEED TO GO I
WOULD ENCOURAGE THIS COMMITTEE
TO CONSIDER IT THE END USES THE
END GOAL WE'RE TRYING TO
TRANSITION FOLKS TO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES THERE'S NO
REASON IN THE WORLD TO
ARTIFICIALLY LIMIT THOSE AND
USES. THANK YOU THANK YOU AND I
ONLY GIVE YOU MORE TIME BECAUSE
YOU'RE SPEAKING FOR DOZENS OF
COMPANIES SO I SORT OF ADDED
THEM UP. BUT NOBODY ELSE IS
GOING TO GET THAT SO YOU'RE
LISTENING IT WAS THE LAST ONE SO
NEXT A SPEAKER PLEASE MCHALE'S
GROWTH WALKER PARA BEHALF OF
LINDE PLC- WE REPRESENT- EVERY
ASPECT OF THE HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION VALUE CHAIN- FROM
PRODUCTION TO THE REFILLING.
STATION INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING
A LARGE PORTION OF THE
LIQUEFACTION- THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND NATIONALLY- EARLY WE
JUST RECENTLY ONE ELECTROLYZER
WARD FROM THE C. C. AND WEBER
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT. WE'VE
ALSO- DIRECTLY CONTROLLED BIO
GAS TO REFORM THAT TO- RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN FOR THE DELIVERY TO THE
VEHICLE SPACE TODAY THAT THAT IS
A- LOT LOWER THAN ELECTRICITY.
CARBON PATHWAY THAT WE SHOULD
NOT PRECLUDE BECAUSE OF CARBON-
THE HIGH GLOBAL WARMING
POTENTIAL OF. MISSIONS LIKE
METHANE BUT ALSO THERE'S OTHER
INTERESTING PATHWAY SUCH AS
BIOMASS. WHICH COULD HELP
MITIGATE OUR WILDFIRE ISSUES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE CALIFORNIA.
SO WHAT WE WANNA URGES THAT WE
CONTINUE TO KEEP AN OPEN MIND ON
THE RENEWAL PATHWAYS JUST AS WE
DO IN THE L. IN THE R. P. S. TO
CONTINUE TO DECARBONISE HYDROGEN
GOING FORWARD- SECOND. THE
NUMBERS A LOT NUMBERS BEING
THROWN AROUND A LOT OF PEOPLE
TALKING IN WARNING ABOUT COST.
JUST WANNA LEAVE THIS WITH YOU.
HYDROGEN ALSO TODAY IN A LIGHT
DUTY STATION AND WE EXPECT BIG
GREATER SPEED AT THE HEAVY DUTY
STATIONS COMING FORWARD. IS FOUR
TIMES GREATER THAN THE
THEORETICAL ONE MEGAWATT
CHARGER- THAT IS BEING DEVELOPED
FOR THE HEAVY DUTY CHARGING
SPACE. LIGHT DUTY HYDROGEN
VEHICLES RECEIVED A FOUR
MEGAWATT CHARGE ON EQUIVALENT
BASIS. AND WITH THE STATE
REBATE. WE ARE DELIVERING TEN
TIMES THE ENERGY TRANSFER AT 5%
OF THE STATE REMAKE COST. PER
KILOWATT. WE'RE JUST GETTING
PERFECTION AND- TESTING THESE
EQUIPMENT TODAY FIFTY IS NOT
ENOUGH TO CHIEF. KIND OF
PROFICIENCY WORK WORK GET URGENT
A CONTINUED INVEST IN THE SPACE.
BUT ALSO WE'RE VERY HOPEFUL THAT
FOR THAT WE DO THE SPACE IS A
SPACE WHERE HYDROGEN WILL
ABSOLUTELY. DOMINATE AND BRING
ZERO MISSION TO IT YOU KNOW THE
COMMUNITIES ARE AFFECTED BY PORT
TRAFFIC. AND UP AND DOWN OR
TRANSPORTATION INFREQUENT OURS
WITHOUT SACRIFICING WEIGHT. VMT
MATTERS EFFICIENCY FREIGHT
MOVEMENT MATTERS. THAT THERE ARE
OTHER TYPES OF EFFICIENCY AZAR
IS ALSO PRODUCTIVITY WE MUST
MAINTAIN PRODUCTIVITY ESPECIALLY
IN THIS COMMERCIAL PACES. SO TO
THAT END- WE'D LIKE TO FOLLOW UP
WITH SOME SOME MORE MATH SO YOU
GUYS CAN SEE THE NUMBERS BUT-
THE PREVIOUS TIME. THANK YOU AND
I DON'T SEE ANYONE ELSE HERE IN
THE ROOM TO TESTIFY SO WE'D LIKE
TO MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES
PLEASE IF. THE OPERATOR-
COMMITTEE OPEN UP THE- FOR ANY-
TESTIMONY REMOTELY. THANK YOU
FOR ANY PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE IN THE VIDEO FOR ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT. AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONLINE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
SORRY YOU'RE BREAKING UP ON A
SIR. THIS TIME WITH ART. YOU I'M
ABOUT MEDICARE. YEAH MAYBE SIR
IF YOU CAN HANG UP AND DIAL BACK
WE CAN'T HEAR YOU AT ALL SO
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO ANOTHER-
COLOR BUT PLEASE DO CALL BACK OR
SEND THIS TESTIMONY THROUGH OUR
WEBSITE. OKAY NEXT CALLER PLEASE
. THANK YOU AND WE WILL PER LINE
UP BY EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE EIGHTY
TWO I FIND IT FASCINATING THAT
SAMA TESTIMONY IS EXTENDED WHILE
OTHER TESTIMONY TENDS TO BE
CURTAILED. THAT BEING SAID
READING FROM A FORBES ARTICLE
ABOUT WHY ARE WE STILL TALKING
ABOUT HYDROGEN. ON THE SURFACE
HYDROGEN SOUNDS LIKE A WONDERFUL
FUEL. TO WATER WHICH IS HARDLY
GOING TO DESTROY THE ATMOSPHERE
WHAT REALLY WHAT REALLY APPEALS
TO PEOPLE IS THE FACT THAT YOU
CAN REFUEL HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
VEHICLE AND THE SAME KIND OF WAY
OF THE FOSSIL FUEL CAR. NO
LIFESTYLE CHANGES ARE NECESSARY
YOUR CAR WILL HAVE A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT ENGINE INSIDE BUT
UNLESS YOU ENJOY TINKERING WITH
ITS MECHANICALS YOU WON'T NOTICE
FROM DAY TODAY YOU CAN JUST HEAD
TO A FUEL STATION WHEN YOU NEED.
A FIVE MINUTE POP UP JUST LIKE
THE GOOD OLD DAYS HYDROGEN'S
INHERENT FLAW THE PROBLEM IS
THAT THIS CONVENIENCE HIDES A
SIGNIFICANT FLAW IN THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT HAS SOMEHOW
FAILED. TO BE INCLUDED IN THE
MARKETING PROPAGANDA OF HYDROGEN
AND VANGELIS. IT DOESN'T APPEAR
TO BE WIDELY UNDERSTOOD BY THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN LISTENING TO THE
MESSAGES EITHER THE FILE IS
BASICALLY BECAUSE BUT A LOT OF
PHYSICS. FOR HYDROGEN TO BE
COMPLETELY GREEN AND MUST BE
PRODUCED BY ELECTROLYTE AND
WATER WHICH SPLITS THIS INTO THE
H. TWO AND O. THAT IS MADE OF.
YOU CAN PRODUCE H. TWO FROM
COPPELL FUEL YOU USUALLY METHANE
BUT THIS CREATES EITHER GRAY
HYDROGEN WHICH STILL PRODUCES A
LOT OF CO TWO OR BLUE HYDROGEN
WHICH CAPTURES 90% OF THE CO TWO
AND STORE THAT MERELY DELAYING
THE PROBLEM. ONLY ELECTROLYTES
ZING HYDROGEN FROM WATER USUALLY
USING ELECTRICITY GENERATED FROM
RENEWABLE SOURCES MAKES THE FEEL
ENTIRELY GREEN. THIS IS AN
INEFFICIENT SYSTEM THAT WASTES
ENERGY AND I COULD GO ON AND ON
EVEN AS THE COLLAPSE
SUPERMAJORITY DIDN'T SUSPEND THE
GAS TAX TODAY. AND YOU PEOPLE
ARE SETTING UP THEIR PONTIFICATE
YOUR TIME IS UP OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU THAT A
COMPROMISED SEVENTY TWO YEAR
LINES OPEN. I GET AFTERNOON
THANK TURN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JANE JORDAN
WITH LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY- AND
TO THE EXTENT THAT CALIFORNIA'S
IN HYDROGEN WE WANTED TO- THAT
THAT INVESTMENT IS EXCLUSIVELY
IN HYDROGEN DRIVE FROM WIND OR
SOLAR ENERGY. IN PARTICULAR
WHERE WE URGE CALIFORNIA TO
AVOID INVESTING IN HYDROGEN
DERIVED FROM DAIRY BIOMETHANE
THE LIFE CYCLE IMPACTS OF THIS
PRODUCTION RESULTS AND
DEMONSTRATED HARMFUL IMPACTS ON
LOCALIZED AIR AND WATER QUALITY
PRIMARILY IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. JERRY BIOMETHANE HAS NO
PLACE IN OUR CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE
INCLUDING IN THE HYDROGEN THIS
SESSION AND SHOULD NOT BE
CONSIDERED A CLEAN SOURCE FOR
FUEL WHEN SURELY CLEAN OUT THE
ALTERNATIVES EXIST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER.
GIVE IT A COMPROMISED EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS REMEMBER PROVIDER ON
BEHALF OF UNIVERSAL HYDROGEN
UNIVERSAL HYDROGEN WAS FOUNDED
IN TWENTY TWENTY AND IS
HEADQUARTERED IN CALIFORNIA AND
IS BUILDING A CARBON FREE FUTURE
FOR AVIATION AND BELIEVE THAT
THERE ARE CARBON EMISSION
AVIATION IS ACHIEVABLE WITHIN
THAT DECADE. UNIVERSAL HOW
YOU'RE GONNA CURRENTLY
DEVELOPING THE TECHNOLOGY TO
ENABLE PLANES TO FLY USING
HYDROGEN FUEL CELLS INSTEAD OF
TRADITIONAL JET FUEL. AND YOU
MAY BE AWARE AVIATION IS ONE OF
THE HARDEST SECTORS TO
DECARBONISE IN ADDITION TO
WORKING ON THE POWER TRAIN THAT
CAN CONVERT HYDROGEN FUEL
ELECTRICITY UNIVERSAL HYDROGEN
IS ALSO DEVELOPING DEVELOPING
INNOVATIVE MODULAR CAPITAL TO
TRANSPORT GREEN HYDROGEN FROM
PRODUCTION SITES TO AIRPORT
USING EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE.
PROVIDES A SOLUTION TO ONE OF
THE HURDLES RAISING THE
COMMITTEE BACKGROUND MATERIAL
FOR HOW TO GET THE HYDROGEN TO
WHERE IT IS NEEDED YOU CAPITAL
WILL NOT BE LIMITED TO AVIATION
AND COULD BE USED IN LOTS OF
OTHER APPLICATIONS INCLUDING
PASSENGER AND HEAVY HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES. RAIL FERRIES AND AMONG
OTHERS REGARDING GREEN HYDROGEN
AS YOU HEARD FROM COMMISSIONER
HOOK SHIELD THE COST TO BRING
HYDROGEN ITS POTENTIALLY MORE
THAN GRAY OR BLUE HYDROGEN.
UNIVERSAL HYDROGEN IS COMMITTING
TO USING GREEN HYDROGEN BUT TO
MAKE THAT FEASIBLE THERE NEEDS
TO BE MORE PRODUCTION AND THE
COST OF GREEN HYDROGEN MUST COME
DOWN IF THE STATE IS COMMITTED
TO GREEN HYDROGEN OVER OTHER
TYPES OF HYDROGEN THEY NEED TO
BE INCENTIVES OR SUBSIDIES TO
REDUCE THE COST. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY PRIVATE PUBLIC
COMMENT THIS AFTERNOON ON BEHALF
OF UNIVERSAL HYDROGEN WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AT THE DISCUSSION
ESPECIALLY AROUND THAT THE
HYDROGEN HUB CONTINUE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU I COME LINE.
FIVE VELITE IS OPEN. I MY NAME
IS SARAH AND I'M FROM THE-
HYDROGEN BUSINESS CAN. THE
TALKING YOUR BUSINESS COUNCIL
AND TRANSPOSITION ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE NUMBERS
THAT OUR WAR ALL WORKING TO
COMMERCIALIZE THE HYDROGEN AND
ENERGY AND TRANSPORTATION BASIS-
I THOUGHT SITTING IN THE CHAIR
MEMBERS FOR HOLDING THAT'S-
GREAT INFORMATIONAL SESSION. AND
I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO START MY
COMMENTS BY SECONDING EVERYTHING
THAT A TREE TO COOK FROM THE TOP
AND HYGIENE COALITION HAD STATED
PREVIOUSLY- WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THOSE STATEMENTS. BUT IN
ADDITION I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT-
SOME COMMENTS MADE BY THE
CORPORATE FINANCE. ADVOCATING
FOR THE CARBON INTENSITY SCALE
IN ALL ASPECTS OF GETTING TOWARD
DECARBONIZATION GOALS- THIS IS
BC IS. THRILLED WITH LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD IN THE FACT IT
DOES USE THE CARBON INTENSITY
SCALE REALLY GET THE METRICS OF
HOW TO RETURN THE HARMONIZATION
GOALS- WE WOULD SUPPORT THAT
METHOD GOING FORWARD WITH ALL
EXPANSION OF HYDROGEN
ELIGIBILITY. FURTHER WE REALLY
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT. YOU KNOW A HUGE DISCUSSION
FOR HYDROGEN HEAVY DUTY WE HAVE
SO MANY HAVING TO REMEMBER THE
WE SUPPORT AS WELL HOW DID YOU
END UP AT THE STATE. AMENITY
SECTOR BUT ALSO THE STATE LIKE
ANY FACTOR WE REALLY CAN'T WRAP
MY HEAD AROUND THE FACT THAT
MANY OF THE CARDS THAT ARE
PLUGGING INTO THE GRID BECAUSE
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE DO PLUGINS.
ARE CUTTING INTEGRATED IS ON
AVERAGE ABOUT 33% RENEWABLE
WHEREAS ALL OF THE STATIONS THAT
ARE PART OF LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD BESIDES. SEVEN OR EIGHT
ARE IN OPERATION SO ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S HYDROGEN FILLING
STATIONS ARE ABOUT 90% RENEWABLE
ARE HIGHER AND I THINK OF THE
BABY REPORT THAT WAS PRODUCED
FROM CARD ITSELF. I DON'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND. THIS LARGE
CONFERENCE FOR. ELECTRIC VEHICLE
THAT'S HARD. ON A GRID THAT UP
30% AS COMPARED TO THE- FUEL
STATION. THAT ARE MATURE NINETY
PER MIDDLE OR HIGH. WHAT KIND OF
A WINNER LOSER HERE WE JUST
JERRY AND- YOUR TO PARITY IN
ADDRESSING THAT THE IS THE AND-
HOW TO RELATE TO GETTING RIGHT
INFO. FOR YOUR MUCH VEHICLES.
ARE GOING FOR. WHICH IS REALLY A
HER. CLICK TELL YOU DISCUSSION
AND NOT TO ONE OR THE THERE'S
LIKE HEALTH CAN'T ABOUT THREE
FOURTHS. THIRTY CREDIT. THANK
YOU YOUR TIME IS. UP NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. GET A COMPROMISE SEVENTY
YEAR IS OPEN. MMHM GOOD EVENING
GOOD AFTERNOON OF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND CHAIR- MY NAME IS
STEVE ROSENBLOOM ON A RESIDENT
OF PALO ALTO AND I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR AN INTERESTING
PROCESS THOSE SORT OF
INTERESTING PRESENTATIONS ON.
HYDROGEN AND IN OUR- FUTURE
ECONOMY- I'D LIKE TO REFOCUS
YOUR ATTENTION BACK ON THE
PRODUCTION AND THAT WAS
DISCUSSED IN DETAIL BY CHAIR
HOPE SHE'LL. AND MISTER SIEGEL
OF CARBON- AS WE ARE CHAIR HOPE
YOU POINTED OUT THE CHEAPEST
HYDROGEN IS MADE BY STEAM
REFORMING OF METHANE. BUT THAT
HAS A VERY HIGH CARBON INTENSITY
AND I THINK WE NEED TO FOCUS THE
PRODUCTION END OF THE PROCESS ON
CARBON INTENSITY AS THE S THE-
MAIN QUALIFICATION BECAUSE IF WE
WANT TO GET THE ZERO CARBON. NOW
WE WANT TO SAVE OUR CLIMATE THAT
HAS TO BE THE KEY METRIC- IF YOU
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS I HAVE
THERE'S A LOT OF DATA ON THIS
BUT- IT'S NOT AND YOU KNOW DO
NOT DOWN TO THE SINGLE DIGT
ACCURACY BUT- IF YOU LOOK AT THE
KILOGRAMS OF CARBON DIOXIDE
EQUIVALENT PER KILOGRAM OF
HYDROGEN PRODUCED. IN REFORMING
OF METHANE PRODUCES ABOUT TWELVE
KILOGRAMS OF CARBON DIOXIDE
EQUIVALENT. STEAM REFORMING WITH
CARBON CAPTURE IS IN THERE TWO
TO THREE KILOGRAM RANGE AND-
PRODUCTION BY ELECTROLYSIS OF
WATER IS IN APPROXIMATELY THE
ONE OR LESS KILOGRAM. ABOUT
CARBON DIOXIDE EQUIVALENT RANGE.
SO WE IN ORDER TO GET. TO THE
LOWEST POSSIBLE CARBON EMISSION
WE REALLY HAVE TO CONCENTRATE.
ON ON THE ELECTROLYSIS END OF
THE SPECTRUM FOR ALL ALL NEW
INVESTMENTS. AND I THINK THAT
HAS TO BE THE KEY THE KEY
QUALIFIER. AND I THINK AS CHAIR
FRIEDMAN ALLUDED TO. IT DURING
THE PRODUCTION PROCESS WHICH
INCLUDES THAT WHAT WE CALL
SCOPES ONE AND TWO. OF THE-
CARBON EMISSIONS PROCESS- THAT
THAT'S WHERE MOST OF THE
MISSIONS OCCUR BUT IN SCOPE
THREE WHERE THE END USER USES
THAT THERE COULD ALSO BE
INVOLVED. SO IT'S UNIQUE BUT I
REJECT WHICH NEED TO BE
CONSIDERED THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH- NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU THAT ARE FROM NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT YEAR LINE IS- OPEN
PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
JULIA LEVINS WITH A VIOLENT OR
TO YOUR SITUATION A CALIFORNIA I
WANT TO THANK BOTH COMMITTEES.
FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING HOW
BEEN REALLY INFORMATIVE AND IT'S
A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR
CALIFORNIA- TO TACKLE THE ROLE
OF HYDROGEN IN DECARBONIZING OUR
ENERGY FACTOR. WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE COMMENTS MADE BY
MCNAMARA FROM THE CONCERNED HIGH
HAS. AIRPORT REPRESENTED AND
SEVERAL OTHERS THAT IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THE CALIFORNIA LOOK AT
GREEN HYDROGEN OVER RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN LIFE CYCLE BASIS. NOT
JUST LOOK AT THE EMISSIONS FROM
ONE PART OF THE PRODUCTION
PROCESS BUT- THE ENTIRE WELL TO
WHEELS WELL TO. WHATEVER THAT'S
THE WHOLE LIFE CYCLE BASIS. AND
I THINK- THE REASON THIS IS
IMPORTANT WAS UNDERSCORED BY THE
AIRPORT PRESENTATION THE AIRPORT
FLIGHT NUMBER FOUR I REALLY URGE
ALL OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON
THE OTHER LISTENERS. TO TAKE
ANOTHER LOOK AT FIVE NUMBER
FORCING AIR RESOURCES BOARD
WHICH WHICH SHOWS A VERY WIDE
RANGE OF LIFE CYCLE CARBON
INTENSITY FOR DIFFERENT SOURCES.
IT ALSO UNDERSCORES THAT THE
ONLY FORM OF HYDROGEN THAT CAN
ACTUALLY BE CARBON NEGATIVE.
HYDROGEN THAT IS GENERATED FROM
ORGANIC WASTE. AND THAT'S
BECAUSE IT THAT CAN HELP TO
REDUCE METHANE EMISSIONS- THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE BE RELEASED BY
LANDFILLS OR BLACK CARBON
EMISSIONS IT WOULD EITHER BY
OTHERWISE BE RELEASED ON THE
OPEN BURNING OF AGRICULTURAL A
FOREST WASTE. WHEN YOU CONVERT
THAT ORGANIC WASTE TO HYDROGEN
INSTEAD YOU CAN PROVIDE CARBON.
NEGATIVE POWER. CAN ORGANICALLY
TOO HIGH IS ALSO WAITING REDUCE
SHORT LIVED POLLUTANT
COUNTERFEITING THE MANSION SHE'D
BEEN AT THE KLASKO CONFERENCE. I
THINK THAT CONFERENCE
UNDERSCORED VERY VERY STRONGLY
THAT THE MOST URGENT THING WE
CAN DO TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGES TO REDUCE SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS. IT IS THE
ONLY THING THAT ACTUALLY
BENEFITS THE CLIMATE RIGHT AWAY
AND AT SCALE. BOTH PRESIDENT
BIDEN AND THE HEAD OF THE UNITED
NATIONS ENVIRONMENT PROGRAM SHE-
SAID THAT THE MOST URGENT THING
YOU CAN DO IN THE NEXT TEN TO
TWENTY FIVE YEARS. TO ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE IS TO REDUCE
SHORT LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS
SHOW. ME TWO RECOMMENDATIONS
NUMBER ONE. OUR DEFINITION BASED
ON LIFE CYCLE EMISSIONS. AND
NUMBER TWO ORGANIC WASTE SHOULD
BE INCLUDED AS AN ELIGIBLE
FEEDSTOCK FOR GREEN HYDROGEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND AGAIN I WILL REMIND PEOPLE
THAT YOU- WELCOME TO SEND
MATERIAL TO US BECAUSE THEN YOU
CAN GET MORE OF YOUR THOUGHTS
AND SUGGESTIONS OUT THERE AND WE
WILL ABSOLUTELY DISTRIBUTE THEM
TO THE COMMITTEES. OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. YOUR THAT A
COMPROMISE SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR CONVENING THIS
HEARING MY NAME IS WAYNE LEVY ON
COMMERCIAL HEAD FOR HYDROGEN
MOBILITY AT SHELL I ALSO
COMPLETED GRADUATE STUDY AT UC
DAVIS IN TWENTY TEN IN THE
TRANSPORTATION TECHNOLOGY AND
POLICY PROGRAM STUDYING THESE
TRANSITIONS THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING TODAY AND I'M WORKING
HARD TO DELIVER. AT SHELL WE'RE
DEVELOPING THE FULL RANGE OF%
DECARBONIZE FUELS IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING CHARGING A BATTERY
ELECTRIC AND FUELING OF HYDROGEN
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
SO AS WE DO THIS THROUGH
OPPORTUNITIES COMPETING FOR
INVESTMENT WE DEVELOP AN
OBJECTIVE VIEW OF MARKETS AND
CUSTOMER SEGMENTS. FOR WHOM EACH
TECHNOLOGY IS AND WILL WORK WELL
SO FROM THIS PERSPECTIVE MAY I
PLEASE SUGGEST THREE POINTS FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION FIRST THE
OPENING FRAME IN THE BACKGROUND
PAPER NEEDS APPROPRIATE CARE
PARAPHRASING. TO FOCUS ON THE
MOST COST EFFECTIVE TECHNOLOGIES
AVAILABLE AT THE TIME COULD RISK
LOSING PROGRESS ON THE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE BECOMING
COST EFFECTIVE AND AVAILABLE
WHERE WOULD WE BE TODAY IF SOLAR
PANELS AND BEV'S HAD THIS
APPROACH TWENTY TWENTY YEARS
AGO. THERE'S NOW A TREMENDOUS
PACE OF PROGRESS IN HYDROGEN
FUELING AT SHELL WE'VE DOUBLED
THE CAPACITY WHILE HAVING COST.
TWICE ALREADY IN THE STATIONS.
SECOND POINT TRAINING THAT
BATTERY ELECTRIC VEHICLES ARE
MORE EFFICIENT THAN ALSO
ELECTRIC VEHICLES SHOULD BE
COMPLEMENTED WITH AN
UNDERSTANDING OF ENERGY SYSTEMS
LIKE WE TALKED ABOUT TODAY. THE
OPPORTUNITY WITH HYDROGEN TO
MAKE USE OF RENEWABLE MOLECULAR
ENERGY FEEDSTOCKS FOR A CIRCULAR
ECONOMY LIKE AGRICULTURAL AND
FORESTRY WASTE. IN COMPLEMENT
RENEWABLE POWER GENERATION AND
PRODUCING HYDROGEN BY
ELECTROLYSIS CAN MOVE STRANDED
NOBLE POWER IN TIME AND SPACE TO
ITS HIGHEST VALUE IN
TRANSPORTATION. THOSE CAN HELP
ENABLE THE AFFORDABLE AND
RESILIENT RENEWABLE POWER AND
BEV CHARGING GOALS THAT WE HAVE.
WE FIND CALIFORNIA IS WELL
INFORMED AND CONSTRUCTIVE IN ITS
FOCUS ON THE OUTCOMES OF
RENEWABLE FEEDSTOCKS AND CARBON
INTENSITY. AT SHALL WE FIRST
TOLD A 100% RENEWABLE HYDROGEN
IN THE THIRD QUARTER OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND WE GOT TO ZERO
CARBON INTENSITY IN THE THIRD
QUARTER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TIME IS UP AS WELL FINALLY.
CAUGHT THE GREAT NEWS COLOR US
NEXT COLOR PLEASE. THANK YOU.
WHITE EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. OUR
COMMUNITY. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
GO AHEAD. GREAT THANKS SO MUCH
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS WOODY
HASTINGS ON THE ENERGY PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR THE CLIMATE TURNER-
AND THANK YOU FR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK- MY
COMMENTS ARE ALSO ON THE
PRODUCTION SIDE- WE'VE CLIMATE
CENTER. I FEEL STATE INVESTMENT
OF PUBLIC DOLLARS SHOULD FOCUS
ON BRINGING THE COSTS DOWN OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY BASED
ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN- WE DO SEE
THAT IS THE KEY TO MAKING
HYDROGEN A TRULY- ARE TRULY ARE
CLEAN FUEL INTO THE PRODUCTION
AND WHERE THAT COMES INTO PLAY
WE DO SHARE CONCERNS EXPRESSED
BY. JORDAN FROM THE LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL ABOUT THE USE OF BIOMASS
ENERGY AND WE DO FEEL WITH NO
PUBLIC DOLLARS SHOULD GO TO-
CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE
APPLICATION AT FOSSIL GAS- FROM
RICK WE FORMATION PRODUCTION
SYSTEMS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR STAYING
WITHIN THE TIME LIMIT THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU BETTER
COME FROM LINE EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE AND- BOTH
SHARES- MY NAME IS BRADY
BORDERING WITH FUEL CELL ENERGY
OR A CONNECTICUT BASED
MANUFACTURER OF STATIONARY FUEL
CELLS. THAT PRODUCE BOTH
ELECTRICITY AND HYDROGEN- WE'RE
ACTUALLY BUILDING RIGHT NOW THE
BY THE PORT OF LONG BEACH A
PROJECT THAT WILL PRODUCE A TWO
POINT THREE MEGAWATTS OF GREEN
POWER UNDER THE BIO MAT TERRACE.
AND BY TWELVE HUNDRED KILOGRAMS
OF GREEN HYDROGEN TODAY
PATTERSON WILL BE USED TO FUEL
TOYOTA VEHICLES. AND CLASS EIGHT
TRUCKS AT THE PORT OF LONG BEACH
AND WE'RE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
THIS PROJECT. AT THE COUNTRY'S
MANKER INFRASTRUCTURE TO
DECARBONISE THE SEVEN TEN
CORRIDOR AND THE TRADE QUARTER
AFTER THE ON A FIRE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY HAVING MANY
BEYOND TO THE PROJECT YOU SEE IT
FOR YOURSELF THANKS SO MUCH
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU I EIGHTEEN YELLOW IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD
AFTERNOON- JIM HOLLY LAWRENCE
BERKELEY NATIONAL LABORATORY. OF
BOTH LAWRENCE BERKELEY LAB LAB
IN UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA OUR
NATIONAL LEADERS IN HYDROGEN
TECHNOLOGY COLLECTIVELY WE ARE
INTERESTED IN HELPING CALIFORNIA
NGUYEN. SIGNIFICANT HYDROGEN
FUNDING IN THE FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL AND
DEVELOPING A STRATEGY THE BEST
ACCELERATES ACHIEVEMENTS OF OUR
CLIMATE GOALS. A PARTIAL
HIGHLIGHT OF OUR RESEARCH
INCLUDES THAT WE CO LEAD THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY'S MILLION
MILE FUEL CALL CAR CONSORTIUM-
TO ENABLE WIDESPREAD
COMMERCIALIZATION AND EFFICIENT
DURABLE FUEL CELLS. THAT WITH
THE GOAL OF SYSTEMS THAT CAN
POWER A LONG HAUL TRUCK FOR ONE
MILLION MILES. WE FEEL FUEL
CELLS CAN BE ESPECIALLY VALUABLE
FOR HEAVY DUTY IN POLICE
OPERATIONS BECAUSE FUNDING
FILLING STATIONS CAN BE
CONCENTRATED AT FEWER LOCATIONS
THAN WILL BE NEEDED FOR
PASSENGER VEHICLES. SUCH A LONG
FREQUENTLY TRAVELED A LONG HAUL
TRUCK QUARTERS. BERKELEY LAB IS
ALSO A CO DEPUTY OF THE
DEPARTMENT ENERGY EFFORT TO
LOWER. THE COST OF ELECTROLYZER
. THEIR QUEUE TO A CAN ATROCITY
DEGREE HIGH. DELETE HELPS THIS A
GOAL TO RID. THE COST OF IB BY
EIGHTY PER FROM FIVE DOLLARS TO
ONE KILOGRAM TWO ONE DOLLAR PER
KILOGRAM THE BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL WILL SPEND A
BILLION DOLLARS ON THIS. THIS IS
IN ADDITION TO THE MONEY FOR THE
HYDROGEN HUBS WE BELIEVE THE
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR THIS EASY
TO SUPPORT ELECTROLYSIS. IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO KEEP IN
CALIFORNIA ON THE CUTTING EDGE.
BUT AGAIN I JUST WANT TO SAY THE
UC AND LAWRENCE BERKELEY LAB ARE
VERY INTERESTED IN WORKING WITH
THIS COMMITTEE. TO WHEN
SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
CALIFORNIA AND ADVENTURE
CLINICALS THANK. YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
THAT I COME FROM NINE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS ASSIGNMENT-
JUSTICE CAN YOU HEAR ME ALRIGHT
YES. GREAT THANK YOU- I WANTED
TO PURCHASE FONG QUICKLY TOOK A
GOOD QUESTION I HEARD FROM- THE
CHAIR THAT YOU KNOW WHY ARE WE
WHY ARE WE ADDING SO MUCH
SCRUTINY ON HYDROGEN AND I JUST
WANT TO GROUND THAT'S PERSON
THAT. AND THE FACT OF THE STATUS
QUO THAT 99% OF HYDROGEN TODAY
IS FROM THE FAUPEL BASED ECONOMY
THAT THE GAS INDUSTRY IS THE
NUMBER ONE PRODUCER OF HYDROGEN
IN THE OIL INDUSTRY IS THE
NUMBER ONE CONSUMER. AND IT IS
NOW WELL WELL DOCUMENTED FACT
THAT THE OIL SUPER MAJOR ISSUE
FOR DECADES DENIED THE REALITY
OF CLIMATE CHANGE I THINK THE
DUPLICATING OUTSTANDING MEMBERS
OF MOST OF THE HYGIENE TRADE
ASSOCIATION. THE CURRENT CENTER
BEING THAT YOU CAN SUBTYPING
CLIMATE FUNDING TOWARDS AWFUL
DRY FUELS WHAT TIME OPINION
PLEASE FOLLOWING THE TRANSITION
UNDER. WAY TO ELECTRIFICATION-
PROBABLY MORE IN. SO THAN WE
JUST SPOKE ON THE- THAT THE CVS.
I REPLY. HAS ALREADY FOUND THE
CALIFORNIA HAS. INVESTED IN
INFRASTRUCTURE TO THE TUNE TO
SUPPORT. TWENTY FIVE TIMES THE
NUMBER OF FUELING STATIONS. WE
NEED FOR THE NUMBER OF HYDROGEN
CARS ON THE ROAD. SO IT'S REALLY
TIME TO STOP SANCTIONING
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC INVESTMENT.
TOWARD THIS VASTLY UNDER
UTILIZED FUELING NETWORK. GIVEN
THAT WERE FAR OFF TRACK BUILDING
ENOUGH CHARGING STATIONS TO KEEP
UP WITH THE SURGING DVDFAB. AND
ALMOST ALL THE HYDROGEN WE
DISPENSED A THOUGHTFUL DERIVED.
AND THE CLEAN THE LTFS SHIFTED
UP TOWARDS RENEWABLE HYDROGEN IS
DEMONSTRABLY FALSE. VIRTUALLY
ALL OF THE HYGIENIC CALIFORNIA
THAT'S CLAIMED TO BE RENEWABLE.
COMES FROM POSSIBLE DRUG CHARGES
CHEN SHARED WITH THE PURCHASE OF
BIO GAS CREDIT. IT'S NOT EVEN
PRODUCE FROM ACTUAL BIOGAS IT'S
JUST FROM BOTTLE GOD. WITH THE
COUPLING OF CREDITS LANDFILLS IN
INDIANA. OR FACTORY FARMS IN
MISSISSIPPI. AND IT'S NOT JUST
CARD THAT ARE ID. BATTERY
ELECTRIC TRUCKS ARE UNDERSTOOD
BE THE MOST STRAIGHTFORWARD
TASK. TO DECARBONISE ALMOST ALL
OF ROAD TRANSPORT. PERSONAL 80%
OF TRUCKS RUN LESS THAN ONE
HUNDRED MILES WHICH IS EASILY
ACHIEVABLE FOR BATTERY TRUCKS.
THAT ARE ALREADY ON THE MARKET
YOUR TIME IS NOT FIVE YEARS NPE
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU THANK YOU- IS THERE ANOTHER
CALLER OPERATOR. BUT I'M SURE
THERE IS NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WELL I WANT TO
ESPECIALLY THANK THE PUBLIC FOR
THEIR PARTICIPATION I'M REALLY
I'M SURPRISED THAT WE HAD SO
MUCH PUBLIC- TESTIMONY TODAY AND
VERY VERY GLAD TO HEAR THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION AND- AND WE
GOT THE GIST OF ALL THE CALLS
EVEN IF WE DIDN'T. YOU KNOW YOU
DIDN'T HAVE LIKE YOU KNOW TEN
MINUTES TALK ABOUT IT I THINK WE
GOT WE GOT YOUR POINT SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- I DO THINK THAT
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION FOR US TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE. AS WE SEE THE
INVESTMENTS THAT THE STATE IS
MAKING CERTAIN THE INVESTMENT
FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR IN THE
INTEREST IN HYDROGEN TECHNOLOGY
AND- TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THE
BEST PATH FORWARD TO
DECARBONISING. OF NOT JUST A%
TRANSPORTATION BUT ANYTHING THAT
IS PRODUCING CARBON IT'S AT ADD
IN MASS AMOUNTS- IT VARIOUS
INDUSTRIES AND TRANSPORTATION
BEING ONE OF THE- THE BIGGEST
ONES- THIS IS THE MOMENT YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE SEE THE VOLATILITY
OF GAS PRICES WE SEE THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN- AND IT'S-
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT'S NOT
NEW BUT THE- THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN. REALLY BAD- ACTORS
AROUND THE GLOBE- IN THE OIL
INDUSTRY AND THE CONNECTION TO
GAS PRICES HERE AT HOME EVERY
TIME- WE ENTER INTO ANY KIND OF
A- FRIGHTENING GEOPOLITICAL.
EVENTS LIKES HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW. A WE NEED TO HAVE ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE AND THAT NEEDS TO
BE CLEAN ENERGY IT CANNOT BE
FOSSIL FUELS IT'S GOT TO BE.
ZERO EMISSION FUELS. AND SO I
THINK THAT THIS IS AN EXCITING
AREA BUT ONE OF COURSE THAT WE
NEED TO. MAKE SURE THAT AS WE
MOVE INTO IT WE DON'T JUST
REPLACE ONE POLLUTING FUEL WITH
ANOTHER- SO THERE'S A LOT OF
POTENTIAL HERE BUT YOU KNOW
WE'RE CALIFORNIA AND IF WE DO
HYDROGEN WE'RE GOING TO DO IT
RIGHT AND THAT'S WHAT THESE
HEARINGS ARE ALL ABOUT. SO I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION WE WILL CONTINUE
TO HAVE THIS DISCUSSION GOING
FORWARD AND I. WANT TO TURN IT
OVER TO MY CULTURE THREE OF US
FROM NATURAL RESOURCES. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- AND TO YOUR
TEAM FOR ORGANIZING. THIS
HEARING TO ALL THE PARTICIPANTS
THE PANELISTS. AND THE PUBLIC I
LEARNED SO MUCH TODAY AND- I
AGREE THAT THIS IS THE RIGHT
TIME TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION-
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO MORE- IN
THE FUTURE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE ARE ADJOURNED.